ALLEN ARCHULETA OR ATKINS BATES.
WELL FOR JUST BRADFORD CABRERA
CHIANG DALLY DODD TO RUSSELL
GALGIANI GLAZER GONZALEZ ROSE
HERTZBERG HILL. HUESO TADO
JACKSON JONES LEYVA MCGUIRE
MELINDA'S MITCHELL MONNING
MORLOCK MORALE NIELSEN PAN
PORTANTINO ROTH RUBIO SKINNER
STERN AMBERG MY CASKEY WIENER
WILK. MEMBERS A QUORUM IS
PRESENT. WITH THE MEMBERS AND
OUR GUESTS BE ON THE RAIL AND
IN THE GALLERY PLEASE RISE WE
READ LEAD IN PRAYER THIS
MORNING BY SENATOR ARCHULETA
AFTER WHICH PLEASE REMAIN
STANDING WE WILL BE LED IN THE
PLEDGE OF ALLEGIANCE TO THE
FLAG BY SENATOR GONZALEZ.
CENTERS WHERE YOU PLEASE BOW
YOUR HEADS. THIS PRAYER WAS
GIVEN TO ME BY GEN PHILLIPS.
AND SHE ASKED ME TO READ IT
TODAY. THE DALAI LAMA. ADMITS
THAT HIS RELIGION IS HUMAN
KINDNESS. THAT MAKES IT EASY
NOTHING TO MEMORIZE NOTHING TO
ARGUE OVER NOTHING TO DIE FOR
JUST ONE SIMPLE PRACTICE TO
NOTICE THAT WE LIVE IN A WORLD
THAT TRIES TO KEEP IS DIVIDED.
AND DO EVERYTHING IN OUR POWER
TO RECONNECT WHAT WE SEE
CORNICE ASUNDER. GREAT LOVE
LISTEN TO OUR HEARTS LONGING
FOR THE HEALING OF OUR WORLD
KNOWINGLY YOU ARE HERE IN US
BETTER THAN WE ARE SPEAKING.
OFFER THESE PRAYERS IT ALL THE
HOLY NAMES A TRIBUTE TO YOU A
MAP. IT WILL YEAH. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH PRIVILEGES OF THE
FLOOR. THERE ARE NONE MESSAGES
FROM THE GOVERNOR WILL BE
DEEMED READ. MESSAGES FROM THE
ASSEMBLY WILL BE DEEMED READ.
REPORTS OF COMMITTEES WILL BE
DEEMED READ AND AMENDMENTS
ADOPTED. MOVING ON TO MOTIONS
RESOLUTIONS AND NOTICES. THE
FOLLOWING BILLS ARE REFERRED TO
THE RULES COMMITTEE ITEM NUMBER
ONE SB THIRTEEN EIGHTY THREE
AND ITEM NUMBER TWO AB SIX ZERO
NINE. PURSUANT TO SENATE RULE
TWENTY NINE POINT B. ARE
REFERRED TO THE RULES COMMITTEE
ITEM NUMBER THREE AB ONE SIXTY
EIGHT. MEMBERS WE'RE GOING TO
MOVE ON TO THE CONSIDERATION OF
THE DAILY FILE. SECOND READING
FILE ITEMS ONE THROUGH THREE
MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE READ.
SENATE BILL THIRTEEN EIGHTY
THREE ASSEMBLY BILL SIX OH NINE
AND ASSEMBLY BILL ONE SIXTY
EIGHT. MEMBERS WITHOUT
OBJECTION WE WILL MOVE TO
ASSEMBLY THIRD READING. UNDER
ASSEMBLY THIRD READING ITEM
NUMBER SEVENTY NINE SENATOR
MITCHELL. ARE YOU PREPARED SHE
IS PLEASE READ. THEY SAY FIVE
TO SEVEN IS ON BOARD. I JUST
STOOD UP. TO THE PEOPLE YEAH
POWER TO THE PEOPLE.
WE'LL TRY
THAT AGAIN IT'S FILE NUMBER
SEVENTY NINE BY- PLEASE READ.
ASSEMBLY CONSTITUTIONAL
AMENDMENT FIVE BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER WEBER AN ACT RELATING TO
GET MEANT PREFERENCES SENATOR
MITCHELL THE FLOOR IS YOURS
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MADAM
PRESIDENT GOOD MORNING
COLLEAGUES. UNFORTUNATELY I
HAVE NOTED THERE'S BEEN QUITE A
BIT OF MISINFORMATION WHENEVER
THE TOPIC OF AFFIRMATIVE ACTION
IS BROUGHT UP. SO I WANT TO
FRAME OUR CONVERSATION TODAY IN
SOME BASIC FACTS. ACCORDING TO
DATA PROVIDED BY CALTRANS
DURING THE NINETEEN EIGHTIES
AND EARLY NINETIES WHEN EQUAL
OPPORTUNITY PROGRAMS WERE
WIDELY UTILIZED AWARDS TO
BUSINESSES OWNED BY PEOPLE OF
COLOR AND WOMEN ROSE TO A HIGH
OF 28% IN NINETEEN NINETY FOUR.
FOLLOWING THE PASSAGE OF PROP
TWO OH NINE AWARDS FAILED TO
UNDER 10% BY NINETEEN NINETY
NAY. AND HAVE NEVER RECOVERED.
A DISPARITY STUDY PUBLISHED IN
TWENTY TWO THOUSAND SEVEN. WELL
THE SAYS TO COMPARE THE RATES
OF DISPARITY FOR FEDERAL AND
STATE CALTRANS AWARDS. GIVEN
THE CALTRANS STILL MANAGES A
FEDERAL EQUAL OPPORTUNITY
PROGRAM YOU WOULD EXPECT A
MODEST DISPARITY BETWEEN THE
TWO PROGRAMS. IN ACTUALITY THE
DISPARITY RATE BETWEEN THE TWO
PROGRAMS IS TWO TO THREE TIMES
HIGHER FOR STATE AWARDS.
COLLEAGUES THERE IS CLEARLY
REDUCED OPPORTUNITY FOR PEOPLE
OF COLOR AND WOMEN OWNED
BUSINESSES THAT. THROUGH THE
DATA CAN BE DIRECTLY ATTRIBUTED
TO THE PASSAGE OF PROP TWO OH
NINE. THE DISPARITIES ARE FELT
EVEN DEEPER IN HIGHER EDUCATION
PARTICULARLY THE UC SYSTEM
WIENER ACCORDING TO THE DATA.
FROM THE EDUCATION TRUST WES IN
TWENTY EIGHTEEN NINETEEN THE
TWELFTH GRADE IN A ROMAN OF
BLACK AND LET NEXT STUDENTS. 6%
AND 53% EFFECTIVELY. YET THE UC
NEW FRESHMEN ROMAN FOR THE FALL
OF TWENTY NINETEEN WAS 4% BLACK
AND 25% LET NEXT A STARK
DIFFERENCE. AS YOU GO BACK YEAR
BY YEAR YOU SEE A SIMILAR TREND
THAT IS TRACED BACK TO THE
YEARS FOLLOWING PASSAGE OF PROP
TWO OH NINE. IN FACT THOSE
NUMBERS IN TWENTY NINETEEN- UP
SIGNIFICANTLY FROM THE FIRST.
DECADE AFTER THE PASSAGE INTO A
NINE WHEN DOLE'S NUMBERS WERE
HALF BUT THEY ARE TODAY. AGAIN
IN ORDER TO BRACKET OUR
DISCUSSION OF A CA FIVE I WANT
US TO BE VERY CLEAR ABOUT THE
CONTEXT OF ITS NECESSITY. FOR
NEARLY TWENTY FIVE YEARS
PROPOSITION TWO OH NINE HAS
BLINDED OUR LAWS AND
INSTITUTIONS TO THEBAY AREA
AIR SPACE BY WOMEN AND PEOPLE
OF COLOR. NOT A COLOR BLIND. IN
ONE THE COLLECTIVE ACTIONS WE
HAVE SEEN AROUND THE WORLD
REPRESENT AN URGENT CALL FOR
SYSTEMIC CHANGE AND IT'S TIME
FOR A NEW GENERATION OF
CALIFORNIA VOTERS THE STAND UP.
AN OLD TIME ON THEIR
PERSPECTIVE ON WHAT'S FAIR AND
JUST AND WHAT EQUITY LOOKS LIKE
FROM THEIR PERSPECTIVE. WE
CANNOT SOLVE PROBLEMS WE CHOOSE
NOT TO SEE. I STRONGLY URGE
YOUR SUPPOT FOR A FEE A FIVE.
SENATOR WIENER. I THANK YOU
MADAM PRESIDENT ON I RISE IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF A CA FIVE.
CALIFORNIA IS A VERY
PROGRESSIVE STATE AND WE HAVE A
LONG HISTORY OF BEING AHEAD OF
THE CURVE ON MANY MANY
PROGRESSIVE CHANGES.
UNFORTUNATELY HOWEVER FROM TIME
TO TIME CALIFORNIA LEADS IN A
BAD WAY IN A REGRESSIVE WAY IN
A WAY THAT HARMS. JUSTICE AND
EQUITY AND UFORTUNATELY
REPEATEDLY IN OUR CONSTITUTION
I'M PROP TWO OH NINE HAPPENED
IN A CONTEXT IN CALIFORNIA'S
CONSTITUTION ON MULTIPLE
OCCASIONS THIS STATE HAS
INSERTED. VERY REGRET OF AND AT
TIMES RACIST XENOPHOBIC
HOMOPHOBIC PROVISIONS INTO OUR
CONSTITUTION THESE ARE SCARS ON
OUR CONSTITUTION CALIFORNIA.
HIM FIFTY. BUT IN ORDER THIRTY
FOUR WHICH WAS DESIGNED TO
UNDER MY PUBLIC HOUSING TO KEEP
BLACK PEOPLE ON LOW INCOME
PEOPLE OUT OF WHITE
NEIGHBORHOODS. CALIFORNIA DID
IT BY IN. PROP ONE EIGHTY SEVEN
TO SEND A POWERFUL AND I GET A
MESSAGE THAT IMMIGRANTS ARE NOT
TO CALIFORNIANS. CALIFORNIA DID
IT BY PASSING CROP AIDS WHAT
SIGNAL TO MY COMMUNITY THE
LGBTQ COMMUNITY THAT WE AS WELL
WE'RE NOT FULL CALIFORNIANS.
CALIFORNIA DID IT BY PASSING
PROP TWO OH NINE THE SIGNALED A
CALIFORNIA NOT FULLY COMMITTED
TO WRITING PAST WRONGS WRONGS
GOING BACK HUNDREDS OF YEARS
AND I CALIFORNIA WAS NOT TRULY
COMMITTED. TO EMBRACING DIVERSE
MAKES THIS STATE WHAT IT IS.
PROP TWO OH NINE LIGHT PROPERTY
LIKE ARTICLE THIRTY FOUR LIGHT
PROP ONE EIGHTY SEVEN IS A TRUE
DEEP SCAR ON OUR STATE AND ON
OUR STATE CONSTITUTION IT IS
TIME TO REMOVE THAT'S- TO
REPEAT PROP TWO OH NINE. AND I
URGE AN IDOL ONE EIGHT FIVE
THANK YOU. SENATOR GONZALEZ.
SENATOR ARCHULETA. THANK YOU
MADAM PRESIDENT I RISE TODAY IN
SUPPORT OF AC A FIVE OUR
DIVERSITY IS OUR STRENGTH AND
TO IGNORE THAT WOULD BE TO
IGNORE THE VERY PEOPLE WE'RE
HERE TO SERVER PRESENT. WHEN WE
TAKE THIS VOTE TODAY WE MUST
RECOGNIZE THAT PEOPLE OF COLOR
AND WOMEN. WERE THE ONES WHO
WERE IMPACTED BY PROPOSITION
TWO OH NINE. AND THAT WE AS A
STATE ARE BETTER. WHEN WE AND
OUR CLASSROOMS. OUR WORKPLACES
AND OUR LEADERS REFLECT WHAT
ARE COMMUNITIES LOOKED LIKE. AS
A BODY WE HAVE A RESPONSIBILITY
SET AN EXAMPLE AND MUST TAKE
THIS NECESSARY STEP FORWARD
TOGETHER AS A UNIT. TODAY WE
DECIDE IF THE VOTERS WILL HAVE
THE OPPORTUNITY TO USE THEIR
VOICE ON THIS IMPORTANT MEASURE.
THE BORDERS SHALL COME TOGETHER
AND SPEAK. I URGE MY COLLEAGUES
TO GIVE OUR CONSERVE OUR
CONSTITUENTS THAT CHANCE WITH
THAT I RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR
AYE VOTE. ON A CD FIVE THANK
YOU. SENATOR HERTZBERG. MADAM
PRESIDENT. YEAH ME ON. ONE OF
THE GREAT JUSTICES OF THE
UNITED STATES SUPREME COURT WAS
A GENTLEMAN. BY THE NAME OF
THURGOOD MARSHALL. WANTED TO
THE SUPREME COURT BY PRESIDENT
JOHNSON. FORTY TWO YEARS AGO
ALMOST TO TODAY. ON JUNE TWENTY
EIGHTH NINETEEN SEVENTY EIGHT.
HE OPINED IN A VERY FAMOUS CASE
CALLED THE REGENTS OF THE
UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA VERSUS
BAKI. HE AGREED IN PART AND
DISSENTING IN PART I JUST WANT
TO READ TWO PARAGRAPHS THAT I
FIND. FOUND IS IT INSPIRATION
THOSE DAYS AS A YOUNG LAW
STUDENT AND TODAY I WAS A
SENATOR ON THIS. HE SAID. I
AGREE WITH THE JUDGMENT OF THE
COURT ONLY IN SO FAR AS PERMITS
THE UNIVERSITY TO CONSIDER THE
RACE OF AN APPLICANT IN MAKING
ADMISSIONS DECISIONS IF YOU
REMEMBER THIS CASE INVOLVED
MEDICAL SCHOOL THE UNIVERSITY
OF CALIFORNIA DAVIS. I DO NOT.
BE THE PETITIONS ADMISSIONS
PROGRAM VIOLATES THE
CONSTITUTION. FOR IT MUST IT
MUST BE REMEMBERED THAT DURING
THE MOST OF THE PAST TWO
HUNDRED YEARS THE CONSTITUTION
AS INTERPRETED BY THE COURT DID
NOT. DID NOT PROHIBIT THE MOST
INGENIOUS AND PERVASIVE FORMS
OF DISCRIMINATION AGAINST
AFRICAN AMERICANS NOW WHEN THE
STATE TAX TO REMEDY THE EFFECTS
OF THAT LEGIT BECAUSE SEE OF
DISCRIMINATION. I CANNOT
BELIEVE THAT THE SAME
CONSTITUTION STANDS AS A
BARRIER. HE WENT ON GOING TO
THE HISTORY IN A VERY ELOQUENT
WAY AND ENDED WITH ONE OTHER
QUOTE THAT I WANT TO USE AND I
WILL STAND DOWN AS SOON AS I
FIND THAT. HE SAYS. IN LIGHT OF
MY GLASSES. THREE MEN PRESIDENT.
IN LIGHT OF THE STORY HISTORY
OF DISCRIMINATION AND IT'S
DEVASTATING IMPACTS ON THE
LIVES OF AFRICAN AMERICANS
BRING THE AFRICAN AMERICANS TO
THE MAINSTREAM OF AMERICAN LIFE
SHOULD BE A STATE INTEREST OF
THE HIGHEST ORDER TO FAIL TO DO
SHOW IS TO ENSURE THAT AMERICAN
WILL FOREVER REMAIN DIVIDED
SOCIETY. TRUTHIS THE TRUTH AND
THAT IS THAT THERE ARE. THE
POINTS MADE BY THE- BUDGET
CHAIR TODAY AND THAT THIS. IN
THIS VERY CHALLENGING HISTORY
THAT WE HAVE FACE TO IN THE UPS
AND DOWNS OF THIS. REMAINS THE
SAME UNDERLYING ARCHITECTURE OF
A CONSTITUTIONAL PRINCIPLE THAT
THURGOOD MARSHALL TO ABOUT
FORTY TWO YEARS AGO. AND WE
TODAY SHOULD AMEND OUR
CONSTITUTION TO CONFORM
ACCORDING. I ASKED FOR AN AYE
VOTE. SENATOR PORTANTINO. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT
AND MEMBERS- I RISE IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF ACA FIVE- AND I
COMPLIMENT MY COLLEAGUE FROM
LOS ANGELES FOR HER PASSIONATE
COMMENTS AND APPROPRIATE
COMMENTS. IN EARLY TWO
THOUSANDS WHEN I WAS
CAMPAIGNING FOR THE STATE
ASSEMBLY I MET WITH A GENTLEMAN
NAMED JOE HOPKINS. WHO WROTE
THE LOCAL BLACK NEWSPAPER IN MY
DISTRICT STILL GOING STRONG
AFTER FORTY YEARS. HE TOOK OFF
HIS EDITORIALS OVER THE FIRST
TWENTY FIVE YEARS OF HIS PAPER
VITAMIN A BOOK. AND I READ THE
BOOK AND EVERY THREE MONTHS.
THERE WAS A REOCCURRING THEME
IS TWENTY FIVE YEARS OF
EDITORIALS. WHY DOES IN
CALIFORNIA WHICH SUCH A RICH
EDUCATION HISTORY. DO MORE FOR
BLACK STUDENTS. WHY DOES IN
CALIFORNIA WITH THE GREATEST
UNIVERSITIES IN THE COUNTRY. DO
MORE FOR BLACK HIGH SCHOOL
SENIORS AND MAKE THEM FEEL
WELCOME. ON ITS CAMPUSES ANYONE
ON FOR TWENTY FIVE YEARS HIS
PLEASE. FOR CALIFORNIA TO DO
MORE. FOR BLACK STUDENTS
THROUGHOUT OUR STATE SO I SAT
DOWN WITH THEM AND I SAID. IF I
GO TO THE ASSEMBLY I WANT TO DO
SOMETHING I WANT TO HELP I READ
YOUR BOOK. AND YOUR XIN NEEDS
TO BE ANSWERED IN SO. MANY
PEOPLE DON'T KNOW THE VERY
FIRST PIECE OF LEGISLATION THAT
I AUTHORED. WHEN I WAS A
FRESHMAN ASSEMBLY MEMBER. WAS A
RESOLUTION THE CALL ON THE
UNIVERSITY CALIFORNIA TO DO
MORE ACADEMIC PARTNERSHIPS.
WITH HISTORICALLY BLACK
COLLEGES AND UNIVERSITIES.
SOMETHING MISTER BRADFORD TALKS
FONDLY ABOUT HIS IN MY DISTRICT
THERE'S A- STRONG COMPLEMENT OF
HBCU GRADUATES BOARD MEMBERS
THE CHAIRMAN OF THE MORE HOUSE.
THE BOARD LOSING THAN OTHERS A
PROUD HISTORY OF HBCUS BUT
THERE'S ALSO A YOUNG COHORT OF
STUDENTS WHO WANT TO ATTEND THE
UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA. AND
THEY WRESTLE WITH THAT AND I
SAID WELL LET'S DO ACADEMIC
PARTNERSHIPS WELL. WHAT I RUN
INTO. PROP TWO OH NINE. WHEN
YOU GET ALLEGE COUNCIL OPINION
THAT SAID IF YOU DO AN ACADEMIC
PARTNERSHIP. YOU CAN GET AROUND
PROP TWO ONE NINE THE FACT THAT
WE HAD THE INTELLECTUAL LIES.
ACADEMIC PARTNERSHIPS IN A WAY.
TO GET AROUND THE ROADBLOCK TO
HELP YOUNG STUDENTS GET AN
EDUCATION. IN AND OF ITSELF. IS
A PROBLEM. AND THEN I WAS HAZED
ON THE FOUR. WHEN I PRESENTED
THIS RESOLUTION. WHY WOULD WE
DO THIS. WHY WOULD WE DO THIS.
WHY WOULD WE CREATED ACADEMIC
PARTNERSHIP. BETWEEN
HISTORICALLY BLACK COLLEGES AND
UNIVERSITY CALIFORNIA NINETEEN
ASSEMBLY MEMBERS. DIDN'T GO UP
ON THE BILL ON CONCURRENCE
TWELVE SENATORS LAID OFF. AC
ARE TWENTY ONE AT THE TIME IN
TWO THOUSAND EIGHT. SO HERE WE
ARE IT'S TIME TO RECTIFY THAT.
DURING OUR DISCUSSIONS WE
BROUGHT TOGETHER BLACK BUSINESS
LEADERS. BLACK HIGH SCHOOL
STUDENTS COMMUNITY LEADERS AND
WE HAD A DISCUSSION OF WHAT CAN
WE DO. AND THOSE OF US WHO ARE
PARENTS WERE SHOCKED WHEN WE
HEARD HIGH SCHOOL SENIORS SAY.
WHY WOULD I WANT TO GO TO UCLA.
THEY DON'T WANT ME. WHY WOULD I
WANT TO GO TO BERKELEY. I'M
COMFORTABLE ON THAT CAMPUS AS I
DON'T SEE PEOPLE WHO LOOK LIKE
ME. AND SO FOR A PUBLIC
INSTITUTION. TO MAKE A SEGMENT
OF THE PUBLIC FEEL ON WELCOME
AND NOT WANTED. AND HAVE
EIGHTEEN AND SEVENTEEN YEAR
OLDS FEEL THAT WAY. THAT WAS A
PROBLEM I WILL SAY TO MY GOOD
COLLEAGUE FROM RIVERSIDE ALMOST
EVERY STUDENT IN HIGH SCHOOL
SAID THE ONLY YOU SEE I WOULD
BE INTERESTED IN GOING TO IS
RIVERSIDE BECAUSE IT'S THE MOST
DIVERSE CAMPUS. THEIR PARENTS
DIDN'T EVEN KNOW THAT BUT THE
SIXTEEN SEVENTEEN AND EIGHTEEN
YEAR OLDS KNEW THAT. BECAUSE
THE WORD HAD FILTERED DOWN
WHICH CAMPUS WAS THE MOST.
DIVERSE FRIEND SO WE ULTIMATELY
CREATED AN ACADEMIC PARTNERSHIP
BETWEEN THE H. B. C. USE AND
THE HISTORICALLY BLACK OLLEGE
ACTUALLY HISTORICALLY BLACK
COLLEGES AND UNIVERSITY
CALIFORNIA WE CREATED A SUMMER
FELLOWSHIP WHICH IS IN ITS
ELEVENTH YEAR TO CREATE A
PIPELINE INTO MBA PROGRAMS ON
MY GOOD COLLEAGUE FROM LOS
ANGELES PUT IT IN THE BUDGET.
THREE YEARS AGO US ALL AMOUNT
OF MONEY ON THIS ACADEMIC
PARTNERSHIP. WHEN WE FIRST
STARTED DOWN THAT ROAD WE GOT
PUSHED BACK FROM THE SENATE
WELL WHAT ARE THE STANDARDS. OF
H. B. C. USE EVERYBODY HAD A
REASON NOT TO DO IT. AND SO I
STAND IN STRONG SUPPORT OF A CA
FIVE TODAY. BECAUSE WE HAVE TO
HAVE A REASON TO DO THIS
BECAUSE WE HAVE DECADES OF
REASONS TO KNOW WHY THIS IS THE
RIGHT THING TO DO. OUR STUDENTS
SHOULD BE WELCOME ON THESE
CAMPUSES AND OUR ADMISSIONS
OFFICERS SHOULD HAVE THE TOOLS
THEY NEED. TO ACCEPT OUR
DIVERSE POPULATION THAT DIVERSE
POPULATION THRIVES IN A OUR
PUBLIC EDUCATION INSTITUTION SO
I STRONGLY SUPPORT ACA FIVE AND
COMPLEMENT ITS AUTHOR AND IT'S
FEEL DROPPED. SENATOR SKINNER.
THANK YOU OF. CITING OFFICER IN
MEMBERS I WANT TO. REITERATE
WHAT MY COLLEAGUE FROM- LOOKING
ON TO GET THE CORRECT JUST A.
DESCRIBE SO I HIT I'VE ALREADY
MENTIONED ON THE FLOOR AND
PREVIOUS OUTSIDE TALKS THAT I.
GREW UP IN A VERY SEGREGATED
TOWN EVERYONE PRETTY MUCH LOOKS
LIKE ME FOR THE DUE TO THE FACT
THAT THEY WERE COVENANTS IN THE
TOWN AND PEOPLE CAN LIVE THERE
ANYWAY. SO WHEN I WENT TO
COLLEGE AT UC BERKELEY IN THE
EARLY SEVENTIES I WAS A VERY.
IT WAS IT WAS A NEW WORLD FOR
ME BECAUSE THERE WERE PEOPLE OF
EVERY CLASS IN COLOR. AND THERE
WERE A LOT OF BLACK STUDENTS AT
CAL AT THAT TIME. AND OVER TIME
BY STATE I GOT BOTH MY DEGREES
AT UC BERKELEY AND I THEN ENDED
UP WORKING ON THE CAMPUS SO I
WAS ON THAT CAMPUS ON A DAILY
BASIS FROM THE EARLY SEVENTIES
UNTIL THE MID NINETIES HAND
OVER THAT TIME PERIOD I SAW A
REMARKABLE CHANGE IN THE
DEMOGRAPHICS OF THE CAMPUS
WHERE IT IS- IT DID NOT REFLECT
WHAT IT LOOKED LIKE NOW I CAN'T
FULLY DESCRIBE THAT ALL OF THE
STUDENTS OF COLOR WHO WERE
THERE. WHEN I WAS THERE IN THE
EARLY SEVENTIES FELT. FULLY
WELCOME TO IN FOLEY- INCREASED
BUT I CERTAINLY OBSERVED OVER
TIME THAT LESS AND LESS
ESPECIALLY BLACK STUDENTS FELT
AT ALL COMFORTABLE AT UC
BERKELEY BECAUSE INEVITABLY
THEY WOULD BE THE ONLY BLACK
STUDENT IN THE CLASS IN A
PARTICULAR COURSE WERE THE ONLY
BLACK STUDENT IN THEIR MAJOR
UNLESS THEY WERE IN ETHNIC
STUDIES MAJOR FOR EXAMPLE. YOUR
THE ONLY BLACK STUDENT IN THEIR
PARTICULAR HOUSING. SETTING
THAT IS NOT RIGHT AND I ALSO
WATCHED WHERE THE DIVERSITY OF
FACULTY HUGELY CHANGED HUGELY
CHANGED. NOT TO A GOOD END AND
NOT REFLECTING THE DEMOGRAPHICS
OF OUR STATE. SO IT'S BACK IN
TWENTY THIRTEEN OR FOURTEEN MY
TOWARDS THE END OF MY TERMS IN
THE ASSEMBLY THIS ISSUE WAS
BROUGHT UP THAT WE SHOULD RE
LOOK AT TWO NINE AND WE SHOULD
PUT IT ON THE BALLOT AND GET
RID OF TWO NINE. AND IT WAS
ISSUE USING THE TERM DIFFICULT
IS TO IS- IT IS A NICE WAY TO
DESCRIBE THE AT THE- PAIN FOR
CONVERSATIONS THAT OCCURRED
AROUND THIS SUBJECT AT THAT
TIME. BUT I AM VERY VERY HAPPY
THAT WE HAVE. THAT THE PROGRESS
THAT HAS BEEN MADE IN THAT
DISCUSSION AND DEBATE SINCE
THEN I APPRECIATE THAT THERE
ARE STILL RESIDENTS CALIFORNIA
WHO MAY NOT SEE THE VALUE. THE
IMPORTANCE IN THE ESSENTIAL
NESS OF AFFIRMATIVE ACTION BUT
I THINK I THINK THAT SO MANY
MORE PEOPLE HAVE NOW SEEN THAT
WE HAVE NOT BEEN SERVED BY THAT
BY TWO NINE WE HAVE NOT BEEN
SERVED. AND I WAS VERY VERY
PROUD THAT THE ENTIRE UC SYSTEM.
GOT BEHIND AND SUPPORTS THE
REPEAL OF TWO NINE AND I
STRONGLY URGE AN AYE VOTE.
SENATOR WES SO. THANK YOU
MEMBERS YOU KNOW PROP TWO OH
NINE I REMEMBER THIS VERY CLEAR
WHEN THIS INITIATIVE WAS PUT
FORWARD THIS IS WILL SOMETHING
THAT GOT ME ACTIVATED CIVIC
KLAY WORKING ON A CAMPAIGN
OPPOSES MEASURE AND I WAS VERY
DEEPLY SADDENED WHEN OF CAST
AND LESS MORE SAID AND WHEN I
HEARD THAT- 60% OF THE LATINO
COMMUNITY ACTUALLY VOTE FOR IT
WHEN I SPOKE TO BE SUPPORTED.
HE DIDN'T UNDER WHAT PROP TWO
OH NO WASN'T. ABOUT THEY SAID
ALL THIS IS ABOUT GETTING THE
BEST TENANTS IN OUR SCHOOLS
AND- BUT WE WERE ALREADY DOING
THAT. WE WERE ALREADY DOING
THAT SO PROP TWO OH NINE DID
NOT FIX THE PROBLEM. PROP TWO
NINE JUST BOND. THE HANDS. OF
OUR UNIVERSITIES. TO PROVIDE
DIVERSITY ON THE CAMPUSES WHAT
HAS RESULTED SINCE PROP TWO OH
NINE. CALIFORNIA'S PUBLIC
UNIVERSITIES ARE THE LEAST
DIVERSE IN THE COUNTRY. WHEN
YOU LOOK AT THE LIST OF THE TOP
FIFTEEN MOST DIVERSE CAMPUSES.
THEY'RE NOT IN CALIFORNIA NOT A
SINGLE ONE OR ARE PUBLIC
UNIVERSITIES BUT WE DO HAVE
STANFORD ON THERE WE HAVE U. S.
C. ON THERE WE HAVE PRIVATE
UNIVERSITIES IN CALIFORNIA THAT
ARE DOING A BETTER JOB. OF
INTERGROUP THEIR CAMPUSES THEN
ARE VERY PUBLIC UNIVERSITIES.
THIS IS SOMETHING THAT THIS
LEGISLATURE SHOULD BE VERY
CONCERNED ABOUT. THIS IS
SOMETHING THAT CALIFORNIANS
SHOULD BE ASHAMED OF. BECAUSE
WHEN PROP TWO OH NINE WAS
ADOPTED IN CALIFORNIA GUESS
WHAT HAPPENED. VICE LIKE A
SICKNESS PROP TWO NIGHT
AFFECTED OTHER STATES YOU HAVE
STATES LIKE. LIKE WASHINGTON IN
MICHIGAN AND THE BRASS CAN ERA
ZONA OKLAHOMA FLORIDA NEW
HAMPSHIRE FOLLOWED CALIFORNIA
TO DO THAT TO THEIR PUBLIC
UNIVERSITIES BUT WHEN WE THINK
ABOUT HEY WE THINK ABOUT RACISM
WE USUALLY DON'T THINK ABOUT
THOSE STATES WE THINK ABOUT THE
SOUTHERN BELTS THAT. THOSE HAVE
THESE THESE POLICIES YOU WOULD
EXPECT THEY WOULD BUT THEY
DON'T. SO WHY ARE WE THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA. WHY DO WE
DISCRIMINATE ARE AGAINST OUR
OWN PEOPLE MORE THAN ANY OTHER
STATE WHY WE WERE FOR WHY WERE
WE FIRST BECAUSE WERE THE MOST
EVER STATE. AND WE HAD ELEMENTS
IN THE STATE THE SOUGHT TO
ADVANCE THESE POLICIES TO KEEP
OUT THECERTAIN PEOPLE OUT OF
OUR UNIVERSITIES AND YOU KNOW
WHAT LADIES AND GENTLEMAN IT'S
BEEN EFFECTIVE. AND IT'S JUST
MORALLY WRONG THAT'S NOT
SOMETHING THAT THELEGISLATURE
SHOULD STANDING BY. NOT
SOMETHING THAT WE SHOULD
CONDONE WHAT ARE WE DOING WHAT
WE'RE DOING IS SAYING WE DON'T
WANT GIVE. DISADVANTAGED PEOPLE
THAT ARE POOR THAT WERE RAISED
FOR THAT COME FROM. THE POOREST
NEIGHBORHOODS IT OFTEN ARE
PLAGUED BY HAVING THE WORST
SCHOOLS. THAT OFTEN DON'T HAVE
THE EQUAL OPPORTUNITY GET A
QUALITY EDUCATION TO GO
UNIVERSITIES YOU. ARE ARE CUT
OUT OF EVERY SINGLE LEVEL OF
OPPORTUNITY IN OUR STATE YOU'RE
GONNA LIVE IN THE POOREST
COMMUNITIES WITH THE MOST
CONTAMINATION WITH THE WORST
SCHOOLS WITH NO PARKS. AND NO
HOPE TO GO TO A PUBLIC
UNIVERSITY THAT OFFERS YOU THE
MOST AFFORDABLE HIGH QUALITY
EDUCATION IN THE COUNTRY WE
CELEBRATE. THERE ARE
UNIVERSITIES ARE SOME OF THE
BEST. NUMBER WHAT I WANT TO
KNOW THE NUMBER ONE PUBLIC
UNIVERSITY IN THE COUNTRY UCLA.
CURRENTLY RANKED NUMBER ONE
PUBLIC UNIVERSITY YET. IT'S A
RECORD ON DIVERSITY. IS SAD I'M
ASHAMED OF IT. AND I WANT TO DO
SOMETHING I WOULD DO MORE. TO
DIVERSIFY MARC ALMOND MATER I
WANT MORE PEOPLE TO HAVE ACCESS
TO QUALITY EDUCATION WHY WOULD
WE BE AGAINST THAT LAYS IN
GERMAN. WHY DO WE HAVE A POLICY
TYING THE HANDS. OF THE LEADERS
OF OUR UNIVERSITIES TO THE
SIDE. YOU KNOW I MENTIONED THE
OTHER DAY. BUT I SUPPORT THIS
LEGISLATURE WEIGHING IN ON
DECISIONS THAT PERTAIN TO OUR
UNIVERSITIES AND WE WEIGH IN
AND SAY WE WANT TO GIVE OUR
CHILDREN MORE EDUCATION THAT'S
SOMETHING THAT WE SHOULD BE
PROUD OF. BUT WHEN WE WEIGH IN.
AND THE PUBLIC WAYS AND- I'M
CREATING OBSTACLES FOR OUR
UNIVERSITIES TO EDUCATE THE
PEOPLE OF OUR STATE WE OUGHT TO
BE ASHAMED OF THE- THAT'S WHAT
WE SHOULD. CLOSER TO WE SHOULD
FIGHT. LET THE PEOPLE THAT WE
APPOINT TO THESE POSITIONS AND
LET THE PEOPLE THAT WE PAY. TO
MAKE OUR UNIVERSITY IS THE BEST
IN THE NATION THE BEST THE
WORLD DECIDE. ON HOW THEY WANNA
OF A UP IN A GREAT. THERE
UNIVERSITIES WHAT KIND OF
ENVIRONMENT THEY WANT TO CREATE.
WHETHER THEY WANT PEOPLE OF THE
BRING IN PEOPLE THAT ARE ARE
FOR OUR DIVERSE BACK BACKGROUND
TO REPRESENT OUR STATE ANOTHER
LEVELS YOU KNOW WE ARE CREATING
VALUES. THERE ARE NOT.
APPROPRIATE AND THAT ARE NOT
REPRESENTATIVE OF WHO WE ARE AS
A NATION AND HOW WE HAVE BECOME
THE NUMBER ONE ECONOMY WE ARE
THE NUMBER ONE ECONOMY BECAUSE
WERE DIVERSE LADIES AND
GENTLEMAN BECAUSE WE HAVE DIPPY
FOR FROM ALL OVER THE WORLD OF
DIFFERENT VIEWS AND DIFFERENT
BACKGROUNDS AND THAT IS ONE OF
THE MOST IMPORTANT VALUES. IN
OUR STATE AND IN HUMANITIES
WITH GIVES A STRING THAT'S WHAT
STRENGTHENS THE FABRIC OF
SOCIETY WE ARE SAYING THAT IS
NOT IMPORTANT IN OUR
UNIVERSITIES AND WE ARE WRONG
THIS IS NOT RIGHT LET'S WRITE
THIS SHIP LET'S EDUCATE. THE
PUBLIC. WHY THEY NEED TO.
SUPPORT THIS INITIATIVE MD
TEAR DOWN PROP TWO NINE LET'S
EDUCATE THEM LET'S HAVE A
CONVERSATION WITH PEOPLE OUR
STATE LET'S DON'T DENY THEM THE
OPPORTUNITY TO WEIGH IN ON THE
SPANIARDS SO IMPORTANT TO THE
FUTURE OF OUR STATE TO THE
IMAGE OF OUR STATE. TO THE
HEART AND SOUL OF OUR STATE.
THIS IS AN ISSUE THAT WILL
DEFINE CALIFORNIA FOR MANY
YEARS. AND LET'S STOP HAVING
THIS DEBATE. ON ON RACE AND WHO
IS. MORE IMPORTANT BECAUSE OF
THE COLOR OF THEIR SKIN BUT
STOP HAVING THAT DEBATE AND
LET'S START REACHING OUT TO
EVERYBODY AND SAY BE PROUD YOUR
CALIFORNIAN CALIFORNIAN VALUES
YOU WORK HARD. CHANCE BUT THE
CALIFORNIA DREAM LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN PLEASE SUPPORT THIS
MEASURE BUT YOU NIGHT. AS
LEGISLATORS HERE I HOPE THAT
YOU FEEL. IN YOUR HEART THAT
THIS PROP TWO NINE WAS WRONG IN
EVERY SENSE IT WAS WRONG TO
BIND THE HANDS OF THE LEADERS
OF OUR UNIVERSITY TO THAT WAS
THE WRONG THING TO DO LET'S
RIVERSIDE LET'S MAKE IT RIGHT
PLEASE VOTE TO SUPPORT THIS
VERY IMPORTANT MEASURE THANK
YOU. FINISHING THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT. MEMBERS RACISM
EXISTS DEMOCRAT OF
DISCRIMINATION EXISTS THAT'S NO
SECRET I'VE EXPERIENCED IT
MYSELF I'VE SHARED IT LAST WEEK
WHEN WE WERE VOTING ON ETHNIC
STUDIES THAT WAS JUST A VERY
SMALL EXAMPLE I'VE HAD PEOPLE
ASK ME TO CHANGE MY NAME TO
ANGLICIZED MY NAME. I'VE HAD
YOU KNOW. WE ALL WE ALL HEARD
ABOUT KUNG FU AND HOW THE ASIAN
AMERICANS ARE TREATED BECAUSE
THE COLD IT RIGHT NOW. BUT NONE
OF THIS COMPARES TO WHAT WE ALL
WITNESSED WITH GEORGE FLOYD. I
CONTINUE TO WITNESS AS OUR
COUNTRY WAKES UP. TO THIS UGLY
REALITY. I STOOD WITH MY
COLLEAGUES RECENTLY OUTSIDE THE
STEPS OF THE CAPITOL TO
MEMORIALIZE MISTER FLOYD AND
MAKE A CALL TO ACTION. IT WAS
I'D LIKE TO THINK ARE OUT OF
THE LOS ANGELES CAUCUS IN OUR
LEGISLATIVE LEADERS FOR
ORGANIZING THAT. WE HAVE A LOT
OF WORK TO DO AND I AM PREPARED
TO ENGAGE IN THAT WORK. WE MADE%
HISTORY LAST YEAR WITH AB THREE
NINETY TO REFORM USED A POLICE
FORCE LAWS. AND WE HAVE MORE TO
DO. SOME OF THAT S NOT BEING
LED BY MISTER GIBSON MY GOOD
FRIEND MISTER GIBSON IN THE
ASSEMBLY AND I LOOK FORWARD TO
SUPPORTING HIS BILL TO BAN THE
USE OF CHOKEHOLDS. I SUPPORT
THE CSU REQUIREMENT TO MANDATE
ETHNIC STUDIES. FOR STUDENTS
AND WE STILL HAVE A LOT MORE
WORK. BUT EVEN THAT ISN'T A
PANACEA. RACISM EXISTS AND SOME
OF IT WILL REQUIRE CULTURAL
CHANGE. MEMBERS IT WAS NOT THAT
LONG AGO OUR COUNTRY AND
CALIFORNIA POLITICS IS
SUPPORTED THE CHINESE EXCLUSION
ACT THAT PUT IN LAW AT FIRST
LAWS SPECIFICALLY TARGETING
CHINESE PEOPLE ON THE BASIS OF
RACE. REMAIN IN EFFECT UNTIL
NINETEEN FORTY THREE. IT'S EASY
TO FORGET THAT MUCH OF
CALIFORNIA'S HISTORY IS
REPLETE. WITH ANTI ASIAN RACISM.
THE CHINESE EXCLUSION ACT ONLY
ESTABLISH BARRIERS EXCLUSIVELY
FOR CHINESE ATTEMPTING TO ENTER
THE COUNTRY BUT ALSO PLACE
DISCRIMINATORY RESTRICTIONS ON
CHINESE LABORS. ALREADY LIVING
IN THE UNITED STATES WE
ACTUALLY HAD LAWS AT ONE POINT
PROHIBITING PUBLIC BODIES FROM
EMPLOYING CHINESE AND CALLED
UPON THE LEGISLATURE TO
PROTECT. THE STATE FROM BURDENS
AND EVILS ARISING FROM THEIR
PRESENCE. IT WASN'T LONG AGO
THAT THERE WAS AN ENTIRE
POLITICAL PARTY CREATED AN
ORGANIZED AROUND ANTI CHINESE
RACISM. IT WAS CALLED THE
WORKING MEN'S PARTY OF
CALIFORNIA. IT'S FAMOUS SLOGAN
WAS THE CHINESE MOSCOW. THEIR
BIGGEST LEADER AND ADVOCATE
DENISE TURNEY INFAMOUSLY
PROCLAIM CALIFORNIA MUST BE ALL
AMERICAN FOR ALL CHINESE WE'RE
RESOLVED THAT IT SHALL BE
AMERICAN AND ARE PREPARED TO
MAKE IT SO. COLLEAGUES THAT
RIDICULOUSNESS THAT PARTY LED
BY THAT RACES MAN HELD SEATS IN
THIS VERY HOUSE. THE VERY
INSTITUTION WE'RE SITTING IN
AND REPRESENTING TODAY. THAT
RACES PARTY VIGOROUSLY
SUPPORTED AND PUSH ANTI CHINESE
LAWS AND CONSTITUTIONAL
AMENDMENTS I WON'T READ THROUGH
ALL OF THEM. BUT ONE THE
SUCCESSFUL IN SIGNED IN THE
STATE'S CONSTITUTION WAS A BAN
ON PUBLIC EMPLOYMENT FOR THE
CHINESE. IT WAS UNDER SECTION
OF THE CONSTITUTION WHICH THEY
SIMPLY ENTITLED CHINESE.
KNOWING THIS HISTORY MAKES ME
SAD FRANKLY THAT TODAY THIS
BILL IS RESCINDING VERY SIMPLE
BUT POWERFUL LANGUAGE FOR MORE
CONSTITUTION THAT MAKES IT
ILLEGAL TO DISCRIMINATE AGAINST
SOMEONE FOR ETHNICITY OR RACE
IN THE COURSE OF PUBLIC.
EMPLOYMENT RACISM IS STILL WITH
US AND TWENTY TWENTY IT'S
INFURIATING IT'S FRUSTRATING
AND IT'S HARD TO BELIEVE
SOMETIMES. AND IT'S WHY SO MANY
PEOPLE TOOK TO THE STREETS IN
THE MIDDLE OF A GLOBAL HEALTH
PANDEMICS. THE PROBLEM WITH THE
CA FIVE IS THAT IT TAKES THE
POSITION THAT WE MUST FIGHT
DISCRIMINATION WITH MORE
DISCRIMINATION. MEMBERS THE
ANSWER TO DISCRIMINATION IS NOT
MORE DISCRIMINATION THE ANSWER
IS NOT TO CODIFY IN OUR STATE
CONSTITUTION. THE ABILITY FOR
OUR GOVERNMENT AND EDUCATIONAL
INSTITUTIONS TO DISCRIMINATE ON
THE BASIS OF RACE SEX SEXUAL
ORIENTATION. COLOR ETHNICITY OR
NATIONAL ORIGIN. THE LANGUAGE
OF OUR CONSTITUTION CLOSELY
PARALLELS TITLE SEVEN OF THE
CIVIL RIGHTS ACT OF NINETEEN
SIXTY FOUR. IN FACT PROP TWO
NINE WITH CALLED THE CALIFORNIA
CIVIL RIGHTS INITIATIVE. THE
FIRST TWO NIGHT OF THE UNITED
STATES SUPREME COURT DECISION
TO CONSIDER AN ALLEGED
VIOLATION OF TITLE SEVEN
CONCLUDED. WHAT IS REQUIRED BY
CONGRESS IS THE REMOVAL OF
ARTIFICIAL ARBITRARY. AND
UNNECESSARY BARRIERS TO
EMPLOYMENT WHEN THE BARRIER
OPERATE INVIDIOUS LEE. TO
DISCRIMINATE ON THE BASIS OF
RACIAL OR OTHER IMPERMISSIBLE
CLASSIFICATION. AS CALIFORNIA
SUPREME COURT JUSTICE JANICE
BROWN THE FIRST AFRICAN
AMERICAN WOMAN TO SIT ON THE
CALIFORNIA SUPREME COURT
EXPLAINED. HOWEVER IT IS
RATIONALIZED A PREFERENCE TO
ANY GROUP CONSTITUTES INHERENT
INEQUALITY. MOREOVER
PREFERENCES FOR ANY PURPOSE ARE
ANATHEMA TO THE VERY PROCESS OF
DEMOCRACY. LET'S FAST FORWARD
TO TWENTY TWENTY. JUST LAST
WEEK WE HAD A HISTORICAL
SUPREME COURT RULING PROTECTING
THE RIGHTS OF THE LGBT
COMMUNITY. THIS RECENT DECISION
A SIGNIFICANT LEAP TOWARD
EQUALITY FOR THE LGBT COMMUNITY
DECLARED THAT A KEY PROVISION
OF TITLE SEVEN OF THE CIVIL
RIGHTS ACT OF NINETEEN SIXTY
FOUR BARS JOB DISCRIMINATION
AGAINST LGBT WORKERS. IT BARS
RUMINATION MEMBERS THAT'S THE
POINT OR INSTITUTION SHOULD NOT
BRACE AND CELEBRATE
DISCRIMINATION BASED ON RACE
SEX SEXUAL ORIENTATION COLOR
ETHNICITY OR NATIONAL ORIGIN
LET'S NOT FORGET THIS BILL IS
ELIMINATING A PROHIBITION ON
DISCRIMINATION BASED ON SEX
WHICH THE SUPREME COURT JUST
DETERMINED ENCOMPASSES THE LGBT
COMMUNITY. LET'S READ THE
CALIFORNIA CIVIL RIGHTS
INITIATIVE OR A. K. A. PROP TWO
OH NINE. TWENTY CA WANTS TO
JETTISON FROM OUR STATE
CONSTITUTION. THE STATE SHALL
NOT DISCRIMINATE AGAINST OR
GRANT PREFERENTIAL TREATMENT TO
ANY INDIVIDUAL OR GROUP ON THE
BASIS OF RACE SEX COLOR
ETHNICITY OR NATIONAL ORIGIN IN
THE OPERATION OF PUBLIC
EMPLOYMENT. PUBLIC EDUCATION OR
PUBLIC CONTRACTING WHAT IS SO
CONTROVERSIAL ABOUT THIS. HOW
DID WE GET TO A POINT WHERE WE
ARE NOW ADVOCATING FOR
DISCRIMINATION IN THE LAW. THE
WORDS AFFIRMATIVE ACTION DO NOT
APPEAR IN THIS BILL. IT'S ABOUT
DISCRIMINATION LEGALIZED
DISCRIMINATION. I ACKNOWLEDGE
THE PROBLEM THE PROPONENTS ARE
TRYING TO SOLVE AND THAT'S WHY
WE SHOULD BE WORKING TO
INCREASE THE REPRESENTATION OF
WOMEN AND MINORITIES IN OUR
PUBLIC INSTITUTIONS. LET'S LOOK
AT SOME OF THE NUMBERS. SINCE
NINETEEN NINETY FOUR PRIOR TO
THE ENACTMENT PROPOSITION TWO
OH NINE. UC FRESHMAN ENROLLMENT
FOR BLACK AFRICAN AMERICANS
HAVE ALMOST DOUBLED. FRESHMAN
WOMAN FOR STATIC LATINOS
INCREASED BY TWO HUNDRED AND
43% WHITE FIRST YEAR FRESHMEN
WOMAN IS EQUAL TO WHAT IT WAS
IN NINETEEN NINETY FOUR. AND
HERE'S A RECENT HEADLINE FROM
THE LA TIMES YOU SEE ADMITS
LARGEST MOST DIVERSE CLASS EVER
OF CALIFORNIA FRESHMAN. WE HAVE
SOME OF THE MOST DIVERSE
UNIVERSITIES IN THE COUNTRY
MEMBERS. KNOWING THIS WHY WOULD
WE ALL OF A SUDDEN INJECT RACE
INTO OUR ROOM AND PROCESS. SO
HOW DO WE REALLY QUALITY. WE
NEED TO IMPROVE OUR EXISTING
SYSTEM AND INSTITUTIONS LET'S
LOOK AT PUBLIC SCHOOLS. OUR
PUBLIC SCHOOLS ARE LETTING DOWN
STUDENTS IN SOME OF THE MOST
VULNERABLE AREAS OF THE STATE.
TOO MANY LOW INCOME MINORITY
STUDENTS ARE NOT GETTING THE
EDUCATION THEY DESERVE IN
PRIMARY AND SECONDARY GRADES.
FOR EXAMPLE. 21% OF AFRICAN
AMERICAN STUDENTS WHO GRADUATED
IN TWENTY EIGHTEEN WE'RE
CONSIDER PREPARE FOR COLLEGE OR
CAREER COMPARED TO FIFTY TWO
PERCENT. OF WHITE STUDENTS AND
74% OF ASIAN STUDENTS. THIS IS
NOT ACCEPTABLE. WE OWE IT TO
THE STUDENTS TO PUSH FOR
COMPREHENSIVE SCHOOL REFORMS
AND FUNDING SO ALL OUR STUDENTS
ARE PREPARED FOR HIGHER
EDUCATION. I'VE FOUGHT FOR
SCHOOL REFORM FOR YEARS AND
SEVEN PROVING OUR SCHOOLS AND
ENSURING KIDS RECEIVE THE BEST
EDUCATION POSSIBLE. TOO MANY OF
US RESIST CHANGE. NOW IS THE
TIME FOR THIS CHANGE. MEMBERS I
MENTION IT WASN'T THAT LONG AGO
THAT WE HAD THE CHINESE
EXCLUSION ACT. IT'S NOT THAT
LONG AGO WE HAD LAWS THAT
EXPLICITLY HEARD AFRICAN
AMERICANS. AND THE LEGACY OF
THESE LAWS CONTINUE WITH US.
THERE ARE WAYS WE CAN BREAK
THIS UP. JUST CONSIDER RIGHT
NOW YOUR ZIP CODE IS THE VISIT
BECAUSE THE TERMINATION OF HOW
GOOD YOUR EDUCATION WILL BE IN
SCHOOL. IF THE MOM IN A LOW
INCOME NEIGHBORHOOD WANTS TO
SEND YOUR CHILD TO SCHOOL
ACROSS TOWN THAT PROVIDES A
BETTER PROGRAM FOR HER CHILD.
SHE'S FOR BRIDGE FOR BILLION
FROM ALLOWING HER CHILD TO GO
TO THAT SCHOOL. WE HAVE DECADES
OF LAWS. RIGID INSTITUTIONS AND
ECONOMIC CIRCUMSTANCES THAT
DETERMINE WHERE YOUR ZIP CODE
WILL BE BUT NOW YOUR ZIP CODE
DETERMINES WHAT EDUCATION YOU
WILL GET. THIS IS WRONG AND WE
NEED TO FIX IT. EVERY TIME A
BILL WAS INTRODUCED IN THIS
BUILDING TO PROVIDE MINORITY
AND LOW INCOME STUDENTS WITH
MORE PUBLIC SCHOOL OPTIONS IT
IS RESISTED BY TOO MANY OF US.
SOME WHO LIVE IN NICE
NEIGHBORHOODS WITH SCHOOLS THEY
ARE HAPPY WITH. I HAVE TO GIVE
CREDIT TO THE AUTHOR OF A CA
FIVE. SHE HAS TRIED TO PUSH FOR
SCHOOL REFORMS AGAINST MANY
ODDS AND DESERVES CREDIT FOR
THAT. MEMBERS A HUNDRED AND
FIFTEEN THOUSAND PEOPLE HAVE
SIGNED A PETITION AGAINST THIS
BILL. I AM FOR YOU TO LISTEN TO
THESE VOICES BEFORE WE PROCEED.
THIS BILL IS RACING TO BEAT THE
DEADLINE TO GET ON THE BALLOT
BUT IT'S WORTH SLOWING DOWN.
LET'S WORK TOGETHER OVER THE
NEXT YEAR ON HOW WE CAN
ACCOMPLISH OUR GOALS WITHOUT
USING DISCRIMINATION AS THE
MAIN TOOL TO FIGHT
DISCRIMINATION. I STRONGLY URGE
ALL OF US TO VOTE NO OR WITH
pTOGETHER TO PROVIDE REAL
SOLUTIONS. I UNDERSTAND THE
SENSE OF URGENCY BUT LET'S DO
THIS RIGHT. THANK YOU. SENATOR
DR SO. THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR.
OUR COLLEAGUES ARE RISE NOT
ONLY AS A SENATOR BUT AS VICE
CHAIR OF THE CALIFORNIA LET THE
ANGLE LEGISLATIVE CAUCUS. IN
STRONG SUPPORTER BASE A FIVE
FIVE BY DOCTOR WEBER. UP TO A
NINE WAS PASSED IN NINETEEN
NINETY SIX AND A PROHIBITED.
RACE AND GENDER CONSCIOUS
REMEDIES. THAT RECTIFIED THE
UNDER REPRESENTATION OF WOMEN
AND PEOPLE OF COLOR. BLACK
EMPLOYMENT CONTRACTING AND
EDUCATION THESE PROGRAMS WERE
DESIGNED NOT TO TAKE SOME
PEOPLE'S OPPORTUNITIES AWAY.
RATHER IT WAS TO EXPAND EQUAL
OPPORTUNITY FOR PEOPLE OF COLOR
AND WOMEN WERE THEN AND STILL
TODAY LARGELY EXCLUDED FROM
SCHOOL AND BUSINESS AND JOB
OPPORTUNITIES DUE TO THE
HISTORIC AND SYSTEMIC MAIL
PREFERENCES AND RACISM. THAT
INCLUDED PRO ACTIVE EFFORTS IN
STATE HIRING CONTRACTING AS
WELL AS EFFORTS BY THE
UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA AND
STATE UNIVERSITY SYSTEMS. TO
HELP YOUR PROTECTIVE
PROSPECTIVE STUDENTS OF COLOR
AND BUSINESS OWNERS AN EQUAL
OPPORTUNITY TO TEN WELL
ATTENDED ONE OF THE EXCELLENT
UNIVERSITY CAMPUSES ALL OR- GET
A CHANCE AT A GOVERNMENT
BUSINESS CONTRACT. GOVERNMENT
CONTRACTS ARE INCREDIBLY
VALUABLE FOR SETTING UP SMALL
BUSINESSES FOR SUCCESS. THIS IS
ESPECIALLY TRUE FOR BUSINESSES
OWNED BY WOMEN AND MINORITIES
WHO MUST OVERCOME THE
LONGSTANDING OBSTACLES THE
SUCCESS THAT HAVE NOTHING TO DO
WITH THEIR HARD WORK OR THEIR
ABILITY TO INNOVATE. THE
NINETEEN NINETIES CALIFORNIA
WAS ONE OF THE TOP PERFORMING
STATES IN TERMS OF CONTRACTING
WITH WOMEN AND MINORITY
ENTREPRENEURS. IN THE LAST
TWENTY YEARS CALIFORNIA HAS
DROPPED TO ONE OF THE TWO WORST
PERFORMING STATES RELATIVE. TO
OUR DIVERSITY PUTTING IT IN
COMPANY WITH MUCH LESS RACIALLY
DIVERSE STATES LIKE NEBRASKA IN
VERMONT. IN THE EDUCATION
SECTOR RACE BLIND ADMISSIONS
POLICIES THAT SELECT APPLICANTS
BASED ON PURPORTEDLY OBJECTIVE
METRICS LIKE SAT SCORES OR
RECOMMENDATION LETTERS ONLY
REINFORCE EXISTING
INEQUALITIES. SUCH SYSTEMS
AWARD COVETED ENROLLMENT SLOT
OR DO. TO THOSE WHO CAN AFFORD
EXPENSIVE TEST PREP COURSES ARE
WHO LIVE IN PRIVILEGE THESE
APPLICATION FACTORS DO NOT
RECOGNIZE THE TREMENDOUS
CHALLENGES AND OBSTACLES AND
TALENTS THAT MANY STUDENTS OF
COLOR OFTEN FROM UNDER
UNDERSERVED COMMUNITIES FACE.
CHALLENGES THAT TODAY HAVE BEEN
EXACERBATED BY COLBERT NINETEEN.
LOS ANGELES COUNTY THE LARGEST
PUBLIC SCHOOL SYSTEM AND IN THE
U. S. ARE THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA THE SECOND LARGEST
PUBLIC SCHOOL DISTRICT- SERVING
MORE THAN SEVEN HUNDRED
THOUSAND STUDENTS. IT'S
ESTIMATED THAT MORE THAN HALF
OF THE FAMILIES IN THE DISTRICT
I HAVE ENDURED A JOB LOSS
DURING THE PANDEMIC. AS A
RESULT MANY WORKING AGE
STUDENTS HAD TO LOOK FOR WORK.
OR PICK UP MORE HOURS THE JOBS
THEY ALREADY HAD BECAUSE THEIR
FAMILIES NEEDED HELP. COVERING
LIVING EXPENSES. THERE IS A
REAL FEEL FEAR FEAR THAT FOR
SOME OF THOSE KIDS THIS MAY
PUSH THEM TO DROP OUT OF HIGH
SCHOOL. WE HAVE TO RECOGNIZE
THEIR STRUGGLE AND RECOGNIZE
THAT ACTIONS NEED TO BE TAKEN
TO ENSURE THAT THEY DO NOT FALL
THROUGH THE CRACKS IN THE
SYSTEM. AND NEVER HAVE THE
CHANCE TO REACH THEIR FULL
POTENTIAL. HOW IS IT THAT
CALIFORNIA'S STILL OWN ONE OF
ONLY EIGHT STATES TO HAVE AN
ANTI EQUAL OPPORTUNITY BAND.
AND YET IS THE MOST DIVERSE.
WITH A CA ON THE BALLOT AND
WITH THE VOTERS APPROVAL WHAT
DOES THAT MEAN FAIR HIRING
PRACTICES FOR WOMEN AND PEOPLE
OF COLOR. SINCE OUR COLLEAGUES
I AM PROUD TO SAY THAT HI. AS
MANY OTHERS AND THE PRODUCT OF
AFFIRMATIVE ACTION PROGRAM AT
SAINT MARY'S COLLEGE. THEY SEE
A FIVE WILL STRENGTHEN OUR
STATE AND WITH THAT I URGE YOUR
BIBLE. SENATOR PENN. THANK YOU
MADAM PRESIDENT- SENATORS- IS
VICE CHAIR OF THE ASIAN PACIFIC
ISLANDER LEGISLATIVE CAUCUS-
I'M PROUD TO STAND IN SUPPORT
OF ACA FIVE SO WE CAN PUT THIS
ISSUE BEFORE THE VOTERS. THIS
ISSUE OF FAIRNESS AND THIS
ISSUE OF EQUAL OPPORTUNITY FOR
ALL CALIFORNIANS. NOW I WANTED
TO FIRST OF ALL SAY THAT THE-
MAJORITY OF ASIAN PACIFIC
ISLANDERS AND NUMEROUS POLLS
SUPPORT ACA FIVE AND AGAIN THE
EIGHTY A LEGISLATIVE CAUCUS
ALSO SUPPORTS ACA FIVE. AND WHY
DO WE SUPPORT ACA FIVE BECAUSE
WE UNDERSTAND THAT BY THE TIME
YOU GET TO THE COLLEGE
APPLICATION PROCESS STRUCTURAL
RACISM. STRUCTURAL RACISM
INSURED THAT PEOPLE ARE NOT AT
THE SAME STARTING POINT. NO
MATTER WHAT YOUR TALENT IS
EQUALLY TALENTED PEOPLE ARE NOT
AT THE SAME PLACE BECAUSE OF
STRUCTURAL RACISM. WE NEED THE
TOLLS TO GIVE PEOPLE THE
OPPORTUNITY. TO BE ABLE TO
SUCCEED NO WAY THAT CORRECTS
FOR THIS FUNDAMENTAL ANY
QUALITY. NOW I DO WANT TO I
RECOGNIZE AND APPRECIATE THE
HISTORY OF- DISCRIMINATION
AGAINST THE P. I. PARTICULARLY
THE CHINESE AMERICAN COMMUNITY
IS OUTLINED BY MY GOOD
COLLEAGUE FROM DIAMOND BAR- BUT
AFTER THAT I DRAW DIFFERENT
CONCLUSIONS. FROM THAT HISTORY.
THE CURVE IN NINETEEN OUTBREAK
IS CERTAINLY REMINDED- THE
EIGHTY AYE COMMUNITY ALTHOUGH
THE THING MANY OF US HAVEN'T
FORGOTTEN THAT NO MATTER HOW.
SUCCESSFUL ACCOMPLISHED-
COVERED SEEMS THAT WE ARE PART
OF THE GREATER SOCIETY THAT WE
ARE NOT. THAT WE ARE DIFFERENT
THAT PEOPLE LOOK AT US AND THEY
DO JUDGE US BY THE COLOR OF OUR
SKIN OR OTHER CHARACTERISTICS
THE SLANT ARISE OTHER PHYSICAL
CHARACTERISTICS. AND FORTY
THERE ARE SOME WHO WILL NOW
ONLY EXPRESS HATE AND EVEN
SOMETIMES VIOLENCE- BUT ALSO AT
PEOPLE WILL JUDGE US BUT- FOR
DIFFERENT THINGS AS WELL. BUT
THIS IS NOT SOMETHING THAT JUST
SHOWED UP WITH BECAUSE OF IT.
AND IS MENTIONED THERE WAS A
LONG HISTORY OF THIS IS
PREVIOUSLY DESCRIBED BUT I ALSO
POINT OUT THAT. FOR THE API
COMMUNITY AND I DO I RECOGNIZE
THAT THERE PORTIONS OF THE API
COMMUNITY WHO DO HAVE
CHALLENGES. IN THE COLLEGE
ADMISSIONS PROCESS SO IT'SA
METHODOLOGY THAT ALL API OR
DOING FINE FOR GOING TO COLLEGE
WE CAN TALK ABOUT. THE DIRECTLY
TO THE PACIFIC ISLANDER
COMMUNITY THE- MAY THIS
SOUTHEAST ASIANS- MOM- THESE-
FOURTH THAT HAVE MORE
CHALLENGES. IN THAT COLLEGE
PROCESS BUT THERE ARE SOME THAT
ARE. DOING BETTER. IN IN THAT
BUT YET. WHEN WE FINISH COLLEGE
AND WE GO OUT IN THE WORKPLACE-
WE DON'T SEEM TO DO AS WELL IN
FACT THE- THIS VERY SENATE WE
HAVE A SELECT COMMITTEE ON A
TIE FAIRS. WE ACTUALLY HELD A
HEARING ON THE GLASS CEILING
FOR ATI. BECAUSE WHAT WE'LL SEE
IS THAT WELL CERTAIN SUBGROUPS
OF THE P. I. COMMUNITY MAYES
BE. REPRESENTED ARE WELL
REPRESENTED IN CERTAIN
PROFESSIONS AND HIGHER
EDUCATION AGAIN ONLY SOME SUB
SEGMENTS. WHEN YOU LOOK AT
UPPER MANAGEMENT AND COMPANIES
OR PROFESSIONS RIGHT EVEN MY
OWN PROFESSION OF MEDICINE AND
A PHYSICIAN YOU LOOK AROUND AND
YOU START LOOKING AT THE
DEPARTMENT CHAIRS AND THE DEANS
AND YOU DON'T FIND A WHOLE LOT
OF A. B. I. UP THERE IN FACT
THERE ARE NO ATI MEDICAL SCHOOL
DEANS. IN THE UNITED STATES.
THINK ABOUT THAT. ALL RIGHT-
YOU HAVE OVER A HUNDRED FIFTY
SOME MEDICAL SCHOOLS IN US AND-
SO WE'RE SUPPOSED TO BE WELL
REPRESENTED- BUT WE SAW THAT
THIS IS ALSO THE CASE AND LAW
IN TECHNOLOGY LOT OF API
ENGINEERS ON THE BOTTOM RUNGS
SOMEHOW THEY DON'T SEEM TO GET
PROMOTED. AND I DON'T THINK. I
DON'T THINK THAT THAT'S BECAUSE
WE'RE NOT TALENTED ENOUGH.
RIGHT I DON'T THINK IT'S
BECAUSE WE'RE NOT TALENTED
ENOUGH TO DO SO MAYBE SOMETHING
ELSE IS AT PLAY AND I THINK
THAT'S SOMETHING THAT CERTAINLY
THE BLACK AND LATINO COMMUNITY
HAVE NOTICED AS WELL NOT ONLY
FOR THEMSELVES BUT FOR OTHER
PEOPLE OF COLOR. AND SO IF WE
WHAT COMES THE ACA FIVE IT'S
GREAT TO TALK ABOUT A QUOTE
UNQUOTE COLOR BLIND- PROCESS OR
SOCIETY BUT WE KNOW IT'S- NOT
COLOR BLIND IT'S BLINDNESS
TOWARDS STRUCTURAL RACISM. AND
THAT DOES NOT BENEFIT OUR STATE
AND CERTAINLY DOESN'T BENEFIT
THE PEOPLE OF CALIFORNIA. SO I
HOPE THAT WE WILL ALL JOIN
TOGETHER. THE ON THE SENATE
FLOOR TO GIVE THE VOTERS AN
OPPORTUNITY TO WEIGH IN ON THIS
VERY ISSUE. SO WE CAN HAVE THIS
DEBATE IN THE STATE WE CAN HAVE
THIS DISCUSSION. OUT WE NEED TO
RECOGNIZE THAT WE NEEDTHE
TOOLS. TO BE ABLE TO ADDRESS.
THIS ONGOING PROBLEM A
STRUCTURAL RACISM THAT MEANS
THAT PEOPLE DO NOT ACTUALLY
HAVE EQUAL OPPORTUNITY. AND IF.
THE FOR THE EIGHTY EIGHTY AYE
COMMUNITY PARKS THE PORTIONS
THAT OPPOSE THIS BILL AND I
KNOW YOU KNOW THERE'S THERE ARE
SOME WHO HAS COME OUT AND SAY
THEY'RE OPPOSED. I WOULD SAY TO
THEM IS THAT LOOK AT YOUR OWN
LOOK AT HISTORY LOOK EVEN YOUR
OWN EXPERIENCES AND WE CAN'T
HAVE A CONVERSATION ABOUT HOW
RACE. AS AFFECTED EVEN YOUR OWN
LIVES. AND YOUR OWN
OPPORTUNITIES. THEN HOW ARE WE
GOING TO CREATE THOSE
OPPORTUNITIES FOR ALL
CALIFORNIANS INCLUDING
YOURSELVES AND WITH THAT HIGHER
AN AYE VOTE ON A CA FIVE THANK
YOU. SENATOR WIECKOWSKI. MAN
THE SPEAKER MADAM CHAIR. AND
PRESIDENT I'LL GET IT RIGHT
THIS THIS ISSUE AC FIVE IS BEEN
PASSIONATELY CONSTITUTIONALLY
EMOTIONALLY DEBATED IN MY IN MY
DISTRICT AND I FEEL COMPELLED
THIS AFTERNOON TO GET UP AND
AFFIRMATIVELY STATE MY SUPPORT
FOR A CA FIVE- I WAS A YOUNG
STUDENT WHEN THE BACK POCKET
DECISION. CAME DOWN ERA WHEN
PROP TWO OH NINE WAS PASSED HI
I PERSONALLY FELT ASHAMED OF
THE GREAT STATE OF CALIFORNIA-
WE'RE GOING TO HAVE. AS MY
COLLEAGUE FROM SACRAMENTO SAID
CALIFORNIANS DESERVE TO HAVE
THIS DEBATE MY GOD IF WE CAN'T
DO IT IN TWENTY THE YEAR TWENTY
TWENTY WITH EVERYTHING GOING
AROUND IN THE STATE IN IN OUR
COUNTRY TO HAVE THIS DEBATE IN
OUR VILLAGES IN OUR TOWNS AT
OUR CHURCHES. INEQUALITY AND
STRUCTURAL RACISM IF THIS IS
NOT THE TIME. WE'LL NEVER IT'S
NEVER GET A COPY I THINK WITH
THE PASSAGE OF PROP TWO OH NINE.
WE SAW AND IT'S MY COLLEAGUES
WHO SPOKE ELOQUENTLY ABOUT IT A
REAL- RACIAL DISPARITIES
INCREASE IT'S BEEN TWO DECADES
WE JUST CAN'T PRETEND THAT IT'S
NOT HAPPENING. THIS IS A
FUNDAMENTAL STEP IN THE RIGHT
DIRECTION PITCH TOWARDS
EQUALITY IT'S A FUNDAMENTAL
STEP IN THE RIGHT DIRECTION
TOWARDS CORRECTING THE
STRUCTURAL- HAS. RACISM AND
IT'S LONG OVERDUE. I WOULD URGE
AN AYE VOTE AN ACA FIVE.
SENATOR BRADFORD. THANK YOU
MADAM PRESIDENT I RISE TODAY AS
VICE CHAIR OF THE AFRICAN
AMERICAN CAUCUS AND STRONG
SUPPORT OF A CA FIVE I'M REALLY
SAD THAT WE HAVE TO HAVE A
DEBATE. ON RACE AND ONE OF THE
MOST DIVERSE IF NOT DIVERSE
MOST DIVERSE STATE IN THIS
NATION. ONE OF THE FIRST
COUNTRIES IN THE- AND WE'RE
STILL HAVING A ISSUE REGARDING
RACE WITH A TWENTY FOUR YEARS
OF FILL YEAR. BECAUSE OF PROP
TOOL NINE WE HAVE FAR FEWER
WOMEN WE HOW FAR FEWER MEET
MINORITIES IN CORPORATE SEE
SWITCH. THAN EVER BEFORE IN
THIS STATE. WE HAVE FAR FEW
AFRICAN AMERICANS AND LATINOS
IN COLLEGE BECAUSE OF TWO OH
NINE BUT TO SIT HERE AND SAY
THAT RACE IS NOT A FACTOR RACE
IS A FACTOR IN EVERY BEING THAT
WE DO. AND TO SAY THAT WERE
COLOR BLIND WE'RE NOT CONSCIOUS
OF IT WERE A LOT. STILL THIS
AFFORDS US THE OPPORTUNITY TO
NOT SET QUOTAS. BUT TO REMOVE
THE BARRIERS OF HIRING REMOVE
THE BARRIERS AND EDUCATION
REMOVE THE BARRIERS OF
OPPORTUNITY. I'VE BEEN IN THIS
LEGISLATURE NINE YEARS AND I'VE
LOST TRACK OF THE NUMBER OF
BILLS THAT WE'VE HAD TO
INTRODUCE THAT HAD SOME KIND OF
SUPPLIER DIVERSITY SOME KIND OF
EQUITY AND MAKING SURE
CONTRACTING INCLUDES WOMEN
MINORITIES WE PUT THAT LANGUAGE
IN SB ONE BUYER MY GOOD FRIEND
FROM SAN JOSE. WE PUT IT IN
CANNABIS LEGISLATION. SB TWELVE
NINETY FOUR THAT I AUTHOR WE
PUT IT IN INSURANCE FOR OUR
FORMER COLLEAGUE IN OUR CHURCH
COMMISSION TO MAKE SURE
MINORITIES ARE AT THE TABLE
WE'VE DONE IT FOR GENDER. WE'VE
DONE IT BECAUSE TOOL NINE IS
PREVENTED US FROM HIRING AND
ALLOWING FOLKS THE INNER
OPPORTUNITIES I CHALLENGE MY
WHITE COLLEAGUES. BUT YOU CAN
COUNT ON ONE HAND THE NUMBER OF
TIMES IF YOU WALKED INTO A ROOM
LOCKED INTO AN ORGANIZATION IN
YOUR THE ONLY ONE THAT LOOKS
LIKE YOU. THERE'S NOT ENOUGH
FINGERS IN POLLS IN THIS
BUILDING THE COUNT THE NUMBER
OF TIMES THAT ME AND MY
COLLEAGUE FROM LA AND WALKED
INTO A ROOM AND WE'RE THE ONLY
ONE IT LOOKS LIKE CUTS. STARTED
WHEN I WAS A BOY SCOUT. SCOUT
LEADER CALLED ME DARKIE. IT WAS.
WHEN I WAS THE ONLY BLACK DIAL.
IT'S EITHER BEING THE ONLY
BLACK WHITE WITH SILVER UPRIGHT
PIANO THE ONLY BLACK SALES REP.
IN MY ORGANIZATION. I KNOW
ABOUT DISCRIMINATION I'D LIVE
IT EVERY DAY WE LIVE IN THIS
BUILDING I CHALLENGE MY NON
AFRICAN AMERICAN COLLEAGUES.
MANY OF WHOM HAVE NEVER HIRED A
BLACK PERSON. AND PROBABLY
NEVER WILL. AND THAT'S WHY BUT
WHEN YOU COME TO OUR OFFICE WE
HAVE GREAT DIVERSITY IN OUR
OFFICES. BUT I CHALLENGE MY
NINE AFTER AMERICAN COLLEAGUES
I KNOW WHO ARE DIFFERENT FROM
BERKELEY IS DONE THAT A FEW
OTHERS BUT THE MAJORITY HAPPEN
AND THE MAJORITY NEVER WILL.
BECAUSE WE'RE RATE CONSCIOUS
AND EVERYTHING THAT WE DO AND I
THINK AT SOME POINT HE NEEDS TO
AN- WE JUST SAW THIS WEEKEND.
IN MARYLAND A MOTHER AND A
CHILD A NINE YEAR OLDS SIGN
WALK INTO A RESTAURANT THE KID
HAD SHORTS ON A JORDAN T.
SHIRT. AND SNEAKERS. AND THE
WHITE MANAGER THAT NIGHT THAT
BLACK MOTHER AND THAT CHILD HE
SAID HE WAS NOT DRESSED
APPROPRIATE WERE RIGHT ACROSS
THE ROOM YOU SAW A WHITE KIA IN
THE SAME T. SHIRT AND SHORTS
AND TENNIS SHOES AND THEIR JOIN
A FAMILY MEAL. SO QUIT LAW TO
YOURSELVES AND SEEING RACE IS
NOT A FACTOR AGAIN THIS BILL
DOES NOT ESTABLISH QUOTAS BUT
IT REMOVES THE BARRIERS TO
ALLOW US. TO FACTOR THAT IN
BECAUSE WE FACTORED IN IN
EVERYTHING THAT WE DO IN THE
STATE IN THIS COUNTRY THE
BEDROCK OF WHO WE ARE IN THIS
COUNTRY IS BASED ON REX. A
COUPLE YEARS AGO THE LETTER.
BOB IS. A HEARING. ON DIVERSITY
IN CORPORATIONS. CALIFORNIA
BASED KEPT CORPORATIONS IT WAS
ONLY TWO. IN CALIFORNIA THAT WE
CAN IDENTIFY IT AFRICAN
AMERICANS. ON THEIR BOARD A FEW
MORE HERE WOMEN BUT THE
MAJORITY OF. WHITE MEN WHITE
MALE DOMINATED AND THAT'S WHAT
THIS COUNTRY'S ALL ABOUT ME
WHITE MALE DOMINATED SO THIS IS
A CREATIVE AGAIN NO QUOTAS TO
JUST BALANCE IS THE PLAYING
FIELD FORTY TWO OTHER STATES
HAVE RACE CONSCIOUS ADMISSIONS
BE A TO COLLEGE TO EMPLOYMENT
WEISS IN CALIFORNIA HOW THAT
TOO. I THINK MEMBERS THE TIME
WE'VE SEEN ENOUGH IT'S TIME TO
DO THE RIGHT THING. IT'S TIME
TO END RACISM THAT EXISTING
CALIFORNIA TIME AND RACISM THAT
EXIST IN THIS BUILDING. SOME
THERE AND RACES IN AN EXISTING
AMERICA IT'S TIME TO.
UNDERSTAND IT RACE AND GENDER
ARE FACTORED IN ITS NOTHING
WRONG AT LOOKING AT IT WHEN YOU
DECIDE TO HIRE WE'RE NOT ASKING
FOR A HANDOUT BECAUSE WE STILL
WANT TO HIRE THE MOST QUALIFIED
PERSON. I WAS APPALLED AT THE
ARGUMENTS YESTERDAY IN APPROACH
ABOUT HOW IT WAS GOING TO
DISCRIMINATE AGAINST SOMEBODY.
WE'RE SEEING NO IT DOESN'T IF
YOU HAVE A HIGHER GPA THAN THE
NEXT PERSON YES YOU SHOULD BE
ADMITTED TO COLLEGE WE'RE NOT
SEEING SOMEONE WHO DOESN'T
DESERVE TO GO TO COLLEGE.
SHOULDN'T GO TO COLLEGE BUT
WE'RE SEEING. IF YOU HAVE ANY
OPPORTUNITY TO FACTOR IN
MINORITIES AND SAY HEY WHY IS
THIS PERSON GOING TO COLLEGE.
MY COLLEAGUE WAS FROM DIAMOND
BAR TALK ABOUT THE UNDER
PERFORMANCE OF KIDS TAKE TO
TWELVE. AGAIN RACE HAS A WHOLE
LOT TO DO WITH THAT. WHICH IS
ABOUT. CAN'T GO TO ANOTHER
SCHOOL DISTRICT. A BETTER
SCHOOL DOWN THE ROAD RACE HAS A
WHOLE LOT TO DO WITH IT. SO PUT
LINE TO OUR SEE AN ACTING LIKE
IT DOESN'T HAVE TO HAVE
ANYTHING TO DO WITH WHAT WE'RE
DOING TODAY. THIS IS A RIGHT
HIS BILL I'M HONORED TO BE A CO
AUTHOR. AND I CAN'T UNDERSTAND
A SINGLEPERSON. WHO WOULD VOTE
NO ON THIS BECAUSE ALL IT DOES
IS ALLOW YOUR CONSTITUENTS. THE
RESIDENTS OF CALIFORNIA THE
DECISION THE RIGHT TO MAKE A
DECISION ON WHETHER THEY WANT
TO REMOVE THIS OR NOT WE'RE NOT
DOING IT HERE ALL WE'RE SEEING
IS HERE VOTERS OPPORTUNITY. YOU
ALWAYS TALK ABOUT FAIRNESS YOU
ALWAYS TALK ABOUT OPPORTUNITY
WHY WOULD YOU DENY YOUR
CONSTITUENTS THAT RIGHT TO MAKE
THAT DECISION I RESPECTFULLY UP
FOR A VOTE. SENATOR SENATOR
GROVE. THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT. BECAUSE I WOULD JUST
LIKE TO GO BACK TO WHERE WE
NEED TO START ON THIS
PARTICULAR PIECE OF LEGISLATION
AC EIGHT FIVE WOULD OVERTURN
PROPOSITION TWO OH NINE. WHICH
SAYS AND I QUOTE. THE STATE
SHALL NOT DISCRIMINATE AGAINST
OR GRANT PREFERENTIAL TREATMENT
TO ANY INDIVIDUAL OR GROUP. ON
THE BASIS OF RACE SEX COLOR.
ETHNICITY OR NATIONAL ORIGIN IN
THE OPERATION OF PUBLIC
EMPLOYMENT. PUBLIC EDUCATION OR
PUBLIC KRON CONTRACTING. IN
QUOTE. MY COLLEAGUE FROM SAN
DIEGO SAID THAT WE THE PEOPLE
OF CALIFORNIA SHOULD BE ASHAMED
OF PUTTING PROPOSITION TWO OH
NINE IN TO PLACE. WHY SHOULD
CALIFORNIANS BE SHAME TO PUT
INTO A NINE IN PLACE ONE TWO
ONE NINE SPECIFICALLY SAYS THAT
WE THE PEOPLE OF THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA WILL NOT
DISCRIMINATE IN ANY WAY SHAPE
OR FORM. WILL NOT DISCRIMINATE
OR GRANT ANY PREFERENTIAL
TREATMENT TO ANY INDIVIDUAL OR
GROUP BASED ON THIS THE BASE
BASED ON SEX RACE COLOR
ETHNICITY OR NATIONAL NATIONAL
ORIGIN. FUNDS REPEALING PROP
TWO OH NINE. REMOVES THE
PROTECTIONS REPEALING PROP TWO
OH NINE REMOVES THE PROTECTIONS
THAT WE HAVE TO NOT
DISCRIMINATE AGAINST ANYONE IN
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA. I LOOK
AT WHAT WAS SAID IN SOME OF THE
COMMENTS NGUYEN- WE WERE
LOOKING LISTENING TO MY A GOOD
CALLING IT WAS JUST SPEAKING
AND HE MADE COMMENTS ABOUT THE
COLLEAGUES COMMENTS FROM
DIAMOND BAR ABOUT LOW
SOCIOECONOMIC SCHOOL
DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES. IT'S
NOT IT'S A SHAME THAT THE ZIP
CODE THAT IS USED IN WHERE
PEOPLE LIVE IS THE
DETERMINATION. OF THE SCHOOLS
THAT THEY WILL ATTEND. THAT IS
NOT BECAUSE OF RACE THAT IS
BECAUSE THE POLICY SET FORTH IN
THIS BUILDING. POLICIES THAT
REQUIRE THOSE APPEARANCE IN
THOSE LOW SOCIO ECONOMIC
DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES TO
ATTEND THE POOR PERFORMING
PUBLIC SCHOOLS THAT ARE IN
THOSE DISTRICTS. IF GOOD POLICY
WAS PASSED OUT OF THIS BUILDING
IT'S GOOD POLICY WITH PASSED
OUT OF THIS BUILDING. THE
PARENTS WOULD HAVE THE
OPPORTUNITY TO CHOOSE WHAT
WOULD BE BEST FOR THEIR
CHILDREN INCLUDING CHARTER
SCHOOLS WHERE WE STOOD ON THE
STEPS OUTSIDE OF THIS CAPITAL
WITH BLACK AND LATINO FAMILIES
JUST LAST YEAR. WANTING
CHILDREN TO BE ABLE TO CAN
CHARTER SCHOOLS WE GAVE THEM A
PERFORMANCE EDUCATION AND ALLOW
THEM TO ACHIEVE THE ABILITY TO
GET OUT OF THE SITUATION THEY
FOUND THEMSELVES IN. IN THESE
COMMUNITIES THEY SET UP THERE
IN THE BED AND THEY PICKETED
AND THEY HELD UP SIGNS FOR YOU
NOT TO DEMOLISH OR DESPAIR AND
OR TO PRE TELL CHARTER SCHOOLS.
AND THEY ASKED FOR A CHOICE IN
THIS BODY ON THE OTHER SIDE OF
THE AISLE EVERYONE OF THEM THE-
BILL. WOULD NOT GIVE THOSE
PARENTS THAT CHOICE WE NEED TO
START AT THE LEVEL OF K.
THROUGH TWELVE AND GIVING
PARENTS THE OPPORTUNITY TO BE
ABLE TO CHOOSE THE BEST SCHOOL
THEIR CHILDREN. AND NOT MAKE
THEM ZIP CODES IN WHICH- LIVING
IN. AND BECAUSE OF THE PALM.
THAT ARE PASSED IN BUILDING. I
LOOK AT WHAT AC FIVE A WILL DO
AS WELL WHEN WE LOOK AT CHANGES
IN STANDING CAREER TECHNICAL
EDUCATION PROGRAMS THAT EQUIP
STUDENTS WITH THE TOOLS THAT
THEY NEED FOR THEIR FUTURE
THOSE POLICIES ARE ALSO
RETAILED IN THIS BUILDING. NOT
EVERY KID WANTS TO GO TO
COLLEGE I DIDN'T GO TO COLLEGE
NOT EVERY STUDENT I HAVE PEOPLE
THAT WORK IN IN MY DISTRICT AND
EVEN OUT OF THE BUSINESS THAT I
HAVE THEIR DAD IN THEIR GRANDPA
WAS AUTUMN AND I CAN THESE
YOUNG KIDS LEARN ALL THE WAY
UP. THAT SHADE TREE MECHANIC
RULE AND THEY KNOW EVERYTHING
ABOUT CARS THEY HAVE NO DESIRE
TO GO TO COLLEGE THEY WANT TO
BE ABLE TO GO TO A TRADE OR
TECHNICAL SCHOOL THAT WILL
ALLOW THEM TO LEARN A TRADE
THAT VANCE THEM IN THEIR
CAREER. BUT WE IN THIS BUILDING
PAST POLICIES THAT STOP THAT
FROM HAPPENING. I IMPLORE. TO
FOLLOW WHAT MY COLLEAGUE FROM
DIAMOND BAR SAID. THERE IS AN
ISSUE THAT NEEDS TO BE
ADDRESSED ABOUT EDUCATION AND
HIGHER EDUCATION. THERE IS AN
ISSUE THAT NEEDS TO BE
ADDRESSED ABOUT RACISM. BUT THE
BOTTOM LINE IS THAT THIS BILL
DOES NOT DO IT THIS BILL ONLY
REPEALS. WHAT THE STATE AND THE
PEOPLE OF CALIFORNIA VOTED FOR
WHEN THEY STOOD PROUDLY IN
VOTED FOR THIS BILL. IT SAID
THAT THEY WILL NOT
DISCRIMINATE. AGAINST ANYONE.
FOR THE COLOR OF THEIR SKIN.
FOR NATIONAL ORIGIN. AGAINST
ANYTHING. THEY STOOD IN THE
VOTED IN THE SAID WE WILL STAND
AS CALIFORNIANS THIS DIVERSE
STATE WE WILL NOT DISCRIMINATE
AGAINST PEOPLE FOR THESE
REASONS. THAT'S WHAT AB TWO
OURS PROPOSITION TWO OH NINE
SAYS. AN S. C. FIVE REPEALS TWO
OH NINE. IT SETS FORTH BEFORE
THE VOTERS TO REPEAL THAT
STATUTE. IN OUR CONSTITUTION
AND SO RESPECTFULLY I DO
BELIEVE THAT WE HAVE AN ISSUE
THAT NEEDS TO BE ADDRESSED BUT
AC FIVE IS NOT THE ANSWER AC
FIVE IS A CALL TO WHAT'S GOING
ON IN OUR COMMUNITIES NOW. BUT
TO CREATE DISCRIMINATION POLICY
BY REMOVING THE ABILITY FOR THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA AND ALL OF
ITS CITIZENS CITIZENS NOT TO
DISCRIMINATE IS NOT THE CORRECT
WAY TO DO THIS AND I ASKED FOR
A NUMBER. CENTER LEYVA. THANK
YOU MADAM PRESIDENT- GOOD
MORNING GOOD AFTERNOON MEMBERS
OF I WOULD JUST HAVE TO START
WAS SAYING THERE'S SOME THINGS
I'M JUST APPALLED THAT I HERE
ON THIS FLOOR AND I'M NOT EVEN
GOING TO GO INTO THE WORDS THAT
WE JUST HEARD FROM THE SENATOR
FROM THE CENTRAL VALLEY. TO
THIRTEEN YEAH WRONG I AM VERY
REAL WORDS AND YOU ARE RIGHT
RACISM HAPPENS EVERY SINGLE DAY.
I WOULD SAY I'M VERY PROUD THAT
I'M THE ONLY WHITE PERSONON MY
STAFF IN MY DISTRICT OFFICE AND
WHEN I HIRED BUT THE PEOPLE IN
THAT OFFICE I HEARD THEM BASED
ON THEIR ABILITY NOT BASED ON
THE COLOR OF THEIR SKIN AND
THEY'LL DO A FANTASTIC JOB. BUT
I RISE BECAUSE IS THE CHAIR OF
THE WOMEN'S CAUCUS I STAND IN
VERY STRONG SUPPORT OF A CA
FIVE THIS MORNING THIS
IMPORTANT MEASURE THE PRIORITY
FOR THE WOMEN'S CAUCUS AND IS
CRITICAL THE CALIFORNIANS WHO
IMPLEMENTED OPPOSITION TO OWN
NINE YEARS AGO. GET THE
OPPORTUNITY TO REPEAL THIS
HORRIBLE MAJOR. HERBAL BECAUSE
IT SET BACK YEARS OF PROGRESS
FOR BLACKS. OTHER RACIAL
MINORITIES WOMEN IN OUR STATE.
MEMBERS RACISM IS CLEARLY A
REALITY TO THIS DAY. AND IT IS
IMPORTANT THAT WE FIGHT BACK
AGAINST THE EFFECTS OF RACISM
ON EDUCATION. AND OTHER VENUES
IN OUR SOCIETY. WE JUST HEARD
THAT SOME OF US MIGHT BE VOTING
ON THIS. IN FAVOR BECAUSE OF
WHAT'S HAPPENING RIGHT NOW. I
WOULD CHALLENGE THAT I WOULD
SAY WE'RE VOTING ON THIS RIGHT
NOW BECAUSE IT'S TIME IT'S PAST
TIME. IT PEOPLE MARCHING IN THE
STREETS FOR EACH EQUALITY AND
EQUITY GET YOU TO VOTE SO THIS
MAJOR. TASK PROP WHEN I MAY AT
THE TENT TO HELP THE VERSE CITY.
HAD THE OPPOSITE EFFECT FOR
ASSET YOU STAND WITH ME AND
STAND ON THE RIGHT SIDE OF
HISTORY AND VOTE FOR A CA FIVE.
SO THAT THE PUBLIC HAS THE
OPPORTUNITY TO FINALLY STOP THE
ILL EFFECTS OF PROP TWO OH NINE
THANK YOU. SENATOR BARGES.
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT. I'LL
NEVER FORGET A STORY THAT MY
FATHER TOLD ME WHEN HE WAS
YOUNGER. THAT HE WAS EMPLOYED
AT AN ESTABLISHMENT IN A
SUPERIOR CAME TO HIM. AND
QUICKLY USHERED HIM INTO A-
LOCKER AREA. AND WHEN MY FATHER
ASKED WHY HE SAID BECAUSE THE
OWNERS COMING BY. AND HE
DOESN'T LIKE IMMIGRANTS IN HELL
FIRE YOU IF HE SEES THAT YOU'RE
A GREEK IMMIGRANT. I HAD THE
HONOR OF REPRESENTING FRESNO
COUNTY AS WELL AS TEN OTHERS IN
MY VERY LARGE DISTRICT. BUT I
REMEMBER LEARNING THAT IN
FRESNO THERE WERE ANTI ARMENIAN
COVENANTS. WRITTEN INTO THE
LAND USE POLICIES AND RULES OF
OUR AREA AND THE CENTRAL VALLEY.
IN OTHER WORDS ARMENIANS COULD
NOT BUY PROPERTY IN CERTAIN
AREAS THEY WERE DISALLOWED IN
OTHERS. I THINK IF YOU IN
PRETORIA WHO WATER FOR OUR
FRIEND FROM- KERR DEAN IS OUR
CENTER FROM CORDY IS HAD
IDENTIFIED. RACE IS.
PROBLEMATIC IN PUBLIC POLICY
AND HOW WE CONDUCT OURSELVES AS
A STATE IF HISTORY IS ANY
INDICATION. WHERE THE IRISH OR
YOU'RE JEWISH- GREEK ARMENIAN
OR YOU'RE CHINESE WE ARE
REPLETE WITH EXAMPLES IN
AMERICA OF DISCRIMINATORY
PRACTICES AND POLICIES. NOW MY
FRIEND FROM- A CENTER FROM LOS
ANGELES BROUGHT UP- THE REGIONS
OF CALIFORNIA V. BAKI I
REMEMBER STUDYING THAT IN LAW
SCHOOL WAS VERY INTERESTING
PIVOTAL CASE- THE STATE'S BACK
TO NINETEEN SEVENTY EIGHT WHERE
THE SUPREME COURT REJECTED. THE
USE OF STRICT RACIAL QUOTAS. AT
WITH THAT HAT WAS INTERESTING
STRICT RACIAL QUOTAS. AND THEN
IN TWENTY SIXTEEN WITH PROP WO
OH NINE TUNE NINE REJECTED IT
THE POLICY OF OUR GREAT
AFFIRMATIVE ACTION. NOW WE'VE
HEARD COMMENTARY TODAY THAT IT
SHE THE EXACT OPPOSITE OF THAT.
THAT IS BECOME ENCUMBRANCE AND
THE DIFFICULTY TO FOLKS
SEEKING- EMPLOYMENT IN
ADMISSION INTO HIGHER EDUCATION.
BUT SINCE THAT TIME
UNIVERSITIES AND JOBS
OPPORTUNITIES HAVE BEEN ALLOWED
TO USE RACE AS ONE OF MANY
CONSIDERATIONS IN HIRING OR
ADMISSIONS. SO THIS IDEA THAT
AFFIRMATIVE ACTION DOESN'T
EXIST IS STOP ACTUALLY ACCURATE
WE HAVE AFFIRMATIVE ACTION
POLICIES IN BOTH THE PUBLIC AND
PRIVATE SPHERES ACROSS OUR
STATE ACROSS OUR NATION. IT
EXISTS HE GIVES CONSIDERATION
TO ECONOMIC BACKGROUND RACE
BACKGROUND SEX. IN A NUMBER OF
OTHERS SO WE ALREADY HAVE
AFFIRMATIVE ACTION POLICIES
DESPITE THE FACT THAT TWO OH
NINE SAYS THAT WE SHOULDN'T. SO
WE HAVE A CONTRADICTION HERE
THAT IS IT IS IT IS TROUBLING
ESPECIALLY IN LIGHT OF THE
HEIGHTENED TENSIONS THAT WE'VE
EXPERIENCE OF THE LAST COUPLE
OF MONTHS. BUT MY CONCERN IS
THAT. ACA FIVE. IS A PRELUDE.
TO INSTITUTIONALIZING QUOTAS.
AND THAT TO ME IS A CONCERN.
AND I THINK IT SHOULD BE A
CONCERN FOR EVERYONE BECAUSE
THAT'S PRECISELY WHAT WE DID
NOT WANT TO HAVE HAPPEN. AND IN
OTHER WORDS IT WOULD BE THE END
OF THE EQUAL PROTECTION CLAUSE
PROTECTIONS IN THE U. S.
CONSTITUTION. SO USING
DISCRIMINATION TO COMBAT
DISCRIMINATION IS NOT JUST AN
OXYMORON AND PRINCIPLE. IT'S
BAD POLICY. I WOULD ARGUE THAT
WE CANNOT SIMULTANEOUSLY BE
DISCRIMINATORY. IN EFFORT TO
ADDRESS DISCRIMINATION. AND I
THINK THAT TO SUPPORT THIS
WOULD BE TO REJECT THE EQUAL
PROTECTION CLAUSE OF THE UNITED
STATES CONSTITUTION. IN SUPPORT
OF EQUAL PROTECTION. WE ARE
LITERALLY GETTING. DROWNED OUT
BY THE TENSIONS THAT EXIST IN
REAL TERMS AND THEY ARE VERY
REAL DISCRIMINATION RACIAL
PROFILING. DISADVANTAGED
COMMUNITIES IN UPWARD- MOBILITY
THESE ARE VERY SERIOUS PROBLEMS
THAT WE HAVE. BUT THE IDEA OF
ON DOING AN ANTI DISCRIMINATION
POLICY IN OUR CONSTITUTION IN
FAVOR OF DISCRIMINATION JUST
DOESN'T DOESN'T PASS THE SMELL
TEST. SO I KNOW THAT A LOT OF
FOLKS ARE GOING TO HAVE YOU
KNOW STRONG OPINIONS ON THIS.
BUT I THINK. ALLOWING US TO USE
THE MECHANISMS THAT ARE IN
PLACE RIGHT NOW IN GETTING
BETTER ASK THEM. WE HEARD Y. K.
THROUGH TWELVE. IS A
PROBLEMATIC PERIOD FOR ON A LOT
OF OUR YOUTH IMPROVING ACCESS
TO EDUCATION IMPROVING THE
SOCIAL SERVICES THE- THE- THE
ZERO THROUGH FIVE DEVELOPMENTAL
STAGES. THE IDEA THAT YOU'RE
GOING TO ARTIFICIALLY. ALLOW
FOLKS INTO A UNIVERSITY SETTING
OR INTO A JOB PLACEMENT SETTING
BY USING QUOTAS IS NOT GOING TO
DEAL WITH THE UNDERLYING
CHALLENGES. THIS IS THE EASY
WAY OUT THE HARD WAY OUT IS TO
ADDRESS THE SYSTEMIC PROBLEMS
THAT- JUST THAT I JUST
MENTIONED IN MY OPINION THANK
YOU. SENATOR JACKSON'S. THANK
YOU ARE MATTER PRESSING
COLLEAGUES A VERY INTERESTING
DISCUSSION BUT- I WANT TO START
US OR ASK YOU TO COME BACK TO
THE BEGINNING OF OUR SESSION.
WHEN THE GOOD CALLING FOR
MONTEBELLO. TALKED ABOUT THE
DALAI LAMA. AND THE NOTION
THERE WHAT WE NEED TO DO IS
PRACTICE HUMAN KINDNESS NO I
DON'T KNOW ABOUT YOU BUT THAT
SIMPLE NOTION ACTUALLY BROUGHT
TEARS TO MY EYES. BECAUSE IF WE
ACTUALLY PRACTICED HUMAN
KINDNESS WE WOULD HAVE NO NEED
FOR WAR. WE WOULD HAVE NO NEED
TO DEVELOP A MILITARY THAT CAN
DESTROY EVERY HUMAN BEING ON
THE PLANET TWENTY TIMES OVER.
WE WOULD HAVE NO NEED. FOR
AFFIRMATIVE ACTION. WE WOULD
HAVE NO NEED. AND WE WOULD NOT
SEE LYNCHINGS OR HOLOCAUST OR
DISCRIMINATION BECAUSE IF WE
ACTUALLY PRACTICED HUMAN
KINDNESS WE WOULD TREAT EACH
OTHER EQUALLY. BUT THAT ISN'T
THE WORLD IN WHICH WE LIVE. AND
FRANKLY IT NEVER HAS BEEN. SO
PART OF OUR JOB IS TO RECOGNIZE
THE ASPIRATION AND TO KEEP
REACHING. FOR A BETTER HUMANITY.
BUT AT THE SAME TIME WE CAN'T
IGNORE THE HUMANITY IN WHICH WE
LIVE AND YES IF WE HAD ZERO TO
FIVE EDUCATION AND YASSER FOR
EVERY CHILD THE OPPORTUNITY TO
LIVE OUTSIDE OF POVERTY AND NOT
LIVE IN FEAR OF GUN VIOLENCE IN
THEIR HOMES OR ON THEIR STREETS
YES THIS WOULD BE A MUCH
DIFFERENT WORLD. BUT THAT IS
NOT THE WORLD YOU LIVE IN. AND
TOOK TWENTY FIVE YEARS AGO WHEN
PROPOSITION TWO OH NINE PASSED
IT OPERATED UPON A-
FUNDAMENTALLY FLAWED NOTION
THAT WE LIVE IN A COLOR BLIND
AND GENDER BLIND SOCIETY. AND
THAT WE DON'T NEED TO RECOGNIZE
ORWE DON'T HAVE ANY LEVELS OF
DISCRIMINATION. AND THEREFORE
WE SHOULDN'T. GIVE ANYONE A
MORE OF AN OPPORTUNITY THAN
ANYONE ELSE. BUT THERE NEVER
WAS REALITY. REALITY WHICH HAS
DEMONSTRATED SHOP OVER THE LAST
TWENTY FIVE YEARS IS EXACTLY
VERY FEW WOMEN ON CORPORATE
BOARDS VERY FEW PEOPLE OF COLOR
AND CORPORATE BOARDS BUT
TEENAGE MAKING FORTY FOUR CENTS
TO EVERY DOLLAR A WHITE MAN
MAKES. WE HAVE SO MANY
INSTANCES. WHERE THERE IS
DISCRIMINATION WHETHER YOU'RE
WALKING PRECINCTS AND SOMEONE
SAYS I'D NEVER VOTE FOR AN
ORIENTAL. WHAT DID THE GOOD
SENATOR FROM THAT AREA EVER DO
TO HAVE SOMEONE SAY. I HATE
CHIU BECAUSE OF WHO YOU ARE OR
I WOULD NEVER CONSIDER TAKING I
WOULD NEVER TAKE YOU SERIOUSLY
BECAUSE OF WHO YOU ARE WE ALL
HAVE STORIES SIDE MENTIONED
SEVERAL TIMES ON THIS FLOOR.
GROWING UP IN IT IN A JEWISH
HOME AS A JEWISH PERSON THE
DISCRIMINATION THAT I FIXED
THAT WE SEE TODAY WHAT WE ARE
TOLD IN. WELL NOT REPLACE US.
AS A WOMAN YOU KNOW MY GOOD
COLLEAGUE FROM GUARDINO TALKED
ABOUT WALKING INTO A ROOM AND
NOT SEEING ANYBODY WHO LOOKS
LIKE YOU I CAN'T TELL YOU HOW
MANY TIMES AS A YOUNG ATTORNEY
BACK IN THE DAY BEFORE WE. HAD
TOO MANY ATTORNEYS FOR GOING
INTO A CO ROOM AND BEING ONLY
IN THE ANTI COURTROOM. IT'S A
STRANGE FEELING BECAUSE YOU
DON'T THINK OF YOURSELF THAT
WAY UNTIL YOU WALK INTO THAT
ROOM AND REALIZE YOU'RE THE
ONLY ONE WHO LOOKS LIKE YOU. SO
THAT'S THE REALITY. HUMAN
KINDNESS IS ASPIRIN. IT'S
SOMETHING WE NEED TO STRIVE
FOR. BUT UNTIL WE STOP THE
LYNCHINGS AND STILL WE TALKED
TO STOP THE HATRED AND STILL WE
SHOULD STOP THE NOTION OF MY
NATION'S BIGGER THAN YOUR
NATION A WILL READ A CAKE YOU
FROM THE FACE OF THE EARTH.
UNTIL WE STOP BEHAVING THAT WAY.
WE HAVE GOT TO LOOK AT
OURSELVES IN THE MIRROR AND SAY
HOW CAN WE DO THIS BETTER. AND
SO OPPOSITION TO NINE OPERATED
UNDER A FALSE SENSE OF REALITY.
WHAT THIS EFFORT DOES TODAY IT
SHOULD SIMPLY SAYS TO THE
PEOPLE OF CALIFORNIA GIVEN WHAT
WE HAVE SEEN IN THE LAST TWENTY
FIVE YEARS DO WE WANT TO REALLY
THINK. THIS NOTION THAT WE LIVE
IN A COLOR BLIND AND GENDER
BLIND WORLD. DO WE WANT TO
RECOGNIZE AND TRIED TO HELP
OTHERS WHO HAVE BEEN LESS
FORTUNATE THAN WE- THAN MANY OF
US YOU KNOW WE TALK ABOUT THE
GREAT UNIVERSITY CALIFORNIA THE
BARKING CASE WHICH MY GOOD
COLLEAGUE MENTIONED. THAT WAS A
CASE DEALING WITH THE
UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA WHICH
WAS TRYING TO HELP INCENTIVIZE
AND ALLOW MORE PEOPLE OF COLOR
AND UNDERSERVED COMMUNITIES GET
THE OPPORTUNITY TO GO TO
COLLEGE AND WHAT THE UNIVERSITY
WAS TOLD AND SUBSEQUENTLY TOLD.
YOU CAN'T EVEN CONSIDER THAT.
YOU HAVE TO PRETEND LIKE
EVERYBODY HAD THE SAME
OPPORTUNITIES GROWING UP. AND
WE REALIZE THAT ISN'T TRUE AND
SO LET'S TAKE THE STEPS NOW TO
GIVE PEOPLE AN OPPORTUNITY TO
RE THINK. TO CONSIDER TO KEEP
TRYING TO AN ASPIRING TO A
KINDER MORE EQUAL WORLD WE ARE
NOT THERE. WE ARE NOT EVEN
CLOSE TO THERE WE HAVE NEVER
PASSED AN EQUAL RIGHTS
AMENDMENT WOMEN ARE NOT
CONSIDERED EQUAL IN THE EYES OF
THE LAW. AND CERTAINLY PEOPLE
WHO COME TO US WHO HAVE
DIFFERENT COLOR SKIN OR
DIFFERENT LIFE EXPERIENCES ARE
DIFFERENT ETHNICITIES OR
DIFFERENT NATIONALITIES ARE
DIFFERENT RELIGIONS. ARE NOT
TREATED EQUALLY. AND THIS BILL.
GIVES THE PEOPLE OF CALIFORNIA
AN OPPORTUNITY TO RECOGNIZE
THAT. AND TO ALSO RECOGNIZE NOT
THE ONE WILL GET A LEG UP
BECAUSE OF THEIR RACE OR
BECAUSE OF THEIR GENDER THEY
WILL CHARGE TAPPING THE EQUAL
OPPORTUNITY. THAT'S WHAT THIS
BILL DOES AND THAT'S WHY BIRD
DRIVE VOTE. SENATOR WESSEL.
THANK YOU AND PRESENTERS I FEEL
THAT MY COLLEAGUE FROM KERN
ASKED ME A QUESTION I FELT
COMPLIED TO REPLY BECAUSE SHE
ASKED A VERY IMPORTANT QUESTION.
AND THERE IS A VERY. VERY
IMPORTANT ANSWER I MEAN THIS
IS- THE ESSENCE OF PROP TWO
NINE. WAS IT MISLED
CALIFORNIANS. REPRESENTED OF
LANGUAGES SAID WE SHALL KNOW
THAT THE UNIVERSITY SHOULD NOT
DISCRIMINATE WHO WOULD NOT
SUPPORT THAT. AND I MENTION THE
60% OF LATINOS SUPPORTED IT
THINKING THAT IT WAS AN ANTI
DISCRIMINATION MEASURE. BUT
PRIOR TO THAT THE ARGUMENTS
WERE MADE THAT THEY- A STUDENT
THAT HAD BETTER GRADES HAVE NOT
BEEN ADMITTED. TO ONE OF OUR
UNIVERSITIES BECAUSE A PERSON
WITH LESS GRADES HAD AND THAT
THEY WERE DENIED A SPOT. AND
THAT WAS THE ARGUMENT SO THEY
MADE OF THE PERSON WHO WAS NOT
ADMITTED BECAUSE OF. THERE UP
SUPPOSEDLY BECAUSE OF THE RACE.
THAT THEY WERE THE PERSON
DISCRIMINATING AGAINST. BUT MY
QUESTION RETURN IS IF THIS IS
AN ANTI DISCRIMINATION MEASURE
WHY SINCE THE PASSAGE OF TWO
NINE DO WE HAVE LESS STUDENTS
OF COLOR NUMBER UNIVERSITIES
WHY HAS IT GONE DOWN IF IT'S
REALLY ABOUT NON DISCRIMINATION
WE SHOULD HAVE THAT NUMBER
SHOULD HAVE INCREASED. BUT IS
GONE DOWN. AND OFTEN I FEEL
WHEN I THINK OF PROP TWO NINE
THAT. THE BEST WAY TO
CHALLENGES AFTER NOW OF TWENTY
FOUR YEARS OF DATA. THAT WE
SHOULD CHALLENGE PROP TWO NINE
THE COURTS. BECAUSE IT MOST
CERTAINLY WILL LOSE BECAUSE AN
ANTI DISCRIMINATION MEASURE HAS
REALLY RESULT IN DISCRIMINATION
AND I ALSO WANT TO EXPLAIN HOW
THIS ACTUALLY WORKS OUT
PRACTICALLY. AND I WANT TO GIVE
YOU MY STORY. AND A STORY OF
ONE OF MY- OF A THIS IS A
SCHOOL. I GRADUATED FROM
PORTLAND MY HIGH SCHOOL. WITH A
BAND. BUT I REMEMBER I HAD A
FRIEND THAT ALSO WENT TO UCLA.
HE WAS THE SON. OF A VERY
PROMINENT DOCTOR AND A
PROMINENT JUDGE FROM SAN DIEGO.
AND GROWING UP HE HAD TUTORS HE
DIDN'T HAVE TO WORK GROWING UP
WE NEVER HAD A JOB. HE WAS OF A
VERY EXCELLENT STUDENT. BUT HE
HAD HE LIVED IN A BEAUTIFUL
HOME IN POINT LOMA. AND HAD A
VERY HIGH QUALITY OF LIFE. AND
HE GOT EXCELLENT GRADES WHAT I
WANT TO POINT MY HIGH SCHOOL I
USED TO GET UP AT FOUR IN THE
MORNING AND DO MY PAPER OUT TO
DELIVER PAPERS TWO HUNDRED
THIRTY TWO HOMES MY
NEIGHBORHOOD. BALL BEFORE SIX
AM. I OFTENTIMES WHAT'S WAS
LATE BECAUSE OF RAIN OR
WHATEVER FACTORS THAT MADE ME
LOOK RELATE SO I OFTEN WAS
RUNNING AFTER THE BUS AND THE
BUS DRIVER MADE A JOKE OF IT
THAT IF I DIDN'T RIGHT EXACTLY
TIME HE SAW ME IN HIS RIVER
NEAR HE TOOK OFF TO MAYBE RUN
AFTER HIM. I RAN TRACK NO
RESTAURANT CROSS COUNTRY SO I
OFTEN CUT THE BUS AT THE NEXT
STOP HALF A MILE LATER. BUT
WHEN I WENT TO SCHOOL. I DID MY
PAPER OUT AFTER SCHOOL I HAD A
JOB. AND I HAVE TO WORK IN MY
FAMILY BUSINESS AND SOMETIMES I
HAD A JOB WORKING AT THE
SHOPPING CENTER. THOUSAND
DOWNTOWN I ALSO AS I MENTIONED
RAN TRACK AND CROSS COUNTRY I
STARTED A CLUB IN FRONT LOCAL
DISPENSED CLUB BECAUSE THEY
WOULDN'T LET ME START MENCHACA
ONE STAR MITCHELL. AND THE
SCHOOL LEADERS I WAS TO
POLITICAL. BUT I ALSO WAS IN
SPEECH CLUB I ALSO WAS IN
THEATER I WAS IN JAZZ CLUB. I
WAS IN MARCHING BAND. AND I
ALSO- YOU KNOW WAS A CULTURE
BOY ON MY CHURCH. AND SO WHAT
WHAT YOURS WHAT THIS MEASURE
DID BASICALLY IS WHEN. WHEN MY
SCHOOL MATE APPLY TO UCLA. I
WHEN I APPLIED BACK THEN. I GOT
I GRADUATED THE TOP PERCENTILE
I CRIED REFER DISTANCE
DISTINCTION AYE I NEVER READ MY
DIPLOMA UNTIL LIKE TWENTY YEARS
LATER NICE BUT I WILL GRADUATE
FROM DISTINCT DISTINCTION. AND
I DON'T EVEN KNOW. BUT WHEN I
APPLY TO UCLA THEY HAD AN
OPPORTUNITY TO LOOK AT. THE
FACT THAT I WORKED. TWENTY
HOURS A WEEK THAT I WAS IN
TRACK AND FIELD AND CROSS
COUNTRY AND THAT I OF DIDN'T
HAD A NEW PAPER ROUTE THAT I
WAS IN CLUBS AND ACT AND I WAS
THEATER AND I WAS IN MUSIC. AND
NOW THE YOU DID ME AS A PERSON.
THAT WOULD BRING SOMETHING OF
VALUE NOT ONLY TO THE
UNIVERSITY. BUT TO SOCIETY. AND
UNDER PROP TWO OH NINE THAT
THEY COULD ONLY LOOK AT MY
GROUP AT MY GPA AND MY A CITY
SCORES SO WHAT ALL OF YOU ARE
SAYING BY OPPOSING THIS MEASURE
IS IT DOESN'T MATTER. BUT I HAD
A JOB AND THAT WAS COMPETING
AGAINST SOMEBODY THAT AME FROM
AN AFFLUENT HOME WITHOUT A JOB.
IT DIDN'T MATTER THAT IT CAME.
FROM A DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITY
WITH WHAT LOWER QUALITY SCHOOLS
YEAH I WAS ABLE TO. OF DON'T
APPLY TO COLLEGES THAT WANT TO
GO TO COLLEGE IMPROVE MYSELF I
WANT LOTS OF PEOPLE TO SCHOOL
BUT NOW THEY CAME FROM POOR
FAMILIES A BECAUSE WE GOT A
CHANCE TO GO TO YOU SEE OKAY
NOW ARE LEADERS IN THE
COMMUNITY ENGINEERS HELPING ALL
TRENDS ARE THE PLUGGED INTO OUR
SOCIETY REVERSING COOL POVERTY
GET NOW NOW THEY DO THEIR KIDS
DON'T NEED HELP BECAUSE THEY
COME FROM HOME. WITH WITH WITH
THE WITH THE PARENT COLLEGE AND
THERE ARE NUMEROUS STUDIES THAT
HAVE ALREADY BEEN DONE LESIONS
ON THE SHOW. THAT THE CHILDREN.
OF PARENTS THAT COLLEGE. HAVE A
96% CHANCE OF GOING TO COLLEGE
AND THE CHILDREN. OF PARENTS IT
DIDN'T GO TO COLLEGE OF A 4%
CHANCES FLIPPER. YOUR
LIKELIHOOD OF ACTUALLY EVEN
WANTING TO GO TO COLLEGE
READING OF APPLYING TO COLLEGE.
OR MEET HARDER IF YOUR PARENTS
DIDN'T GO TO COLLEGE. YOU HAVE
TO ADJUST FOR THAT IN SOCIETY
WHY DON'T WE LOOK AT THE PERSON
THE APPLICANT AND SAY. YOU ARE
GONNA BE. FANTASTIC IN OUR
UNIVERSITY. WE YOU BRING
ANOTHER SKILL SET THAT WE
DESPERATELY NEED THAT'S WHERE.
MY ARGUMENTS OF DIVERSE CITY
CAME IN AND THAT'S WHAT I
WANTED ALL OF YOU TO UNDERSTAND
AND I APOLOGIZE IF I DIDN'T
MAKE MY POINT. AND I LEAVE THE
QUESTION IF. AGAIN I'LL ASK IT
ONE MORE TIME IF THIS IS REALLY
AN ANTI DISCRIMINATION MEASURE
WHY IS THE RESULT
DISCRIMINATION. SENATOR RUBIO.
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT TODAY
I JUST WANNA FIRST OF ALL HIDE
LIGHT THE TESTIMONY OF MY GOOD
FRIEND AND SENATOR FROM
GUARDINO I JUST WANT TO SAY
THAT I HEAR YOUR PASSION YOUR
PAIN BECAUSE I THINK IN SOME
WAY ONE IN ONE WAY OR ANOTHER
ALL OF US HAVE BEEN THERE IN
THAT MOMENT THAT WE FELT
DISCRIMINATED AGAINST. AND SO I
WANT TO JUST BRING MY PERSONAL
EXPERIENCE TO THIS AND I THINK
I'VE TOLD THE STORY OFTEN THAT
WHEN I WAS IN HIGH SCHOOL I
WENT TO MY COLLEGE COUNSELOR TO
SAY THAT I WANTED TO GO TO
COLLEGE AND I WAS TOLD THAT.
THAT'S NOT A PLACE FOR ME THAT
TEEN US- THAT WAS A COLLEGE
MATERIAL LATINOS. WERE MEANT TO
GET MARRIED AND HAVE BABIES.
AND BECAUSE OF BAD. ADVICE I
DIDN'T GO TO COLLEGE. UNTIL I
WAS TWENTY FIVE. AND SO.
DISCRIMINATION ISRAEL AND- ALL
OF US HAVE. AT SOME POINT OR
ANOTHER HAVE FELT IT AND IN
DIFFERENT WAYS. AND I WOULD SAY
SOME OF US MORE THAN OTHERS
BECAUSE I HEARD THE TESTIMONY
FROM. MY FRIEND FROM GARDENA
THAT'S- VERY POWERFUL AND I'M
SORRY FOR ALL THOSE MOMENTS
THAT YOU FELT. YOU WERE LESS
THAN BECAUSE OF WHO YOU ARE.
AND SO I ALSO WANT TO POINT OUT
TO MISCONCEPTIONS THAT I OFTEN
HEAR THAT. ARE REALLY
DISTRESSING TO ME I OFTEN HEAR
THAT. PEOPLE THAT ARE
SUPPORTING A CA FIVE PAR IT'S
NOT A TEEN- BILL- IN IN THIRTY
HERE ON THE FLOORWE HEARD- THE
API CAUCUS. BLACK HAWK IS
LATINO CAUCUS. AND SO I JUST
WANT TO CLARIFY THAT THERE IS
SUPPORT FOR THIS NOT ONLY
ACROSS OUR GROUPS HERE BUT
ACROSS OUR STATE. AND SO I WANT
TO POINT OUT THAT EVEN OUR
STATE COMPTROLLER BABIES
SUPPORT SAID. THE LARA ARM.
SUPPORT CENTER INSURANCE
COMMISSIONER THE FRESNO BLACK
CAUCUS I'M SORRY BLACK CHAMBER
AND AT THE CENTRAL VALLEY.
ASIAN AMERICANS ADVANCING
JUSTICE IN LOS ANGELES DOWN
SOUTH. WE ALSO HAVE THE SAN
FRANCISCO BOARD OF SUPERVISORS
DISTRICT TO UP NORTH I REALLY
JUST WANT TO POINT OUT HOW
BROAD THE SUPPORT IS IT'S NOT A
LATINO BILL AN AFRICAN AMERICAN
BILL THE API CAUCUS BILL THIS
IS SOMETHING THAT COLLECTIVELY
WE SUPPORT ACROSS THE STATE.
AND I THINK THAT WOULD YOU KNOW
I'VE HEARD MANY OF. THE PEOPLE
THAT OPPOSE IT KEEP TELLING ME
IT'S A LATINO BILL IT'S NOT. ON
SECOND I ALSO WANT TO POINT OUT
THAT MANY TIMES I HEAR THAT WE
JUST WANT AN OPPORTUNITY TO GO
TO COLLEGE EVEN THOUGH WE'RE
NOT QUALIFIED. AND I WANT TO
STRONGLY STRONGLY DISAGREE OF
COURSE WERE QUALIFIED. IT'S THE
OTHER WAY AROUND WE TO SLACK
OPPORTUNITIES THOUGHT URGE YOUR
BIBLE THANK YOU. SENATOR
GONZALEZ. IF YOU COULD HOLD
SECOND. TRY AGAIN OKAY THANK
YOU MADAM PRESIDENT IN COLLEGE
TO STAND IN STRONG SUPPORT OF
AC FIVE- I THINK MY OUR
COLLEAGUE FROM LOS ANGELES FOR
BRINGING THIS FORWARD AND I
JUST WANT TO REITERATE WHAT MY
OTHER COLLEAGUES FROM LOS
ANGELES HAD MENTIONED ABOUT
WOMEN IN CONTRACTS AND MINORITY
BUSINESSES AND AS WE KNOW AND I
JUST HAVE TO AGAIN REITERATE
BACK IN THE NINETIES- A
CALIFORNIA AGAIN HAVE THE TOP
PERFORMING STATE TERMS OF
GOVERNMENT CONTRACTING FOR
WOMEN AND MINORITY OWNED
BUSINESSES AGAIN IT WORSENS
DURING THE REPEAL OF PROP TWO
OH NINE BECOMING ONE OF THE
LEAST RACIALLY DIVERSE STATES
WHEN IT CAME TO. GOVERNMENT
CONTRACTING AGAIN LESS THAN
NEBRASKA WHICH IS NOT A VERY
GOOD AS WE KNOW WOMEN WERE-
TACKLING CONTRACTING AGAINST
MEN MOSTLY INCUMBENTS. A
HOMOGENEOUS SYSTEM OF
CONTRACTING THAT- TOOK OVER OUR
STATE OVER ONE BILLION DOLLARS
IN CONTRACTING LOSSES WERE
FILLED BY WOMEN. AND MINORITY
OWNED BUSINESSES AND WOMEN IN
MY ALREADY OWN BUSINESSES
DURING THIS TIME. ACTUALLY
GROUPS OF THE LIGHT AT THE END
OF THE TUNNEL WAS JUST VERY
SMALL BUT IT GREW BECAUSE-
BECAUSE WHY THEY WERE LOCKED
OUT OF. GOVERNMENT JOBS AND
THEY WERE LOCKED OUT OF HIGHER
EDUCATION THEY HAD NO OTHER
OPPORTUNITY BUT TO CREATE THEIR
OWN BUSINESSES. BUT AS WE KNOW
SELF EMPLOYED WOMEN SELF
EMPLOYED MINORITIES HIRE WOMEN
AND THEY HIRE A MINORITY
WORKFORCE THEY ALSO CAN CREATE
SUPPLEMENT MARKETS- TO BUILD
CAPITAL NETWORKS AND SUPPLIES
AND SKILLS AND SUPPLY CHAINS
AND AS THE FEDERAL CARES ACT IS
PROVIDING TEN MILLION DOLLARS
FOR MINORITY OWNED BUSINESSES
DURING THIS TIME. IT MAKES THE
MOST SENSE TO PROVIDE AN
OPPORTUNITY FOR VOTERS TO WEIGH
IN WHY NOT GIVE THEM A GREATER
SHARE OF THE PROSPERITY IN THE
WORLD'S FIFTH LARGEST ECONOMY.
SPECIALLY AS WERE INVESTING AT
THE STATE AND FEDERAL LEVELS
FOR THESE COMMUNITIES. AND ARE
AS BUSINESSES ARE STRUGGLING TO
COME BACK ON LINE. THE LAST
THING I'LL SAY IS WHEN YOU'VE
ALWAYS HAD A SEAT AT THE TABLE
AC FIVE SEEMS LIKE AN INJUSTICE
BUT WHEN YOU'VE SEEN AND
JUSTICE AND YOU FELT AND
JUSTICE YOUR WHOLE LIFE AC FIVE
IS TRULY AN OPPORTUNITY AND FOR
THAT I STAND STRONG SUPPORT OF
EASY FIVE. SENATOR MELENDEZ.
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT- AND
THANK YOU COLLEAGUES FOR. ALL
OF THE COMMENTS THAT WERE MADE
HERE SO FAR ON THIS BILL. I SAT
AND LISTENED TO MY COLLEAGUE
FROM GARDENA. TWO I LOVE. AND.
THAT WAS AND- I SHOW THAT WAS
PASSION. COMING FROM HIM THAT
IS DEEP PAIN AND HURT. THAT WAS
GENUINE. COMING FROM HIM. A
NIGHT ACTUALLY I APPRECIATE
THOUGH IT'S HARD TO LISTEN TO I
APPRECIATE HEARING IT I THINK-
WE GET ALL STEVEN TO HEAR IT
FROM TIME TO TIME AND BE
REMINDED. OF THE INJUSTICES
THAT HAVE BEEN- FELT BY SOME OF
OUR FOLKS THROUGHOUT THE
HISTORY OF THIS COUNTRY. BUT I.
PATENTLY REJECT THE NOTION THAT
THIS STATE IS RECESSED OR THAT
THIS COUNTRY IS RACIST. THIS IS
THE LEAST RACIST COUNTRY ON THE
PLANET. WE HAVE PEOPLE WHO HAVE
DEEP HATE IN THEIR HEART BIGOTS
RACISTS WHO LIVE IN THIS
COUNTRY ABSOLUTELY NO ONE CAN
DENY THAT. AND AT TIMES WE HAD
TO WORK ALONGSIDE THEM. WE HAD
TO SUFFER LISTENING TO THE
RHETORIC THAT COMES OUT OF
THEIR MOUTHS NO ONE IS
DISPUTING THAT. THIS IS A STATE
IN THE COUNTRY OF OPPORTUNITY.
THIS STATE PUT MEASURES IN
PLACE PARTICULAR WITHIN OUR
UNIVERSITY SYSTEM TO ENSURE
THAT EVERYONE HAS AN
OPPORTUNITY. WITHOUT USING
AFFIRMATIVE ACTION. PERCENT
PLANS A GUARANTEED MISSION TO
LOWER INCOME STUDENTS AND THOSE
WHO COME FROM A LOWER ECONOMIC
BACKGROUND. THEY LOOK AT FAMILY
INCOME FAMILY WEALTH PARENTS
EDUCATION LEVEL. THERE'S
FINANCIAL AID SCHOLARSHIPS
GRANTS THE UC SYSTEM GOT RID OF
LEGACY PROGRAM SO THAT THE KIDS
OF THE WEALTHY WHITE STUDENTS
THEIR PARENTS WHO CAME BEFORE
THEM DIDN'T GET A LEG UP ON
SOMEONE ELSE TO WORK JUST AS
HARD MAYBE EVEN HARDER. TO GET
RID OF THAT. THERE IS A NUMBER
OF THINGS. THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA IS PUT IN PLACE TO
ENSURE THAT EVERYONE HAS AN
OPPORTUNITY MY COLLEAGUE FROM.
FRESNO I THINK HE'S WALKING IN
RIGHT NOW- MADE SOME POINTS
THAT WORD WERE SPOT ON FRANKLY
NO AND I HOPE EVERYONE PAID
ATTENTION AT THAT CALIFORNIA
ALREADY HAS A NUMBER OF.
ESSENTIALLY AFFIRMATIVE ACTION
TYPE OF REGULATIONS IN PLACE
THAT'S A FACT. CAN WE DO MORE.
WE CAN'T BUT IS THE ANSWER TO.
ANSWER WHAT ONE THINKS IS
DISCRIMINATION WITH MORE
DISCRIMINATION NO IT'S NOT. WE
WANT OUR YOUNG PEOPLE TO GET
INTO COLLEGE OUR FOLKS ARE
LOOKING TO GET A PARTICULAR JOB
TO GET IT BECAUSE THEY EARNED
IT AND BECAUSE THEY ARE
QUALIFIED INTO NEVER QUESTION
THEMSELVES AND THINK. DID I GET
THIS FOR SOME OTHER REASON TO
NEVER ALLOW ANYBODY ELSE THEY
WORK WITH THE GO TO SCHOOL WITH.
TO LOOK AT THEM AND THINK. HOW
DID YOU GET HERE. THAT'S UNFAIR
TO PUT SOMEONE IN THAT TYPE OF
POSITION. I THINK. THERE ARE A
NUMBER OF. TALENTED STUDENTS
POTENTIAL STUDENTS A NUMBER OF
HIGHLY QUALIFIED INDIVIDUALS IN
THIS STATE WHO. CAN GET THESE
JOBS IN CAN GET AND CAN GET
INTO THE SCHOOLS BECAUSE THEY
BELONG THERE THEY DESERVE IT
AND THEY'VE EARNED IT GIVEN THE
CHANCE TO DO THAT WITHOUT.
PUTTING THEM IN A POSITION. TO
SECOND GUESS THEMSELVES. I MEAN
THIS BUILDING PUTS POLICIES IN
THE PLACE WILK SOMEONE I DON'T
RECALL WHO IT WAS WAS TALKING
ABOUT THE FACT THAT. YOU KNOW
IT STARTS AT THE AT THE LOWER
GRADE LEVEL OF SCHOOL AND HOW
KIDS ARE IN. SCHOOLS THAT JUST
TO BE AREN'T HIGH PERFORMING
AND SO THEY'RE ALREADY BEHIND
WHEN THEY GET TO START WELL WHY
IN THE WORLD IS THIS BODY NOT
DOING SOMETHING TO ENSURE THAT
THOSE KIDS CAN GET INTO THE
VERY BEST K. THROUGH TWELVE
SCHOOLS THEY POSSIBLY CAN. THIS
BODY CONTINUALLY EVERY YEAR WE
HAVE BILLS RELATING TO SCHOOL
CHOICE WHETHER IT'S CHARTER
SCHOOLS HOME SCHOOLS YOU NAME
IT. WE TRY TO PUT THINGS IN
PLACE TO MAKE SURE WE HAVE
LEVEL THE PLAYING FIELD FROM
THE VERY BEGINNING OF THEIR
LIVES TO ENSURE THAT THEY HAVE
AN EQUAL SHOT. AND TIME AFTER
TIME THIS BODY. REFUSES THAT.
DO YOU CAN'T HAVE IT BOTH WAYS
YOU CAN'T SAY WE WANT THEM TO
GET ON TO A GOOD SCHOOL WE WANT
THEM TO HAVE THESE THE
EDUCATIONAL OPPORTUNITIES. BUT
YOU DON'T EVEN ALLOW THEM TO
GET STARTED. YOU CANNOT HAVE IT
BOTH WAYS. I WOULD URGE IN
ABOUT. SENATOR BELL. THANK YOU
MADAM PRESIDENT MEMBERS I RISE
TO. TALK ABOUT TO A IN SUPPORT
IS. CONSTITUTION MOMENT FROM
THE STANDPOINT OF MY EXPERIENCE.
WORKING IN- BUILDING
TRANSPORTATION FACILITIES.
PUBLIC CONTRACTS. NOW PART OF
PART OF THE LAW ACTUALLY
MENTIONS PART OF PUBLIC
CONTRACTS. SO WHEN WE TALK
ABOUT PUBLIC CONTRACTS. WHAT
WE'RE TRYING TO DO. IS WE'RE
TRYING TO HAVE A FAIR PROCESS
OF BIDDING AND AWARDING A
PUBLIC CONTRACTS IN THE BEST
INTEREST FOR THE PUBLIC. AND MY
EXPERIENCE HAVING BACK IN THE
IT ACTUALLY GOES BACK OVER
THIRTY YEARS WHEN I CHAIRED THE
pBOARD IN SANTA CLARA COUNTY SAN
JOSE. OF WE CREATED A- MINORITY
BUSINESS WOMEN ENTERPRISE
PROGRAM. TO SET SOME GOALS TO
HAVE MORE BUSINESSES FROM OUR
COMMUNITY. TO BED AND BE
INVOLVED. IN THE CONSTRUCTION
OF THE TRANSPORTATION
FACILITIES THAT THE VOTERS
APPROVED THE HALF CENT SALES
TAX. AT THAT TIME WE DIDN'T
HAVE PROPOSITION TWO OH NINE.
WE HAD AN OPPORTUNITY. TO GROW
THE INDUSTRY. WE HAD FIRST THE
FIRST PROCESS IS TO HAVE THE
MAIN CONTRACTORS THAT WORK THE
HIGHER. SUBCONTRACTORS MINORITY
WOMEN BUSINESS ENTERPRISE
SUBCONTRACTORS PRETTY SOON WE
HAD MINORITY BUSINESS WOMEN
BUSINESS ENTERPRISE PRIME
CONTRACTORS. SO WE WERE GROWING
pCONTRACTORS WITH HIGHER. PEOPLE
IN THE COMMUNITY. WHO WERE
WORKERS. WHO THEN THEMSELVES
BECAME CONTRACTORS. NOW WHAT IS
THIS IS A GOOD THING WELL. I
LIKE TO HAVE MORE BIDDERS WHEN
I HAVE A PROJECT I DON'T LIKE
TO HAVE A SMALL GROUP OF
BIDDERS I BECOME REAL
SUSPICIOUS WHEN I SEE ONLY ONE.
CONTRACTOR BIDDING ON A PROJECT.
SB US ABOUT THAT'S THE WAY IT
USED TO BE. AND WHEN WE DID
THIS PROGRAM WE HAD SOME PEOPLE
THAT CAME TO ME AND SAID HEY
JIM OF. YOU'RE YOU'RE
DESCRIBING ALL THESE. THESE NEW
RULES. BECAUSE WE CAN COME IN
AND DO THE JOB AND YOU KNOW
CALTRANS SAID OUR WORK WOULD BE
DONE ABOUT SEVENTEEN YEARS WELL
WE SAID WE'RE GOING TO DO IT
OUR WAY WE'RE GONNA HAVE THE
COMMUNITY DO THE WORK WE'RE
GOING TO HAVE MORE CONTRACTORS
BIDDING. AND GUESS WHAT WE GOT
WE GOT THE PROJECT'S FINISHED
ON TIME AND ON BUT BEFORE OF
CALTRANS SAID NOT WITH A DOING
A SEVENTEEN YEARS WE DID NOT
AND A HALF YEARS. FINISHED TENS
OF THE BILLIONS OF DOLLARS
WORTH OF CONSTRUCTION. MORE
BETTORS MEANS MORE COMPETITION
AND BETTER PRICE. IF YOU LOOK
AT THE UNITED MINORITY
CONTRACTORS ASSOCIATION. FOR
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA. IN THE
EARLY NINETIES. YOU'RE LOOKING
OUT THE PUBLIC OFFICIAL THE
YEAR YOUR CHAIR YOUR SENATE
TRANSPORTATION COMMITTEE. I WAS
AWARDED THAT AWARD. AND WE SET
THE TONE FOR CALTRANS. BECAUSE
A LOT OF THE WORK WAS DONE BY
CALTRANS BEFORE THEY DON'T HAVE
VERY MANY BIDDERS. AFTER WE
STARTED DOING WHAT WE DID WE
START HAVING MORE BIDDERS. WE
STARTED LOOKING TO SEVER THEIR
RULES AND FOUND OUT THAT. THEY
INHIBITED BIDDERS. I DON'T
BELIEVE. WE'RE TALKING ABOUT.
CHANGING. OUR VIEWS ABOUT
DISCRIMINATION. BUT WHEN PEOPLE
SAY THEY WANT TO BE COLOR BLIND.
THAT DOESN'T MEAN YOU HAVE TO
BE BLIND. WHEN YOU LOOK AT IT
FROM MY STANDPOINT ON THESE
CONTRACTS IF YOU'RE BLINDED
THERE'S- BELIEVE MAY. THIS IS
NOT THE RIGHT THING THIS IS A
REGRESSION. AFTER PROP TWO OH
NINE. PROP TWO OH NINE
DESTROYED WHAT I WAS TALKING
ABOUT. PROP TWO OH NINE. PUSHED
IT BACKWARDS INTO THE OLD DAYS
BELIEVE ME WHEN. WE WERE
ENGAGED IN WRITING SB ONE. AND
WE PUT SOME REAL HEAVY.
PARTICIPATION REQUIREMENTS OF
INVOLVEMENT YOU KNOW WE COULD
PUT. THE CARD OF PARTICIPATION
RULES WE HAD BACK IN THE HEYDAY
WHEN WE DID IN THE NINETIES.
BUT THE CENTER FROM GUARDIAN I.
CREATED A- SET A SET OF
STATUTES. THAT REQUIRED MORE
PARTICIPATION BUT I THINK IT'S
SHAMEFUL DON'T SHOOT. THREE
QUARTERS OF THE CONSTRUCTION
INDUSTRY ON OUR TRANSPORTATION
FACILITIES. OUR WOMEN AND
MINORITIES MAILING MINORITIES
NOT ENOUGH WOMEN. BUT LESS THAN
10% OF THE CONTRACTORS ARE
MINORITIES. I THINK IT'S
SHAMEFUL EURO SO IN OTHER WORDS.
THEY'RE DOING ALL THE WORK BUT
THE CONTRACTORS ARE MAKING ALL
THE PROFIT. SO THAT'S THE
RESULT. PROPOSITION TWO OR NINE.
TO ME THAT'S AN EVIL. THAT'S AN
EVIL. WE NEED TO HAVE.
OPPORTUNITIES I TALKED TO A
COUPLE YEARS AGO A- ELECTRICAL.
CONTRACTOR WHO WORKED IN
ELECTRIC SHOULD BUSINESS HE WAS
A UNION MEMBER. AND HE SAID JIM
I'M FINALLY GOING TO CREATE MY
BUSINESS I'M GOING TO CREDIT MY
CONSTRUCTION MY ELECTRIC
CONTRACTING BUSINESS. AND I
SAID YOU KNOW. I MEAN YOU DID A
HIGH TECH CLEAN ROOMS YOU DO IT
YOU KNOW YOU KNOW THE MOST.
DETAILED HIGH QUALITY
ELECTRICAL WORK. A MANAGEABLE
YOU HAVE TO WORK FOR THOSE
COMPANIES THAT WANT TO
PERFECTLY CLEAN ROOMS- ALL THE
PROPER ELECTRICAL SYSTEMS. WORK
AND HOW COME IT TOOK YOU SO
LONG. HE SAID YOU KNOW. WE
STILL HAVE THE GOOD OLD BOYS
SYSTEM. WE STILL HAVE THE GOOD
OLD BOY SYSTEM SO FOR ME.
THAT'S GOING TO CHANGE BECAUSE
IF WE DON'T CHANGE IT GUESS
WHAT YOU'RE GONNA BE PAYING
MORE MONEY FOR YOUR CONTRACTS.
YOU WANT TO YOU WANT TO JUST
GOT A- IGNORE THAT FINE BUT IF
WE WANT TO GET SOME OF GUYS
LIKE THIS I CAN COME IN AND DO
SOME GREAT CONTRACTING WORK. IT
SEEMS TO ME WE OUGHT TO MAE
SOME RULES. THAT BENEFIT TE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA NOT.
SPECIFIC PEOPLE THAT BENEFIT.
BY THE- THAT. WERE PUT ON THE
BALLOT WITHOUT PROPER REVIEW.
THIS NEEDS TO BE LOOKED AT VERY
CLOSELY. SO FOR ME. I THINK
THAT THIS LAW NEEDS TO PASS. I
WANT TO SEE MORE PEOPLE ENGAGED
IN WOMEN MINORITY CONTRACTING I
WANT TO SEE THEIR COMPETITION.
I WANT TO SEE IT FIRST INDUSTRY
FLOURISH. WE HAVE A LOT OF
BEAUTIFUL THINGS TO BUILD. WE
HAVE WATER SYSTEM- EDUCATION
FACILITIES TRANSPORTATION
TRANSIT WE HAVE A LOT OF
BEAUTIFUL THINGS WERE GOING TO
BUILD IN THIS STATE WE'RE GOING
TO MAKE THIS STATE A GREAT
STATE. AND BY GOLLY EVERYBODY
EVERYBODY'S GONNA HAVE AN
OPPORTUNITY TO BE INVOLVED IN
THAT SO I URGE AN AYE VOTE.
SENATOR ALLEN. MEMBERS I JUST
WANTED TO ADD TO THE LIST OF
FOLKS WHO'VE COME OUT AN
ENDORSEMENT- THE JEWS CAUCUS AS
WELL AS IS COME OUT AND DOORS
AND FOR THIS IMPORTANT MEASURE
IN A RACE CONTINUE TO MATTER
FOR ALL THE REASONS THAT HAVE
BEEN DISCUSSED FOR TODAY AND I
THINK IT'S- A. ASIAN AND VOTERS
TO REVISIT THIS QUARTER CENTURY
ALL DECISION. SENATOR UMBERG. A
AT LISTEN TO THE MOVING
COMMENTS OF SOME OF OUR
COLLEAGUES HERE. THE
IMPASSIONED SPEECHES- I KNOW
IT'S HARD TO TELL BUT I'M AN
OLD WHITE GUY. AN OLD STRAIGHT
WHITE GUY. AND I AM NOT
EXPERIENCE THE KINDS OF.
EPISODES THAT WERE EXPERIENCED
BY MANY OF THE FOLKS HERE FACT
I GREW UP IN OF AREA AND
MIDWEST THAT WAS LARGELY ALMOST
EXCLUSIVELY WHITE. OF ALMOST
EXCLUSIVELY CATHOLIC THE GREAT
DIVERSITY IN OUR NEIGHBORHOODS
WAS BETWEEN ST MARTIN'S INSANE
AL'S AND YOU COULDN'T TRUST
THOSE PEOPLE SAY MARTIN THIS.
MOTHER WOULD SAY. THAT WAS THE
DIVERSITY THAT I GREW UP WITH
IN FACT THE ISSUES OF RACE I
NEVER REALLY THOUGHT ABOUT TELL
YOU THE TRUTH UNTIL I WAS.
OLDER IT WASN'T UNTIL I
ACTUALLY WAS IN THE ARMY. IT
WASN'T UNTIL I OBSERVE GOING
THRU OFFICER BASIC TRAIN THEIR
FORTY FOUR MEN IN OUR TRAINING
PLATOON ALL GOING TO BE SECOND
LIEUTENANTS. ALL WHITE. AND
AFTER BECOMING A SECOND
LIEUTENANT THEORETICALLY YOUR
COMMANDING INTER AN INFANTRY
PLATOON. OF FORTY FOUR SOLDIERS
OF WHICH AT LEAST THE THIRD IF
NOT A HALF A MINORITY. AND SO
WHEN HE ENTERED THE ARMY. THERE
WAS TREMENDOUS RACIAL STRIFE
TREMENDOUS RACIAL STRIDES POSE
VIETNAM THE ARMY WAS BROKEN
THERE WERE INCIDENTS ALL OVER
NO WONDER WE HADN'T ALMOST
EXCLUSIVELY ALL WHITE OFFICER
CORPS LEADING AN ARMY THAT WAS
BETWEEN THE THIRD AND A HALF
MINORITY. THINGS CHANGED THE
MILITARY THE ARMY RECOGNIZE
THAT THERE WERE ISSUES OF
LEADERSHIP. AND REACHED OUT AND
TRIED TO CHANGE THE EQUATION IS
IT PERFECT HASN'T WORKED
COMPLETELY IT IS NOT. BUT WHAT
THE MILITARY DID IS THEY
REACHED OUT THEY RECOGNIZE THAT
DIVERSITY AMONG THE OFFICER
RANKS LEAD TO A STRONGER
MILITARY TO A STRONGER NATIONAL
DEFENSE. AND SO IF YOU OBSERVE
TODAY IN WEST POINT LAST WEST
POINT CLASS HAD THE LARGEST
NUMBER OF AFRICAN AMERICAN
WOMEN. IN THE HISTORY OF THE
UNITED STATES GRADUATE THAT THE
ENTERING CLASS NOW IS ABOUT 37%
MINORITY WHICH MAKES SENSE. I
OBSERVED OVER THE THIRTY YEARS
I WAS IN AND OUT OF THE ARMY
THAT THE ARMY CHANGED
DRAMATICALLY. FROM AN ARMY THAT
WAS BROKEN. THAT WAS. REPLETE
WITH STRIFE. TO AN ARMY THAT
WAS FAR MORE FUNCTIONAL IN FACT.
PERHAPS THE GREATEST ARMY IN
THE HISTORY OF THE WORLD AND
PART OF IT IS BECAUSE FOLKS
RECOGNIZE THAT WE ARE STRONGER
WHEN WE HAVE LEADERS. WHO ARE
DIVERS WHO BRING DIFFERENT
EXPERIENCES TO THE FOR WE'RE
STRONGER WHEN WE HAVE LEADERS
WHO LIED PEOPLE WHO CAN LOOK UP
TO THEM AS ROLE MODELS AND SO I
STILL STRONG SUPPORT THEY SEE A
FIVE. FOR A NUMBER OF REASONS.
BECAUSE IT'S FAIR BECAUSE IT'S
JUST BECAUSE IT'S RIGHT AND
BECAUSE IT LEADS TO A STRONGER
ECONOMY AND A STRONGER NATIONAL
DEFENSE ARJUNA VOTE. UNDER THE-
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT- I
APOLOGIZE FOR ASKING TO SPEAK
AGAIN BUT I WON'T APOLOGIZE FOR
WHAT I'M ABOUT TO SAY AGAIN I
WILL SAY THAT THE THINGS I HERE
ON THIS FLOOR SOMETIMES ARE
JUST SHOCKING TO ME I FIND IT
UNCONSCIONABLE AND INCREDIBLY
DISINGENUOUS THAT THE SENATOR
FROM LAKE ELSINORE WHO IS A
WHITE WOMAN AS I AM A WHITE
WOMAN WOULD SAY THAT WE LIVE IN
THE LEAST RACIST STATE AND THE
LEAST RACIST COUNTRY. FOR TWO
REASONS ONE I DON'T AGREE WITH
THAT BUT TO LEAST RACIST
IMPLIES THAT RACISM STILL
EXISTS WE ARE HERE TODAY TO TRY
AND CHANGE THAT AND MAYBE FOR
HER AS A WHITE WOMAN SHE HAS
NEVER EXPERIENCED RACISM BUT SO
MANY PEOPLE HAVE HUNDREDS OF
THOUSANDS OF PEOPLE IN OUR
STATE IN OUR COUNTRY HAVE WE
HAVE AN OPPORTUNITY TO DO ONE
SMALL THING TODAY WE STILL HAVE
SO MUCH WORK TO DO. RISE SAY
THAT BECAUSE I ALSO THINK IT
SHOULD BE IN A ON MY COLLEAGUE
OF MY FROM LOS ANGELES TO
ADDRESS OF THESE ABSURDITIES
SHE HAD HEARD CLOSE THANK YOU
MA'AM PRESIDENT. SENATE THANK
YOU MADAM PRESIDENT I AB WAS
UNDER THE IMPRESSION AND I WAS
TOLD THAT THINGS OPERATED A
LITTLE DIFFERENTLY OVER HERE ON
THE SENATE WITH RESPECT TO HOW
WE TREAT ONE ANOTHER- BUT I
GUESS THAT'S NOT THE CASE SO-
IT YOU KNOW I THINK A LOT OF
TIMES. PEOPLE I DON'T LIKE WHAT
SOMEONE HAS TO SAY ON THIS
FLOOR BUT A PERSONAL ATTACK.
AGAINST ME FOR SOME FOR AN
OPINION THAT I EXPRESSED I
THINK IS REALLY AN APPROPRIATE.
TERRIBLY UNPROFESSIONAL AND
FRANKLY BEHAVIOR NOT
COMMENSURATE WITH THE POSITION.
HOLE AS STATE HERS. THANK YOU
FOR THE SALUTE I APPRECIATE
THAT- IS SO I WOULD JUST ASK
MADAM PRESIDENT. THAT WE COULD
CERTAINLY MAKE SURE WE ARE HERE
TO THE DECORUM AND RULES OF THE
SENATE- AND KEEP THIS A
CIVILIZED DISCUSSION RATHER
THEY AND- SO A TAX. THE VERY
MUCH MADAM PRO TEM. THANK YOU
MADAM PRESIDENT AND COLLEAGUES
THANK YOU VERY MUCH- I HAVE
LISTENED. TO ALL OF THE
COMMENTS TODAY AND CERTAINLY IT
HAS BEEN- A PASSIONATE
DISCUSSION WITH A LOT OF
RELEVANT POINTS. IN OUR- WE ALL
HAVE STORIES WE ARE HAVE A LENS
THAT WE PUT AND EVALUATE THINGS
THROUGH WHETHER WE WANT TO HAVE
IT OR NOT WE DO. OUR STORE.
THIS IS DUE. YOU KNOW I KNOW
THAT ARE I WILL BY THE WAY I
RISE IN VERY STRONG SUPPORT OF
A CA FIVE. YOU KNOW TWO NINE
MAY TELL YOU TO BE COLOR BLIND
AND OTHERS HAVE SAID THIS OR
GENDER NEUTRAL BUT THAT JUST
ISN'T THE REALITY IT'S NOT THE
REALITY. AND THAT'S WHY WE
DEBATE THESE THINGS THAT'S WHY
THE CONSTITUTION WAS DEBATED
THE BILL OF RIGHTS CAME OUT. WE
HAVE TO CONTINUE WE LOOK FOR
EXPERIENCE AND THE SOCIETY IS
GOING ON IN TODAY'S WORLD. FROM
WHICH TO DETERMINE WHAT THE
METRICS WILL BE. OUR I HAVE
EXPERIENCED- CERTAINLY ARE
ISN'T LGBT Q. ARE MEMBER OF
THAT COMMUNITY I'VE EXPERIENCED
DISCRIMINATION I'VE EXPERIENCED
DISCRIMINATION AS A WOMAN BUT I
WILL TELL YOU THE WORST
DISCRIMINATION I HAVE
EXPERIENCED IN MY LIFE. WAS AS
A POOR PERSON A PERSON ARE THEY
COME THROUGH A VERY BLUE COLLAR
WORKING CLASS BACKGROUND AN
APPALACHIAN A SOUTHERNER
WITHOUT A LOT OF OPPORTUNITY.
AND I KNEW I WAS DIFFERENT I
CAN ONLY IMAGINE WHAT IT WOULD
FEEL LIKE I CAN ONLY IMAGINE
BECAUSE I DON'T KNOW IF I HAD
TO ADD A RACE OR AN ETHNIC-
COMPONENT TO ALL OF THESE OTHER
FACTORS SO I DON'T KNOW WHAT
THAT IS LIKE BUT I'LL TELL YOU
I DO HAVE THE EXPERIENCE. OF
HAVE WORLD. WOMAN COMING OUT AS
A LESBIAN AT AGE EIGHTEEN. AND
SO I KNOW WHAT IT MEANS TO HAVE
TO UNDERSTAND SURVIVAL AND HOW
TO BE CAREFUL AND HOW TO
NAVIGATE THE WORLD. OUR BUT I
GET A GOOD EDUCATION THANKS TO
SOME OF THE RULES THAT WERE IN
PLACE THAT ALLOWED ME TO GET
GRANT SINCE AND I GOT
SCHOLARSHIPS I WORKED VERY HARD.
BUT I DIDN'T HAVE THE SAME
OPPORTUNITIES AS MANY OF THE
KIDS WENT TO SCHOOL WITH ME
THAT LIVED ON THE- RIGHT SIDE
OBVIOUSLY. OF THE TRACKS. BUT I
GET A GOOD EDUCATION I GOT TO
COLLEGE WITH A LOT OF SUPPORT.
AND TODAY I AM THE PRESIDENT
PRO TEM OF THE SENATE OF
CALIFORNIA THE FIFTH LARGEST
ECONOMY IN THE WORLD. I'D LOVE
TO SHARE WITH YOU THE STORY MY
SISTER. WHO HAS WHO TOOK A
DIFFERENT PATH. AND WHO DIDN'T-
SOMEHOW GET THE OPPORTUNITIES
THAT I WAS FORTUNATE ENOUGH TO
HAVE. SHE WHEN THE MILITARY
SHE'S A PROUD VETERAN AS WAS
HER HUSBAND NOW DECEASED. BUT
HER EXPERIENCE IN THE WORLD IS
VERY DIFFERENT BECAUSE PEOPLE
PERCEIVE HER NOT TO BE A- WHITE
WOMEN THE PRIVILEGE SHE STILL
HAS A LOT OF THE ISSUES. FROM
THE BLUE COLLAR WORKING CLASS
POOR COMMUNITY THAT WE CAME
FROM. AND WE TELL YOU SHE'S
TREATED DIFFERENTLY. SHE'S
TREATED DIFFERENTLY AND SHE
ACTS DIFFERENTLY SHE WOULD
NEVER THINK TO ASK FOR
SOMETHING THAT SHE DESERVES.
AND I FEEL THE DIFFERENCE
BECAUSE PEOPLE TREAT ME LIKE
THE WHITE WOMAN A PRIVILEGE I
SEEM TO BE UNTIL I GET MY
ACCESS HALFWAY THROUGH. BY I
ONLY SHARE MY STORY BECAUSE I
THINK THAT THE TENSIONS TODAY
EXIST BECAUSE WE HAVE AN
ADDRESS THE ISSUES. BE THE SAME
RELEASE OUR GENDER OUR
ORIENTATION OUR ECONOMIC
OPPORTUNITY YOU HEAR A LOT OF
ECONOMIC OPPORTUNITY- AND AN
EQUITY THROUGHOUT ALL OF THIS
BECAUSE THAT DAY YOU KNOW BE
POOR AND ECONOMICALLY.
DISADVANTAGED CROSSES ALL LINES
ARE. YOU KNOW OUR OUR HAS SOME
REALLY PRETTY BASIC COMMENTS
BUT I WANTED TO JUST THROW THAT
OUT THERE AND BY THE WAY. YOU
KNOW DIVERSITY NOT JUST HAPPEN
IT TAKES WORK HARD WORK.
FOCUSED WORK. AND I KNOW THIS
BECAUSE I THINK I'M A PRETTY
GOOD PERSON I LIKE TO THINK
THAT I. AM ACCEPTING IT OPEN
BECAUSE OF MY EXPERIENCES THAT
I. AND BETTER RIGHT. AND THEN I
TOOK THE IMPLICIT BIAS SURVEY.
AND BOY DID I LEARN A FEW
THINGS ABOUT MYSELF I WAS SO
DEPRESSED AND DISAPPOINTED BUT
IT WAS A REMINDER TO ME. I HAVE
WORK TO DO YOU CAN IMAGINE HOW
HARD IT IS TO COME UP WITH
PARAMETERS AND GUIDELINES AND
RULES AND- IN THE END TO FIGURE
OUT HOW WE PROMOTE AN EQUITABLE
PLAYING FIELD. HOW DO WE DO
THAT. WITHOUT OFFENDING EACH
OTHER. YOU KNOW HOW DO WE DO
THAT BECAUSE IN OUR ATTEMPTS TO
BEHIND OR OR ONE ON ONE-
PERSONAL WE STILL HAVE ISSUES
AND PROBLEMS BECAUSE WE ALL
COME FROM A DIFFERENT
PERSPECTIVE WE ALL LOOK THROUGH
A DIFFERENT LENS. IT JUST IS.
AND SO WE'RE GOING TO CONTINUE
TO DEBATE THESE THINGS BY YOU
KNOW. THE TENSIONS EXIST
BECAUSE WE'VE GOT WORK TO DO
AND THE ONLY WAY WE CAN DO IT
AS A DEMOCRACY. IS TO IS TO
HAVE THE DISCUSSION AND FIGURE
OUT WHAT NEEDS TO HAPPEN SO NOW
I'LL GET TO MINE- BASIC POINTS
WHICH CLEARLY YOU'RE NOT
PASSIONATE BUT VERY RELEVANT I
HOPE. IT'S BEEN MADE CLEAR OUR
DISCUSSION THE ACA FIVE WILL
GIVE VOTERS THE OPPORTUNITY TO
DECIDE IF CALIFORNIA SHOULD
ALLOW RACE AND GENDER TO BE
CONSIDERED IN COLLEGE
ADMISSIONS. GOVERNMENT HIRING
AND GOVERNMENT CONTRACTING NOT
THE ONLY CONSIDERATION NOT THE
DETERMINING CONSIDERATION JUST
ONE OF THE CONSIDERATIONS IN A
HOLISTIC VIEW. IN NINETEEN
NINETY SIX PROPOSITION TWO OH
NINE PROHIBITED THIS POLICY.
BUT IN CALIFORNIA AND
CALIFORNIANS UP WE'VE CHANGED
OVER THE LAST FEW DECADES IT'S
TIME TO ALLOW VOTERS TO ALLOW
CALIFORNIANS TO RE EVALUATE THE
POLICY THE SAME WAY THEY DID
FOUR YEARS AGO WHEN VOTERS
REPEALED ANOTHER RELIC FROM THE
NINETIES PROP TWO TWENTY SEVEN.
AND RESTORE BILINGUAL EDUCATION
BECAUSE IT WAS THE RIGHT THING
TO DO. THE STATE'S EDUCATION
SYSTEM CAREERS IN PUBLIC
SERVICE FAIR PUBLIC PROCUREMENT
POLICIES. HAVE BEEN PROVEN TO
BE EXTREMELY POWERFUL AS MY
COLLEAGUE OVER THERE- POINTED
OUT TO BUILD AND MAINTAIN A
STRONG MIDDLE CLASS SOMETHING
AND MANY OF US. ASPIRE TO. ACA
FIVE WILL ENSURE ALL
COMMUNITIES HAVE A LEVEL
PLAYING FIELD TO COMPETE FOR
THOSE OPPORTUNITIES. COLLEAGUES
CO THE NINETEEN IN THE PANDEMIC
IS FURTHER EXPOSED HEALTH
DISPARITIES WE'LL TALK ABOUT
THAT IN ANOTHER PIECE OF
LEGISLATION BEING OFFERED. IN
COMMUNITIES OF COLOR. SYSTEMIC
RACISM CONTINUES TO BE A STAIN
ON OUR NATION HOWEVER HARD WE
STRIVE AND TRY. IN THE CURRENT
ECONOMIC DOWNTURN IS INCREASING
EXISTING INEQUITIES. AS WE WORK
IN THE LEGISLATURE TO ADDRESS
THOSE ISSUES WE HAVE TO TAKE
EVERY CHANCE WE CAN TO PROMOTE
OPPORTUNITY AND JUSTICE THEIR
ASPIRATIONS. AND E CAN
CONTINUE ALWAYS TO ASPIRE TO
THOSE GOALS AND THE BEST NATURE.
AS OUR COLLEAGUE DR WEBER HAS
NOTED PROPOSITION TWO ONE NINE
WAS HINDERED HAS HINDERED
PUBLIC POLICY FORWARDED
OPPORTUNITY AND MAINTAIN
ECONOMIC DISPARITY LONG ENOUGH
IT'S TIME TO GIVE VOTERS A
CHANCE TO RIGHT THIS WRONG. I
ASK FOR YOUR AYE VOTE ON A CA
FIVE THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT.
MEMBERS THANK YOU VERY MUCH
YOUR PASSION AND VIGOROUS
DEBATE SENATOR MITCHELL YOU MAY
CLOSE. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
MADAM PRESIDENT. I DON'T KNOW
ABOUT- MANY OF YOU BUT I'M
OFTEN ASKED I ASSUME IT'S
BECAUSE- I HELD PREVIOUS ROLES
HERE IN THE LEGISLATURE BEFORE
RUNNING FOR OFFICE I WAS STAFF
OF THE PUBLIC INTEREST
LOBBYISTS BUT I'M OFTEN ASKED
WHAT I'M NOT SURPRISED BY NOW
THAT I'M A SITTING MEMBER. ON I
THINK IT HIT A- I HAVE WORKED
IN DIVERSE SETTINGS WITH PEOPLE
FROM DIFFERENT SCHOOLS OF
THOUGHT BUT I AM MOST INTRIGUED.
HOW A GROUP OF PEOPLE CALL THE
LEGISLATURE CAN LOOK AT A
COMMON SET OF DATA IN FACT.
ANSWER MY LIFE SUCH DIFFERENT
BANG. THAT WAS I REMEMBER BEING
IN THE ASSEMBLY WHICH STRUCK ME
THE MOST TO THE DEGREE THAT I
TURNED AROUND ONE DAY ON THE
FLOOR AND ASK MY CALL THE
CONSENT BEHIND ME WHAT WAS HER
SOURCE OF NEWS. BECAUSE I
COULDN'T BELIEVE. THAT
LISTENING TO THE SAME SET OF
FACTS THAT I HEARD ON THE
FLOOR. SHE COULD COME UP WITH
SUCH A VERY DIFFERENT SUMMARY
VIEW OF THE WORLD IS IDEA. I
APPRECIATE YOU ALL SHARING YOUR
STORIES WE ALL HAVE THEM. AND I
THINK PERHAPS WE DON'T HAVE
ENOUGH OPPORTUNITY TO HAVE
THESE KINDS OF CONVERSATIONS-
CLEARLY DON'T HAVE ENOUGH
OPPORTUNITY HAVE CONVERSATIONS
ABOUT RACE BECAUSE THAT'S- THE
REAL CRUX OF THE PROBLEM WITH
OUR COUNTRY. AN INABILITY TO
USE ALL TO WITH KNOWLEDGE. THE
HISTORY OF THIS COUNTRY THAT IT
WAS BUILT ON THE BACKS OF FREE
LABOR. AND THE REASON THE HARD
TIME HAVING THAT CONVERSATION
BECAUSE PEOPLE ARE AFRAID. THAT
IN ORDER TO SHARE POWER
RESOURCES YOU MIGHT HAVE TO
GIVE SOMETHING UP. I GET THAT
WHAT MAKES IT DIFFICULT. AND
BECAUSE WE'VE NEVER REALLY BEEN
ABLE TO HAVE THAT CONVERSATION
IT FEATURES IN THE SOMETIMES
RELATED SOMETIMES ON RELATED
SITUATIONS MUCH LIKE TODAY. BUT
I APPRECIATE YOU FOR SHARING
ALL YOUR STORIES OF WHAT
INTRIGUED WITHMOST OF YOUR
STORIES WERE FROM CHILDHOOD.
HOWEVER SOME OF MY EXPERIENCES
ABOUT. OVERT AND MY PROGRESS IN
AGGRESSIONS AND RACES
EXPERIENCE HAS WORKED SINCE
BEING A MEMBER THE CALIFORNIA
LEGISLATURE. WE DIDN'T TALK
ABOUT THAT. QUESTIONS ABOUT. ME
AND MY LIFE IN MY JEWELRY AND
MY STYLE OF DRESS FOR MEMBERS
OF THIS VERY BODY. SO WE REALLY
HAVE WORK TO DO. BECAUSE
PERHAPS WE NEED TO SPEND MORE
TIME WITH ONE ANOTHER TO
BROADEN OUR COLLECTIVE
EXPERIENCES ABOUT PEOPLE WHO
ARE DIFFERENT FROM US. FOR WE
CAN BE MORE LEARN IT IN
UNDERSTANDING OF PEOPLE WHO ARE
DIFFERENT FROM US. WITH MANY
PEOPLE TALKED ABOUT THEIR
EXPERIENCES OF BEING THE ONLY
PERSON IN THE ROOM I WAS
REMINDED OF AN AMAZING
INTERVIEW I SAW ONCE CONDUCTED
BY CHARLIE ROSE MANY
INTERVIEWS. TONI MORRISON
PULITZER PRIZE WINNING AUTHOR.
AND CHARLIE KEPT PROBING HE WAS
REALLY CURIOUS ABOUT WHAT HER
LIFE EXPERIENCE HAD BEEN
PARTICULARLY IN. THE LITERARY
WORLD COME OFF IN A VERY LEE
WORLD WHERE SHE'D BEEN A
PUBLISHER. AND A KEPT PUSHING A
COUPLE XIN AND SHE SAID. WITH
SUCH CONFIDENCE IN CALL WITHOUT
BATTING HER EYES. THAT THOSE
SITUATIONS NEVER BOTHERED HER
TO SHE WAS CLEAR SHE WAS
INTELLECTUALLY SUPERIOR TO MOST
OF THE PEOPLE IN THE ROOM IN
HALF OF THE TIME. AND CHARLIE
WAS STUNNED. IT NEVER OCCURRED
TO HIM. HIS PERCEPTION WAS THAT
SHE WOULD FEEL LESS THEN
UNCOMFORTABLE. AND IT WAS THIS
MOMENT IN TIME WITH THE BOTH OF
THEM LOOKED AT EACH OTHER AND
DIDN'T UNDERSTAND THE
PERSPECTIVE OF THE OTHER IT
NEVER OCCURRED TO HER THAT SHE
SHOULD FEEL LESS THAN SHE WAS
CLEAR THAT HE WAS
INTELLECTUALLY SUPERIOR THE
MOST OF THE PEOPLE IN THE ROOM
HALF THE TIME. FULLER THANK YOU
ALL FOR TAKING THE TIME TO HAVE
THIS. POWERFUL CONVERSATION
TODAY. I'D LIKE TO TAKE A QUICK
MOMENT TO DIRECT EVERYONE TO
THE SENATE FLOOR ANALYSIS FOR
THIS BILL THAT WAS PUT TOGETHER
BY OUR OWN CONSULTANTS SO
WHAT'S IMPORTANT I BELIEVE IS
ON PAGE TWO OF THE ANALYSIS.
AND IT'S THAT IT PUT PROP TWO
OH NINE PASSED IN NINETEEN
NINETY SIX IN A HISTORICAL
CONTEXT THAT REMINDS US OF WHAT
WAS GOING ON IN OUR STATE AT
THAT TIME. AS THE ANNOUNCED.
ONE OF THE CO AUTHORS OF THE
CALIFORNIA CIVIL RIGHTS
INITIATIVE WHICH BECAME PROP
TWO OH NINE WAS AN
ANTHROPOLOGIST IN THE CAL STATE
SYSTEM. BY THE NAME OF BILLION
AFTER IT. AND IN A BOOK
REGARDING HIS YOUR PROP TWO OH
NINE ENTITLED COLOR BLIND
CALIFORNIA'S BATTLE TO END
AFFIRMATIVE ACTION. CUSTER
DESCRIBED HIS JOURNEY TO
UPHOLDING AFFIRMATIVE ACTION AS
A BORN OF HIS DISCOMFORT WITH
DIVERSITY AND MULTI
CULTURALISM. HE STATED AND I
CALLED PERMISSION TO REPEAT.
PERMISSION THANK YOU AS AN
ENTREPRENEUR AFTER APOLOGISTS I
KNOW THAT WHEN YOU'VE GOT
DIVERSITY YOU'VE GOT A PROBLEM.
WHICH MEANS THAT YOU'VE GOT TO
COME UP WITH WAYS TO DEAL WITH
IT IN THE MOST REALISTIC WAY.
IN QUOTE. HE ALSO DESCRIBED
MULTI CULTURALISM AS COLD
TERRIBLY MISGUIDED. I WAS
CONCERNED THAT A PEACEFUL
AMERICA WAS NOT POSSIBLE
WITHOUT A COMMON GROUND BETWEEN
ALL AMERICANS WERE AMERICA
WOULD FIND CUSTARDS COMMON
GROUND IS UNCLEAR BUT
APPARENTLY IT WAS NOT FOUND IN
EITHER MULTI CULTURALISM OR
DIVERSITY RATHER. THE TEXT OF
THE CALIFORNIA CIVIL RIGHTS
INITIATIVE COMMON IS IN THE OF
DIFFERENCES OF COLOR BLIND AND
GENDER BLIND SOCIETY. I WOULD
ARGUE. LET ME JUST GO A STEP
FURTHER. SINCE THEY INTERPRETED
THE INTENTION OF PROP TWO OH
NINE. THE CIVIL RIGHTS
INITIATIVE WOULD NOT HAVE
BECOME PROP TWO OH NINE WITHOUT
THE SUPPORT OF MISTER WARD
CONNELLY IN GOVERNOR PETE
WILSON AND SINCE MY COLLEAGUES
HAVE CHOSEN TO. INSERT
PARTISANSHIP IN TODAY'S DEBATE
LET ME JUST STATE SOME
ADDITIONAL FACTS AGAIN I'M
QUOTING FROM THE ANALYSES. IN
LATE NINETEEN EIGHTY FIVE WARD
CONNERLY AN ALLY OF GOVERNOR
WILSON TOOK OVER IS THE CHAIR
OF THE INITIATIVE. AND THE
CALIFORNIA REPUBLICAN PARTY
GAVE THE K. GAVE THE CAMPAIGN
TWO THOUSAND DOLLARS. GOVERNOR
WILSON WHO IS RUNNING FOR
PRESS. THE REPUBLICAN
NOMINATION FOR PRESIDENT. HAD
RECENTLY FOUND POLITICAL
SUCCESS IN USING THE BALLOT
INITIATIVE PROCESS.
SPECIFICALLY PROP ONE EIGHTY
SEVEN OF NINETEEN NINETY FOUR
PROP TWO TWO SEVEN. AS A WEDGE
ISSUE TO DRIVE THE ELECTORAL
SUPPORT FROM WHITE MAN. BOTH
HONOLULU OFTEN FOCUSED ON THE
NEED FOR A COLOR BLIND SOCIETY
SPECIFICALLY THE OFFICIAL PROP
TWO OH NINE BALLOT ARGUMENTS.
GOVERNOR WILSON AND CONNERLY
ARGUED THAT AND I CALLED. THE
ONLY HONEST AND EFFECTIVE WAY
TO ADDRESS ANY QUALITY OF
OPPORTUNITY IS BY MAKING SURE
THAT ALL CALIFORNIA CHILDREN
ARE PROVIDED WITH THE TOOLS TO
COMPETE IN OUR SOCIETY AND THEN
LET THEM SUCCEED ON THE HAIR
COLOR BLIND RACE BLIND GENDER
BLIND THIS. I WOULD ENCOURAGE
YOU TO TAKE A LOOK AT SOME OF
THE INITIATIVES IN THE FUNDING
FOR PUBLIC EDUCATION AND
HOUSING AND HEALTHCARE. THAT
FOLLOW THAT PERIOD TO SEE IF
INDEED THERE WAS AN EFFORT TO
CREATE. COOL OPPORTUNITY FOR
CALIFORNIA'S CHILDREN FALLING
PROP TWO OH NINE UNDER MISTER
WILSON DID MANAGE GEN. I WOULD
ARGUE THAT IT WAS NOT. WHATEVER
YOUR PERCEPTION OF WHAT A COLOR
BLIND SOCIETY IS THE DATA
SUGGEST WE ARE CURRENTLY NOT
LIVING IN ONE. IN ACTUALITY THE
DATA SUGGESTS THE COMPLETE
OPPOSITE THAT OUR SOCIETY IS
DISTINCTLY ON EQUAL ALONG CLEAR
RACIAL AND GENDER
STRATIFICATION. LET'S BE CLEAR
ABOUT MATH VERSUS FACT. YEAH
AFFIRMATIVE ACTION IS
PREFERENTIAL TREATMENT. NEFF
AFFIRMATIVE ACTION IS NO LONGER
NEEDED IN AMERICA MYTH
AFFIRMATIVE ACTION REWARDS THE
ON QUALIFIED NEAR IT PROMOTES
THE SINGULAR USE OF A RACE
BASED LANDS OR QUOTAS AND LET'S
BE CLEAR QUOTAS WERE ILLEGAL
UNDER AFFIRMATIVE ACTION FREE
TO ALL NINE FOR THE CONFERENCE
THE- A THIRTY. THAT THE PASSAGE
OF THE ACA TEXAS THE QUOTA IS
AN ACCURATE. THE REAL MYTH IS
THAT WE HAVE AN EQUAL PLAYING
FIELD AND THAT THE MOST
QUALIFIED PEOPLE ARE THE ONES
WHO GET AHEAD THAT'S THE MATH.
IN FACT AFFIRMATIVE ACTION
HELPS TO OFFSET BARRIERS THAT
UNFAIRLY BLOCKED THE PATHWAYS
OF QUALIFIED AMERICANS. WHO ARE
FULLY ABLE TO SUCCEED IN SO
DOING TO PROMOTE EQUAL
OPPORTUNITY. THE WORLD IS FULL
OF PEOPLE WHOSE TALENTS ARE NOT
ALWAYS RECOGNIZED BY
TRADITIONAL MEASURES OF
EXCELLENCE. FOR EXAMPLE. THE
DOCTOR CLEAN KING IS OFTEN
QUOTED IN IN THE DEBATE AGAINST
A CA LET ME GIVE YOU A LITTLE
HISTORY ABOUT DOCTOR KING.
ALTHOUGH HE WENT TO ALTHOUGH HE
WENT ON TO BE ONE OF THE MOST
GIFTED OR RAIDERS OF THE
TWENTIETH CENTURY DR KING
SCORED VERY POORLY ON
STANDARDIZED VERBAL TEST IN HIS
YOUTH. RESEARCH HAS SHOWN THAT
SUCH TESTS IN SIMILAR CRITERIA
ARE OFTEN BIASED. AND UNDER
ESTIMATE THE CAPABILITIES OF
WORKING CLASS INDIVIDUALS WOMEN
AND PEOPLE OF COLOR. AND THAT
THEY DO NOT ACCURATELY PREDICT
PROFESSIONAL OR EDUCATIONAL
SUCCESS. ENCOUNTERING BILL
SCREAMIN NATION AFFIRMATIVE
ACTION POLICIES OFFSET LIMITED
MEASURES OF MERIT. AND IDENTIFY
INDIVIDUALS WHOSE TALENTS AND
POTENTIAL MIGHT OTHERWISE BE
OVERLOOKED. I KNOW THAT- MY
WORDS AND DEEDS MAY NEVER
CHANGE THE MINDS OF SOME. I
KNOW THAT BECAUSE I CAN SEE IT
IN YOUR EYES. THE WORK WE
STEPPED UP TO RIGHT THE WRONGS
OF THE PAST. SO LET'S BE CLEAR
ABOUT WHAT REPEALING PROP
TWENTY NINE REALLY MEANS. HOW
MANY MORE WOMEN TO POSITIONS OF
LEADERSHIP AND INVESTED IN
WOMEN OWNED BUSINESSES WHICH
ARE LEFT OUT BILLIONS OF
DOLLARS IN GOVERNMENT CONTRACTS
EVERY YEAR. CREATING FAIR THIS
IS IN THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA
THEY GIVE WOMEN LATINOS AND
AFRICAN AMERICANS AND OTHER
MIND ETHNIC MINORITIES ACCESS
THE PUBLIC CAREER JOBS AND GOOD
BENEFITS. HOLDING THE EDUCATION
ACHIEVEMENT GAPS AMONG
COMMUNITIES OF COLOR AND
ENSURING OUR PUBLIC COLLEGES
AND UNIVERSITIES CAN OFFER A
DIVERSE ATMOSPHERE THAT
ENHANCES LEARNING AND
ENCOURAGES MUTUAL UNDERSTANDING.
IT ALLOWS US TO RECRUIT AND
TRAIN MORE TEACHERS OF COLOR.
STANDING UP FOR CALIFORNIA
VALUES AGAINST THE RACISM AND
INTOLERANCE THAT MANY. ELECTED
OFFICIALS HAVE USED TO DIVIDE
OUR COUNTRY. WHAT YOUR VOTE
MEANS TODAY IN SUPPORTING A CA
FIVE. IS THAT IT WILL ALLOW NOT
JUST THE ONE HUNDRED AND
FIFTEEN THOUSAND WHO HAVE
SIGNED A PETITION IN OPPOSITION
TO IT BUT WILL ALLOW THE FORTY
MILLION RESIDENTS. THE HAVE THE
OPPORTUNITY TO WEIGH IN. I
MENTIONED A COUPLE OF THE
INITIATIVES THAT WERE DURING
THE SAME ERA WITH PROP TWO OH
NINE IN I MENTIONED PROP TWO
TWO SEVEN AND A REMINDER IF.
SEVEN TWENTY EIGHTEEN OUR
FORMER COLLEAGUE NOW THE
INSURANCE COMMISSIONER. BOUGHT
THAT ISSUE BACK TO THE FLOOR TO
TALK ABOUT. THE RACIST ANTI
IMMIGRANT TENER IN THE STATE AT
THE TIME. WHEN WE COULD QUALIFY
AN INITIATIVE AND PASS THAT
WITH SIXTY SOME ODD PERCENT OF
THE VOTE AN INITIATIVE THAT
SAID ENGLISH ONLY TO BE TAUGHT
IN SCHOOLS. WELL WITH 75% OF
THE BILL IN TWENTY SIXTEEN THAT
INITIATIVE WAS REPEALED. I
WOULD ARGUE THAT THE MOVEMENT
FOR SOCIAL JUSTICE IS NOT
INEVITABLE. PROP TWO OH NINES
INITIAL PASSAGE SHOULD BE
EVIDENCE OF THAT SO COLLEAGUES
WE MUST BE AFFIRMATIVE AND THE
ACTIONS WE TAKE. TO BEYOND THE
ARC TOWARDS JUSTICE I
APPRECIATE THE FULL DEBATE
TODAY AND I'M URGING YOUR FULL
SUPPORT OF ACA FIVE THANK YOU
FOR THE OPPORTUNITY. THAT
CONCLUDES OUR DEBATE MADAM
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ALLEN I ARCHULETA I ATKINS I
BATES NO BELL I FOR JUST NO
BRADFORD I HAVE A- I CHIANG NO
DALLY. NO DODD. I THEY'RE
AWESOME. I GALGIANI AYE GLAZER
I GONZALEZ I GROWTH. NO
HERTZBERG I HILL I WAS SO HI
TADO. I JACKSON I JONES NO
LEYVA I MCGUIRE. I MELINDA'S
HELLO MITCHELL. I MONNING I
MORE LOCK NO MORALE. NO NIELSEN
NO HAN. I PORTANTINO I ROTH I
RUBIO. I SKINNER. I STERN I
NUMBER I WHITE HOUSE SKI. I
WIENER I WILK HI. THE MEASURE
PASSES FIVE THIRTY KNOWS TEN.
MEMBERS ARE GOING TO RETURN TO
MOTIONS AND RESOLUTIONS SENATOR
HERTZBERG. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
BETTER PRESIDENT UNDER MOTIONS
RESOLUTIONS OF COURSE IS A
RESOLUTION OF THE DESK
REQUESTING PERMISSION OF THIS
BODY TO SPEND JOINT RULE SIXTY
ONE. AND JOINT RULE SIXTY TWO
FOR THE PURPOSE OF ALLOWING
SENATE BILL ONE THREE EIGHT
THREE THIRTEEN EIGHTY THREE TO
BE HEARD AND REPORTED BY
COMMITTEE THESE REQUESTS HAVE
BEEN APPROVED BY THE RULES
COMMITTEE AND ASKING FOR AN AYE
VOTE. CENTER GROVE. CENTER IF
YOU COULD JUST WAIT A SECOND
WILL MAKE SURE YOUR MAX ON. YOU
MAY PROCEED. OKAY GOOD HERE FOR
THE RECORD YOU TO. ONE MORE
TIME ONE MORE TIME HI. SENATOR
YOU MAY PROCEED THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT WE OBJECT TO REQUEST
A ROLL CALL VOTE. REGARD MATTER
SECRETARY. MEDICALLY THE RAZOR
FREE THE RESOLUTION. THE RESULT
OF THAT JOINT RULES OF SIXTY
ONE AND SIXTY TO BE DISPENSED
WITH. MADAM PARK PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL. I VOTE. ALLEN I
ARCHULETA I ATKINS I BATES NO
BELL I FORGES NO BRADFORD HI
CABALLERO I CHIANG. CHECK NO
DOLLY NO DODD HI THERE ARE SO.
I GALGIANI I GLAZER I GONZALEZ
HI GROWTH. NO HERTZBERG. HI
HILL I WISH SO HI TADO. HI
JACKSON HI JONES- NO LEYVA. I
MCGUIRE AYE MELINDA'S NO
MITCHELL. I MONNING I MORE LOCK
NO MORALE. NO NIELSEN. NO HAN
HI PORTANTINO I ROTH. I RUBIO.
I SKINNER I STERN I UMBERG HI
MY CASTING I WIENER I WILK.
FIVE TWENTY NINE KNOWS TEN THE
MOTION PASSES SENATOR HERTZBERG
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT
MEMBERS I ALSO MOVE MEASURES
REPORTED FROM THE BUDGET AND
FISCAL REVIEW COMMITTEE WILL BE
GIVEN THEIR SECOND READING UPON
BEING REPORTED AND ORDERED TO
THIRD READING. THANK YOU CENTER
GROVE. WHICH CELEB MIKE
GOVERNOR HELP TO USE OKAY
MONTEREY THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT WE OBJECT AND I
REQUEST THAT THE PREVIOUS ROLL
CALL BE SUBMITTED FOR THIS-
MOTION SO ORDERED. FIVE TWENTY
NINTH KNOWS TEN THE MAN THE
MOTION PASSES THANK YOU MADAM.
MEMBERS. MEMBERS WE WERE WE
WILL BE TAKING A FIFTEEN MINUTE
RECESS I'M GONNA ASK YOU TO
REMEMBER THE SET TO SOCIAL
DISTANCE AND KEEP YOUR MASKS ON
THIS GIVES US AN OPPORTUNITY
TO- PICK UP LUNCH WHICH IS
AVAILABLE RIGHT OUTSIDE THE
DOOR AND TAKE IT TO YOUR OFFICE
SO THAT YOU MAY HAVE SOMETHING
TO EAT BEFORE WE START THE
AFTERNOON.
GOOD AFTERNOON
MEMBERS ARE READY TO. START THE
SENATE UP AGAIN. MEMBERS ARE
GOING TO MOVE TO MOTIONS AND
RESOLUTIONS SENATOR BRADFORD
FOR WHAT REASON THE RIGHT WHY
THANK YOU MADAM HERE I'M
PRESIDENT. UNDER MOTIONS READ
THE RESOLUTIONS OF JUST GOING
TO REQUEST THAT AB FIFTEEN
FIFTY BY ASSEMBLYMAN. BONTA BE
REMOVED FROM THE IN A FILE AND
OF THE- YOUR- THANK YOU.
MEMBERS ARE GOING TO MOVE BACK
TO ASSEMBLY THIRD READING. THE
NEXT ITEM ON ON THE AGENDA IS
ITEM NUMBER EIGHTY SENATOR
BRADFORD. MADAM CLERK PLEASE
READ. ASSEMBLY CONSTITUTIONAL
AMENDMENT SIX BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER MCCARTY AN ACT RELATING
TO ELECTIONS. SENATOR BRADFORD
THE FLOOR IS YOURS THANK YOU
MADAM PRESIDENT. WE ALL
ADVOCATE FOR THE RIGHT TO VOTE
VOTER PARTICIPATION. AC A SIX.
I REFER TO AS FREE THE VOTE. IS
A PARTY OF THE LEGISLATIVE
BLACK CAUCUS AND IT SHOULD BE A
PARTY TO EACH AND EVERYONE OF
US WHO CARE ABOUT JUSTICE AND
VOTER PARTICIPATION. PROVED
AGAIN WOULD ALLOW THE VOTERS
THE VOTERS TO GIVE INDIVIDUALS.
ON PAROLE THE RIGHT TO VOTE
INDIVIDUALS WHO HAVE SERVED
THEIR TIME AND EVERY TURN BACK
TO SOCIETY ALLOWING THEM TO BE
TRULY. HEADED BACK INTO
SOCIETY. UNITED STATES ANY OF
THE WORLD ONE REGARDS IN
REGARDS TO DEMOCRACY. SYSTEM OF
VOTING BACK IN BED THE CASE
STILL. ARE BLOCKED FROM THAT
ACCESS BASED ON PREVIOUS
CONVICTIONS. SOME OF THE THINGS
THAT AS WE DISCUSSED IN THE
LAST ISSUE IS- RACIALLY BASED
POLL TAX THAT EXISTED IN THIS
COUNTRY FOR YEARS LITERACY TEST
TEST THAT EXISTED- TO EXCLUDING
WOMEN. FROM THE RIGHT TO VOTE
AND WE HAVE FOUGHT FOR JUSTICE
AND THE RIGHT TO VOTE IN THIS
COUNTRY FOR OVER A HUNDRED
YEARS THE DAY BALL AND PEOPLE
ON PAROLE FROM BOTH IN IS JUST
ANOTHER WAY TO CONTINUE TO
DISENFRANCHISE. PREDOMINATELY
CALL. RIGHT SO IT IS WRITING
TO. IT TO DO PEOPLE ARE POOR.
OUR FAMILY MAY. ARE CALL ARE.
ARE FREE. THEY GO TO WORK EVERY
DAY THE PAY TAXES. THEY DO
THEIR PART TO. SUCCESS REAR
THEM BACK INTO SO. YES THIS.
THAT BIG FOR THEM. AND ALTHOUGH
MANY ARE RIGHT FOR. CREATED BY
YOU KNOW OF THAT SAY BY.
WELCOME THERE AREN'T ANY TO
PARTICIPATE IN PEACEFUL PRO FOR
OF BE ARRESTED OR VIA THEIR PER.
WITHOUT THE BILL ABILITIES TO
VOTE THE VOICES SITE AND THEY
HAVE NO VOICE IN THIS WHAT WE
CALL THE MY- IT IS. IN TWENTY
THAT WE NEED TO THE VOTE IN
JUST A FRIED FRANCHISE.
MILLIONS OF IN THE- AND MORE.
COMMUNITIES THIS IS NOT A OR
ISSUE THIS IS A CIVIL RIGHTS TO
THAT NEED TO BE A TO. BEING
CONVICTED OF A CRIME SHOULD NOT
A LIFE SENTENCE- THIS. EACH IN
A OF US RIGHT TO BE A THESE ARE
FOR MEMBERS THESE ARE FOR OUR
RISK ASK FOR AYE VOTE ON A C.
SIX. SENATOR OR TO THE. THANK
YOU MADAM PRESIDENT I RISE
TODAY TO SUPPORT ACA SIX. AS
YOU ALL KNOW OF I THINK MOST OF
YOU THAT I SERVED WITH MY ABOUT
POLICE DEPARTMENTS YOU PROBABLY
THINKING WHAT FORMER POLICE
OFFICER BE STANDING UP AND
SUPPORTING A CA. THERE'S A LOT
OF PEOPLE IN LAW ENFORCEMENT
THE BELIEVE THAT YOU'VE DONE
YOUR TIME YOU SHOULD BE ABLE TO
GET BACK TO YOUR COMMUNITY AND
RESTORE YOUR DIGNITY AND REYES
YOUR HONOR WITH FAN. WHEN ONE
RETURNS FROM SERVICE. THE
BRIDGE SENTENCE. THERE OF THE
COMMUNITIES WE SHOULD RECEIVE
THE- AS MEMBERS OF THE CA.
THERE CHOI. GO TO SCHOOL THE-
THERE'S- AT THE LOCAL SCHOOL
BOARD MEETING THEY'RE ABLE TO
RUN UP AND DOWN THE PAR AND-
AMP. IN ALL THE THINGS THAT WE
DO. BECAUSE THEY ARE. SHOULD
YEAH MAY AND WOMEN WILL COME.
GIVEN THEIR TO IS A SHOULD HAVE
SHOULD BE ABLE TO BUY. IN
MEASURES THAT. THE PARK SHOULD
LOOK HOW THE CITY SHOULD BE RUN
MEASURES AT THE BOND MEASURES
OF- INCREASING TAXES DECREASING
TAXES SELECT THE PEOPLE IN THE
COMMUNITIES AND BEING PART OF
THE COMMUNITY MANY OF THESE.
WHO RETURN HOME. FORTUNATELY
FIND UPS. NOT BE PART OF THE
SYSTEM WE'VE GOT TO BE ABLE TO
PUT THAT ASIDE AND ALLOW THEM
TO BE PART OF THE SYSTEM
BECAUSE OF THE FACT THAT WE
HAVE SET IT UP THAT ONCE
THEY'VE PAID IT. WE KNOWLEDGE
THIS IS A GREAT WAY TO DO IT. I
WANT THEM TO ENTER THE BOOK BE
BOTH TO FILL OUT THE BALLOT. IN
TO HAVE THEIR VOICES HEARD AND
SENSE PART OF THEM. INTO THEIR
CAN. WHERE IT MIGHT BE. THAT
NORMALLY WE FIND THAT IT IS THE
TOP SIDE OF TOWN IN MORTGAGE
CASES WITH ITS THAT'S ALL
THEY'RE GOING TO TURN NOW
AROUND BEING PART OF IT. AND
HELP THEM BECOME. MEMBERS
ASSIST. AND THAT HE HAD THEM.
I'M IN THE ACT MEMBERS OF THE
SUS AND THE- AND SO WITH THAT I
RESPECTFULLY YOUR AYE. THANK
YOU. CENTER WIENER. THANK YOU
MATTER PRESIDENT RISE AGAINST
SUPPORT OF THE COAL. OF A SEX
WHICH FRANKLY ARE IN THIS HAVE
A LONG AGO IT'S A- THAT WE- A
OF PEOPLE. WHO HAVE SERVED
THEIR TIME. FOR BEEN RELEASED
WHO WE ARE AN ASK TO RE
INTEGRATE INTO SO. BUT THEN WE
TELL THEM THERE YOU DON'T EVEN
ONE OF THEM BAY RIGHTS. ARE SO.
THE RIGHT TO VOTE. THIS IS NOT
HOW IT SHOULD BE. AND HONESTLY
THIS DERIVES FROM A RACIST
SYSTEM A RACIST CRIMINAL
JUSTICE SYSTEM. AT A RATE
SYSTEM IN THIS COUNTRY THAT FOR
CENTURIES HAS WORKED VERY HARD
TO PREVENT PEOPLE FROM VOTING
PARTICULARLY PEOPLE COLOR AND
LOW INCOME PEOPLE AND THAT IS
WHAT IS HAPPENING HERE. OF OUR
CONSTITUTION. AND FRANKLY
CALIFORNIA IS IN EVEN IN THE
LEAD ON THIS. THE VOTERS OF
FLORIDA. MATHIS SEVERAL YEARS
AGO THE REPUBLICAN GOVERNOR OF
ALL YOU WANT. AN OUNCE HER
SUPPORT. THIS COMMONSENSE WE
WANT PEOPLE TO REENTER GRAY AND
TO RE ENTER SMOOTHLY WE WANT
PEOPLE TO PARTICIPATE IN OUR
DEMOCRACY AND I HEARD AND I.
SENATOR NIELSEN. THAT PRESIDENT
LADIES AND DOWN THE SENATE NOT
SURE TALK A LITTLE BIT ABOUT
THE UNIVERSE WE'RE DEALING WITH
HERE. THEY INCLUDE MURDERS.
VOLUNTARY MANSLAUGHTER RAPE
SODOMY. YES AND. LEWD
LASCIVIOUS WITH THE CHILD. THIS
IS THE PART OF THOSE WHO ARE
CONVICTED. THAT WOULD BE IN
THIS UNIVERSE THAT THOUGH MY
GOSH THEY SHOULD VOTE. WELL
WHEN YOU TALK ABOUT THE SHOE.
CRIMINAL INJUSTICE BILLS AND
BEGINNING TO CALL THEM. THINK
ABOUT THE VICTIMS AND THEIR
FAMILIES AND THE CHILDREN. AND
YOUR OWN FAMILY WHO WILL BE THE
PROPENSITY TO HAVE BE
VICTIMIZED BY SOME OF THESE
INDIVIDUALS. NOW LET'S TALK
ABOUT WHAT IS PAROLE PEARL
DOESN'T MEAN THAT ON OCCASION
WHEN YOU THENRELEASED FROM
CUSTODY. THEN YOU HAVE IN MANY
CASES NOW ALTHOUGH IT'S BEING
PRETTY WELL ABOLISHED IN ITSELF
ALREADY PEARL BUT THE DEGREE
THAT WE HAVE PEARL. AND THIS IS
FROM THOSE WHO DO THE MOST
HEINOUS CRIMES OF FIVE JUST
MENTION. A PART OF THEIR
SENTENCE INCLUDES THE PAROLE
PERIOD. OF THE JUDGMENT THE
FREE SOCIETY. TO SEE IF DAY
HAVE REHABILITATED SUFFICIENTLY.
TO BE ABLE TO BE SAFE RISKS.
AND THERE CAN BE APPEARED IT
WERE IN THERE ARE UNDER SUPER
AND SUBJECTED TO CONSEQUENCES
FOR THEIR BEHAVIORS. HOW MANY
TIMES A DAY DO WE HEAR ABOUT
PAROLEES OR EARLY RELEASES.
COMMITTING HEINOUS CRIMES IT'S
BECOME COMMONPLACE NOW. UNDER
OUR NEW CRIMINAL JUSTICE SO
CALLED REFORM. AND IT IS ABOUT
JUSTICE JUSTICE JUST DESSERTS.
FOR THOSE WHO COMMIT CRIMES
PROTECTOR THE HEINOUS CRIMES.
PART OF THEIR SENTENCE IS TO
COMPLETE THE PAROLE PERIOD THEY
ARE NOT A- TERMINATED FROM
THEIR QUOTE SENTENCE UNTIL SUCH
TIME AS THERE FORMALLY
DISCHARGED BY A FORMAL ACTION.
OF DISCHARGE FROM PEARL. AFTER
THAT I'M WILLING TO HAVE A
CONVERSATION. BUT THEY HAVEN'T
SERVED THEIR TIME. AND WHAT'S
GONNA BE NEXT. WELL I THINK
THOSE IN WHO ARE STILL
INCARCERATED THERE WILL BE AN
ATTEMPT TO GIVE THEM THE VOTE
TO ABSENTEE MAYBE. MAYBE NOT
MAYBE WILL HAVE TO GIVE THEM AN
EARLY RELEASE SO THEY CAN VOTE.
I HATE TO BE FACETIOUS ABOUT IT
BUT I'M GETTING A LITTLE BIT
TIRED OF THIS GUY'S OF CRIMINAL
JUSTICE REFORM. THE PERFECT
CHOICE ON SOCIETY. AS WELL AS
THE VICTIMS GREAT INJUSTICES.
THE GRIEVING VICTIM THERE'S NO
CLOSURE THEY DON'T EVER GET
OVER IT. THAT'S A LAUGH I'VE
DEALT WITH FAR TOO MANY VICTIMS
LADIES AND GENTLEMAN. TO KNOW
THEY DON'T GET OVER IT SOME IN
MADE ADVOCATE TO SAID THAT THEY
JUST HAVE TO GET OVER A- BOWL
RAPED AND MURDERED. I DON'T
THINK SO. AND I'M GONNA HAVE TO
REALLY HARD WITH ONE I'VE USE
ONCE HERE BEFORE BUT IT'S DEEP
IN MY HEART. BEFORE WE HAD
ANOTHER ONE OF THESE KIND OF
BILLS. JUST A FEW YEARS AGO. I
HAD A DREAM. AND WOKE UP IN THE
NIGHT. THERE WAS A YOUNG WOMAN.
WHO'S CRYING OUT TO ME FROM THE
GRAVE. DO YOU KNOW WHAT HE DID
TO ME. WELL SADLY I SAY I DO
NOT. AND WHAT DID SHE DESERVE.
WHAT DID HER FAMILY DESERVE.
JUSTICE FOR THE ONE WHO
PERPETRATED THAT ON HER. NOW
WE'RE GOING TO GIVE THESE FOLKS
EARLY RELEASE. AND WE'RE GONNA
LEARN TO VOTE. I THINK NOT I
VIGOROUSLY URGE A NO VOTE.
SENATOR MITCHELL. THANK YOU IN
A PRESIDENT ON. INDEED. AS A
MEMBER WHO HAS CARRIED A NUMBER
OF BILLS TO RIGHT SIZE THE
CRIMINAL JUSTICE SYSTEM TO
RIGHT SIZE THE JUVENILE JUSTICE
SYSTEM NEVER HAVE I ONCE STOOD
ON THE FLOOR AND SAID THAT A
VICTIM SHOULD GET OVER IT NOT
ONCE. I THINK IT'S IMPORTANT
THAT WE FOCUS ON THE CONTENT OF
THE BILL. THE BILL HAS NOTHING
TO DO WITH EARLY RELEASE. THIS
BILL SAYS ONCE YOU HAVE PAID
YOUR DEBT TO SOCIETY. AND HAVE
RETURNED TO SOCIETY. TO WORK
AND PAY TAXES AND CONTRIBUTE.
THAT YOU SHOULD ALSO HAVE THE
RIGHT TO VOICE YOUR OPINION
ABOUT YOUR ELECTED
REPRESENTATIVES BASED ON WHERE
YOU LIVE. THAT'S THE FOCUS OF A
FEE A FIX. IN BECAUSE THAT'S
THE FOCUS OF A FEE A FIX AND I
BELIEVE THAT PEOPLE SHOULD HAVE
THAT RIGHT. LIVING IN COMMUNITY
PAYING TAXES SENDING THEIR
CHILDREN TO SCHOOL. I WILL BE
SUPPORTING IT TODAY AND I HOPE
THAT OTHERS WOULD BE CLEAR
ABOUT THE NATURE OF THIS BILL.
YOU WE ALL MAY HAVE DIFFERENT
OPINIONS ABOUT. THE CRIMINAL
JUSTICE SYSTEM AND WHETHER THE
PEOPLE IN IT DESERVE ANY RIGHTS
AT ALL. BUT AGAIN THE UPON
RELEASE. HOW DO WE EXPECT
PEOPLE WHO ARE RELEASED TO
RETURN TO CIVILITY. WE'RE NOT
GOING TO TREAT HIM AS SUCH. AND
VOTING FOR OUR PERSPECTIVE
THANKS TO THE BILL OF RIGHTS.
AND THE US CONSTITUTION IS AN
INALIENABLE RIGHT. AND THIS
POPULATION SHOULD BE GIVEN THAT
OPPORTUNITY I'LL BE SUPPORTING
A CA SIX. SENATOR BURGESS.
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT I
THINK. WE'VE HEARD A NUMBER OF
SPEAKERS MENTION PAYING BACK
THE DEBT TO SOCIETY HELLO
BELABOR THIS POINT BECAUSE I
THINK IT WAS WELL ARTICULATED
BY MY COLLEAGUE. I'M CENTRAL
VALLEY. AT FROM ILLEGAL SO
PAYING YOUR DEBT. NECESSARILY
AND- OFFER FILLING THE PERIOD
OF TIME DURING THE PROBATION OR
PAROLE. I WON'T SPEND TOO MUCH
TIME ON THAT BUT I THINK ONE
THING THAT WE MAY BE OVER
LOOKING HERE. IS THAT THE JAIL
SYSTEM THROUGH REALIGNMENT
THROUGH A NUMBER OF PIECES OF
LEGISLATION. HAS DRAMATICALLY
SCALE BACK THE TIME THE PEOPLE
ARE SPENDING IN JAILS OR EVEN
IN PRISONS- ARE FOR THAT MATTER.
SO WHEN YOU HAVE IT IN
ADMINISTRATIVE IN POSITION-
WEATHERBY BY LAW OR- BUDGET.
THAT REDUCES THE AMOUNT OF TIME
THAT PEOPLE ARE SERVING. FOR
PURPOSES OF A SENTENCE. AND
BEING PUT BACK INTO- SOCIETY IN
RELIEF AND EARLY PERIOD OF TIME
ON THE CONDITION OF PAROLE.
THEY'RE SATISFYING REGIONAL.
BOB OF THEIR SENTENCE THE
DISALLOW THE VOTE TO OCCUR ONE
IS GOING THE ORIGINAL SENTENCE.
INTO THE POST SENS OBLIGATIONS
OF PAROLE WERE SHORT CUTTING IT
UNDER THIS GUY'S AT THE
BOARDING SET THOSE CONDITIONS
TO COMMUNITY AND THAT'S JUST
OFF BACK ACCURATE. SO SOME OF
US ARE LOOK AT IT AS A CIVIL
RIGHTS IS. I IT OR EVEN JUSTICE
FOR THAT MATTER. I WOULD JUST
FOR THE FALL TWO WHAT ARE THE
TERMS THE CAN. IN THE JUSTICE
SYSTEM NEED TO BE RESTORED ALL
OF THE RIGHTS AFTER HAVING
SERVED DESCENDS FOR THAT AFTER
HAVING SERVED A PAROLE AND THAT
BE THE GUIDING FRAMEWORK. THING
NO FURTHER DISCUSSION OR DEBATE
SENATOR BRADFORD YOU MAKE CLUED.
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT I'M
ALWAYS AMAZED WHEN IT COMES TO.
PROVIDING OPPORTUNITIES IN THIS
CHAMBER AND THE STATE IN THIS
COUNTRY TO PEOPLE WHO HAVE
SERVED THEIR TIME PAID THEIR
DEBT TO SOCIETY BUT YOU WANT
THEM TO. SERVE A LIFE SENTENCE.
YOU WANT THEM TO. BEAR THE MARK
OF A FELON BURKE CONVICTED
FELON FOR THE REST OF THEIR
LIVES BUT WE ALWAYS TALK ABOUT
REHABILITATION WE SPEND
BILLIONS OF DOLLARS ON OUR
PRISON SYSTEM WITH INTENTIONS
AND THE PURPOSE OF A
REHABILITATING. YEAH ONCE
RELEASED YOU STILL WANT TO
TREAT ON LIKE A COMMON.
CRIMINAL IT'S AMAZING I WONDER
IF. MY COLLEAGUES WITH A POLLS
ROGER STONE OR MIKE LAND OR
MICHAEL COLE AND FROM THEIR
RIGHT TO VOTE ALL CONVICTED
FELONS BUT I'M PRETTY SURE THEY
WILL BE VOTING VERY SOON
PROBABLY IN THIS UPCOMING
ELECTION HE WON'T HAVE ANY
PROBLEMS WITH THAT. BUT WE
ALWAYS WANT TO. FEAR MONGER AND
DRAW THE WORST SCENARIOS I SURE
YOU THE AVERAGE MURDER OR RAPE
IS. OUT OF PRISON THE LAST
THING THEY PRIDE THING ABOUT IS
RUSHING TO THE POLLS AND VOTING
BUT THIS IS PART OF THE VOTER
FRAUD THAT WE'VE BEEN
PROPAGATING FOR THE PAST THREE
YEARS. OF HOW THIS TAKES NEXT
IS THE FAR THIS THING FROM THE
TRUTH. PEOPLE WHO GO TO POLLS
ARE PEOPLE WHO ARE CONCERNED
ABOUT THEIR COMMUNITIES THEY'RE
CONCERNED ABOUT THEIR SCHOOLS
THEY'RE CONCERNED ABOUT YOUR
CHILDREN. BUT I CHALLENGE YOU
AGAIN. IF THIS IS ONE OF YOUR
RELATIVES PRETTY SURE YOU WOULD
SAY. THAT IS OUR TO VOTE.
THEY'RE ONE OF YOUR FRIENDS-
YEAH THEY'VE BEEN REHABILITATED
THEY DESERVE THE VOTE. BUT WHEN
IT'S BLACK AND BROWN PEOPLE
WHEN IT'S POOR PEOPLE. THERE
MARK FOR LIFE IN A HALF TO. AND
MANY PEOPLE DIE SIR ALIVE SO.
THE IS JUST OUTRAGEOUS IT'S
LONG OVER. WE HAVE TO WITH
SPOKE. NO CRIME ARE RUN OUT
TRYING TO VOTE. WHO WHO ARE CAN
CONCERNED THE COMMUNITY. THIS
IS ABOUT RE ENTER. BEING I CAN.
POSITIVE ROLE MODEL
CONTRIBUTING MEMBER TO SEE. AND
VOTING IS ONE OF THE EASIEST
WAYS THEY CAN DEMONSTRATE THAT
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR A VOTE.
MADAM SO PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ALAN WHAT IF YOU COULD. HOLD ON
FOR A SECOND NAY FOR WHAT
REASON DO YOU RICE. THIS. A LOT
OF THE MY REMARK JUST NAY.
THANK YOU SIR. PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. ALLEN I ARCHULETA I
ATKINS I BATES NO BELL HI
GORGEOUS NO BRADFORD. I COME BY
ADAM I CHIANG NO VALLEY NO DODD.
I THERE ARE SO. I GALGIANI AYE
GLAZER. GONZALEZ I GROWTH.
HERTZBERG I HILL I HUESO I-
TADO. JACKSON I JONES. NO LEYVA.
I MCGUIRE AYE MELINDA'S. NO
MITCHELL I MONNING FIVE MORE
LONG. MORALE NO NIELSEN NO HAN
I PORTANTINO AYE ROTH. I RUBIO
I SKINNER. I STERN I NUMBER
FIVE WACO SKI I WIENER I WILK.
HI PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS. CLICK HERE. GROWTH
TADO. MORE LOCK. PLEASE CALL
THE ABSENT MEMBERS GLAZER.
GROWTH NO TADO. BUT IT WASN'T
MORE LOCK. PRICE. TWENTY EIGHT
KNOWS NINE THE MEASURE PASSED.
MEMBERS THAT CONCLUDES THE
ASSEMBLY THIRD READING MOVING
ON TO THE SPECIAL CONSENT
CALENDAR ITEMS EIGHTY ONE
THROUGH ONE OH TWO WITH ANY
MEMBER LIKE A ITEM MOVE FOR
SEPARATE THE QUESTION. ON THE
WEST HUESO. MADAM CHAIR YES IF
I COULD ASK THAT ITEM. I THINK
THAT- SORRY HERE LET ME JUST SO
ITEM- NINETY SEVEN SB TWELVE
THIRTY EIGHT BE REMOVED FROM
THE CASSETTE PLEASE. SB TWELVE
THIRTY. NUMBER SEVEN NINETY
SEVEN. ANYONE ELSE. SAYING NO
ONE ELSE- MADAM SECRETARY
PLEASE READ. SENATE BILL.
895-907-9219 891-024-1250.
580-387-8880. FOUR NINE TWENTY
NINE THIRTY FOUR TEN TWO OF
ELEVEN FIFTEEN AND TWENTY HELLO
THE SIX OH EIGHTY NINE TWELVE
FIFTEEN IN TWELVE NINETY.
THIRTEEN EIGHTY FOURTEEN FIFTY
AN AT THE BELL SEVEN FOUR.
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. NUMBER
EIGHTY ONE. ALLEN. I ARCHULETA
I ATKINS I BATES AYE BELL HI
GORGEOUS I BRADFORD I HAVE I
ADAM I CHIANG. HI DOLLY I DODD.
I RAZA I GALGIANI FIVE GLAZER I
GONZALEZ I GROWTH FIVE
HERTZBERG. HI HILL I HUESO
WHILE I TADO. I JACKSON I JONES.
I LEYVA. I MCGUIRE. MELENDEZ I
MITCHELL I MONNING. I MORE LOCK
I MORALE I NIELSEN. I PAN FIVE
PORTANTINO I ROTH. I RUBIO.
FIVE SKINNER I STERN. NUMBER HI
MY CAO SKI FIVE WIENER. I WILK
HI THIS CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS.
MCGUIRE I STERN. I THIRTY NINE
NO ZERO THE MEASURE PASSED THE
CONSENT CALENDAR IS PASSED. IS
APPROVED- IF THERE IS NO OTHER
BUSINESS SAYING MAN ARE CENTER
BRADFORD FOR WHAT PURPOSE DO
RISE OCT COMPACT MOTIONS AND
RESOLUTIONS. SO ORDERED THANK
YOU I REQUEST AB EIGHT FOUR SIX.
REMOVED FROM THE ENACT A FILE
AT THE REQUEST OF THE AUTHOR.
THE WORD SENATOR MITCHELL AND
THE COMMITTEE ANNOUNCEMENTS ITS
MA'AM AT THE REQUEST OF THE OUT
REPUBLICAN CAUCUS I'M HAPPY TO
DELAY THE START OF THE BUDGET
COMMITTEE GIVE THEM ADDITIONAL
TIME TO PREPARE AND SO WILL
BEGIN AT THREE FIFTEEN. SO
ORDERED THANK YOU ANYONE ELSE
WELL. SENATOR ATKINS THE DESK
IS CLEAR. DEMAND PRESIDENT
THANK YOU VERY MUCH- PROBABLY
STE YOU OBVIOUSLY IT WAS ARE A
FEW HOURS AND WE DIDN'T GET AS
MUCH DONE AS WE PROBABLY WOULD
HAVE LIKED BUT WHAT WE
ACCOMPLISHED I THINK WAS
SIGNIFICANT- BUT WE WILL BE
VERY BUSY TOMORROW- AND OF
COURSE E HAVE BUDGET THIS
AFTERNOON SO IT IS. IMPORTANT
THAT WE WRAP UP HERE SO THE
BUDGET COMMITTEE CAN MEET AND
PEOPLE HAVE THE ABILITY OF
MEMBERS HAVE THE ABILITY TO DO
THE WORKGOING TO THE BUDGET
CAN BE TOMORROW WILL BE A VERY
HEY. WITH THE INTENTION AND
HOPE THAT WE WRAP THINGS UP
TOMORROW NIGHT AND WE CAN GO
HOME AND BE HOME ON FRIDAY AND
FOR THE WEEKEND THAT IS THE
GOAL- BUT THAT WILL DEPEND ON
US TOMORROW- HAVEN'T SAID THAT
OUR NEXT FLOOR SESSION WILL BE
TOMORROW THURSDAY JUNE FIFTH AT
TWENTY FIFTH TWENTY TWENTY. ARE
STARTING AT TEN AM SHARP THANK
YOU MADAM PRESIDENT. THANK YOU.
THE SENATE WILL BE IN RECESS.
WE WILL RECONVENE THURSDAY AT
TEN AM.